ORDER OF THE ASSEMBLY
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE --
WE'RE GONNA START AS A SUB
COMMITTEE IN THOSE WE DON'T HAVE
A QUORUM.
ONCE WE DO ESTABLISH A QUORUM
THE MOVE ON TO A POINT BUT WE DO
HAVE AN AUTHOR -- PROCEDURES
AUTHORED MISTER.
HOLDEN.
SO WILL THIS ROLE WOULD YOU
PLEASE COME FORWARD AND WE'LL BE
SEEING -- TOTALLY.
SIX AB TWELVE TWENTY SIX PLEASE
PROCEED WITH YOUR RESEARCH.
A RESEARCHER AND MEMBERS OF FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT AB --
TWELVE TWENTY SIX I WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO THANK THE STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH OUR STAFF AND
HOPING -- TO MAKE THIS A BETTER
BILL.
CALIFORNIA IS FACING A CRIPPLING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SHORTAGE AND
HAS THE LARGEST POPULATION OF ON
SHELTER PEOPLE IN THE NATION.
AS OF THIS YEAR HUNDRED THIRTY
THOUSAND CALIFORNIA'S DO NOT
HAVE A HOME.
LOS ANGELES COUNTY ALONE
RECORDED FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
THE HIGH COST OF LIVING IN
CALIFORNIA MAKES IT NEARLY
IMPOSSIBLE FOR SOMEONE.
THAT HAS LOST HER HOME TO FIND
ALTERNATIVE HOUSING IN THEIR
SAME NEIGHBORHOOD.
IN ORDER TO ADDRESS RAPID
HOMELESSNESS IN OUR STATE WE
MUST EXPLORE ALL TOOLS AVAILABLE
TO US.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE TWENTY SIX
WILL STUDY THE FEASIBILITY OF
BUILDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
RESIDENTIAL HOUSING.
OVER BELOW GRADE HIGHWAYS.
THIS WILL ALLOW VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS TO STAY ROOTED IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES.
THEY CALL HOME I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR THANK YOU MISTER WILL
NEARLY WITNESSES WORK -- NO.
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THEY
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THE AUTHORS BILL [inaudible]
SIGNALLY.
AB MEMBERS THE PUBLIC THIRTY
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OR
HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE AUTHORS
BILL [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
ANY QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MR ONLY LIKE CLOSE.
RESPECT MASTER LEVEL.
WE STRONGLY THE ROLL OPEN -- FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS AND FOUR TWO OF
OTIS'S UNIFORM.
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU
[inaudible]
OKAY
.
SO TAKE A FEW MINUTES IN -- AS A
SERVICE CALL -- THE AUTHORS IN
THEIR OFFICES WILL BE TAKEN WILL
PAUSE.
BECAUSE TO HIS MOTHER'S
[inaudible]
SUCH.
THIS IS A
CAN
[inaudible]
THE BILL
REPORTER.
MS RACE ARE YOU READY FOR AB.
ONE SEVENTY NINE GOOD AFTERNOON
PLEASE START WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
TODAY PRESENT AB ONE SEVENTY
NINE A BILL TO ADDRESS ISSUES
RELATING TO THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN CALIFORNIA.
NEW CAR DEALERS AND AUTOMAKERS.
AB ONE SEVENTY NINE UPDATES THE
LAWS.
GOVERNING THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN AUTOMOBILE MANUFACTURERS
AND FRANCHISE NEW CAR DEALERS TO
BRING EQUITY TO THIS VITAL
RELATIONSHIP.
THE NEW CAR DEALERS OPERATING AS
LOCAL INDEPENDENTLY OWNED
FRANCHISED DEALERSHIPS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
CREATE JOBS.
AND HELP SPUR LOCAL ECONOMIC
GROWTH.
THEY'RE OFF TO THE FIRST POINT
OF CONTACT BETWEEN THE CONSUMER
AT A SPECIFIC CAR BRAND.
THE OTHER INDUSTRY IN THE
ECONOMIC BENEFITS OF AUTOMOBILE
SALES WITH THAT SOME LIMITED
EXCEPTIONS RELY ON THE FRANCHISE
SYSTEM BETWEEN THE AUTOMAKERS
AND DEALERS.
THIS IS WHY IT IS IMPORTANT TO
ENSURE THAT THE BALANCE OF POWER
BETWEEN LARGE MANUFACTURE.
LARGE MOST MULTINATIONAL AUTO
MAKERS AND CALIFORNIA'S NEW CAR
DEALERS IS FAIR AND PROVIDES A
COMPETITIVE PLAYING FIELD.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR.
FOR HIS EFFORTS TO ENGAGE ON
THIS ISSUE TO BRING ALL
STAKEHOLDERS TO THE NEGOTIATION
TABLE.
AFTER TWO ROBUST MEETINGS LAST
WEEK BETWEEN THE SPONSORS
OPPONENTS AND OUR RESPECTIVE
STAFFS WE HAVE MADE SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS.
SPECIFICALLY WE HAVE AGREED TO
REMOVE THE WISCONSIN WARRANTY
FORMULA.
APPROACH CURRENTLY IN THE BILL
AND ESTABLISH AN ALTERNATIVE
PROCESS THAT WILL WORK FOR BOTH
DEALERS AND AUTOMATE AUTOMAKERS.
REMOVING THIS FORMULA IS A
SIGNIFICANT CONCESSION.
BUT WE BELIEVE.
IT IS ONE THAT WILL PAY OFF IN
THE LONG RUN AS WE ESTABLISH A
TRANSPARENT AND EQUITABLE
PROCESS TO DETERMINE WARRANTY
REIMBURSEMENT RATES. FOR THE
MORE AUTOMAKERS HAVE REQUESTED A
ROOM A MECHANISM TO VERIFY THE
RETAIL.
REBATES SUBMITTED BY DEALERS AND
WE ARE WORKING IN GOOD FAITH TO
ARRIVE AT A SOLUTION.
THE BILL BEFORE YOU TODAY IS THE
SAME BILL THAT WAS SENT TO THE
GOVERNOR LAST YEAR BOUGHT WE
HAVE MADE SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS
IN OUR RECENT NEGOTIATIONS.
AND I ASK YOU TODAY TO VOTE TO
MOVE THIS BILL FORWARD SO WE CAN
CONTINUE TO MAKE THAT PROGRESS
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SO REMEMBER YOU HAVE
WITNESSES INSIDE YOUR BILL.
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME WHO
YOU'RE REPRESENTING PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR CLIFF
ACOSTA ME HALF THE CALIFORNIA
NEW CAR DEALERS ASSOCIATION I
WON'T REPEAT ANYTHING -- ARE
WONDERFUL AUTHORS JUST SAID I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO TAKE I THANK
THE CHAIR AND HIS STAFF FOR
SPENDING SIGNIFICANT TIME WITH
US AND FOR HELPING BRING ALL
STAKEHOLDERS TO THE NEGOTIATION
TABLE -- WE HAVE.
MADE PROGRESS WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO MAKE PROGRESS TODAY
AND FOR THAT I HAD.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU TO VOTE I
AM SO THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO
MAKE THOSE PROGRESS AND
HOPEFULLY HAVE A PRODUCT FOR YOU
ON THE FLOOR THAT IS BETTER THAN.
THE BILL IS CURRENTLY.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE THE CHAIR
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE CHAMP THE
MARS SENIOR BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MOTORCYCLE DEALERS
ASSOCIATION AND MORE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT.
OF THE AUTHORS BILL.
MATT BROUGHT FOR THE MACHINE
ISN'T SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC FEEL
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OR
HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE AUTHORS
BILL.
PLEASE COME UP SHERMAN.
STATE YOUR NAME AND WHO YOU'RE
REPRESENTING PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE JOHN
MOFFITT ON BEHALF OF THE
ALLIANCE OF AUTOMOBILE
MANUFACTURERS.
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE BILL -- WE
ALSO APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE
CHAIR THE WORK OF THE COMMITTEE
STAFF -- AND AGREE THAT OUR LAST
WEEK AND A HALF OF DISCUSSIONS
HAVE BEEN PRODUCTIVE -- WE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR STATEMENT
THAT THE WISCONSIN FORMULA
CURRENTLY IN THE BILL AND PRINT
WILL COME OUT.
AND WE ARE WORKING TOGETHER TO
SEE IF WE CAN -- FIND A BETTER
PLACE TO LAND ON WARRANTY
REIMBURSEMENT RATES MOVING
FORWARD HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA -- WE APPRECIATE THE
FACT THAT THAT -- FOLKS ARE
BACKING AWAY FROM THAT
PARTICULAR FORMULA -- I THINK
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE YOU KNOW
THE BILL IS -- AND AND WHERE WE
ARE IN THE NEGOTIATIONS AT THIS
POINT OF THE RESULT OF
CONCESSIONS ON BOTH SIDES -- YOU
KNOW WHEN WHEN NEGOTIATIONS
BROKE DOWN LAST AUGUST WE HAD A
LIST OF ABOUT TWENTY FOUR ISSUES.
WITH THIS BILL.
WE HAVE ACQUIESCED ON TWENTY OF
THEM.
AND AND AND ARE NO LONGER
RAISING ISSUES ON THOSE BILLS
AND THERE'S A HANDFUL OF ISSUES
THAT ARE LEFT ALL SORT OF
CENTERED AROUND THE SAME ISSUE.
AND AND GOVERNOR BROWN TO VETO
THE PREVIOUS BILL -- BUT WE ARE
WORKING IN IN GOOD FAITH AND WE
ARE HOPEFUL.
THAT WE CAN COME TO SOME SORT OF
ACCOMMODATION MOVING FORWARD
THAT IS CERTAINLY MORE
REASONABLE THAN WHAT IS IN THE
BILL RIGHT NOW.
THIS ONE IS PLEASE.
MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS CHRISTMAS OUR ON BEHALF
OF THE ASSOCIATION OF GLOBAL
AUTOMAKERS -- WILL CONCUR WITH
MISTER MOFFETT SO -- REMARKS AND
SAY THAT WE HAVE INDEED HAD.
SOME -- PRODUCTIVE --
DISCUSSIONS LAST WEEK AND A HALF --
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
DISCUSSIONS AND HOPEFULLY
PUTTING THIS THE REST.
IN THE NEAR FUTURE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
THE AUTHORS BILL OR HAVE
CONCERNS.
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR.
THIS RACE WAS REALLY CLOSE.
AGAIN I WOULD LIKE TO PUBLICLY
NOTED THAT ALL THE HARD WORK
FROM THE CHAIR AND STAFF -- IN
GETTING TO WHERE WE ARE TODAY
AND I KNOW THAT.
THOSE EFFORTS ALONG WITH THE
GOOD FAITH -- DISCUSSIONS
BETWEEN THE STAKEHOLDERS.
I THINK IT'S GOING TO LEAD US.
TO THE BEST BILL.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE AYE VOTE [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES -- I WANT
TO REALLY DO WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PERSISTENCE.
ON THE CITY HE WILLINGNESS TO
WORK WITH ME.
ON MOVING THE BALL FORWARD.
I THINK THAT WE HAVE -- ALL OF
THIS THE BEST INTENTIONS FOR
BOTH PARTIES.
AND MAKING SURE THAT.
A COUPON COMPROMISE CAN ACTUALLY
[inaudible]
OCCUR -- WE'LL TAKE BOTH PARTIES.
THE HUMAN.
EXCEPTIONAL IN YOUR WORK TRYING
TO COME TOGETHER.
THE MANUFACTURERS OF THE DEALERS --
BECAUSE I REALLY DON'T SEE IS
BILLION [inaudible]
OKAY.
WE ARE IN THAT SENTIMENT.
SO -- I WAS GONNA READ THE VETO
MESSAGE AND AND AND AND BUT YOU
KNOW I I REALLY DO URGE BOTH
PARTIES TO CONTINUE TO WORK.
TOGETHER AND MOVE THIS THING
FORWARD -- I LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING THE MINUTES YOU HAVE
DISCUSSED IN PRINT I WOULD HOPE.
THAT WE HAD GOTTEN FURTHER -- SO
I'M GOING -- TO HOLD MY VOTE
TODAY JUST -- TO BE ABLE TO
RESERVE THE RIGHT TO BE ABLE --
TO MAKE IT AN APPROPRIATE VOTE
ON THE FLOOR IT AS I SEE IT --
AND ALSO RESERVE THE RIGHT FOR
SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TWO IF I
DON'T LIKE.
AND SO.
WE I DON'T THINK WE HAVE A
QUORUM YET SO -- THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND CERTAINLY THE ROLL
OPEN -- FOR THE I THINK THAT WE
GET A QUORUM.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GET.
YOUR SECOND BILL YES SO FOR THAT --
OF WE'RE GONNA GO TO AB.
FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR IN NUMBERS.
BEFORE YOU IS AB FOURTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN A SIMPLE BILL WHICH
PROPOSES TO DISSOLVE THE
EXISTING ON THE TRANSIT JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITY.
AND REFORM IT INTO ON THE TRANS
SPECIAL TRANSIT DISTRICT.
ON THE TRANS IS THE PUBLIC
TRANSIT AGENCY THAT WAS FORMED
IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX CURRENTLY
IT OFFERS PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
THROUGHOUT DECEMBER TO DO YOU
KNOW VALLEY.
SERVING CITIES INCLUDING COLTON
FONTANA GRANT TERRACE REAL TWIN
SAMPOERNA DO YOU KNOW ALL OF
WHICH ARE IN MY DISTRICT.
CERTAINLY ON THE TRANS IS
LOOKING TO EXPAND ITS SERVICES.
INCLUDING TO THE REDLANDS
PASSENGER RAIL PROJECT IN.
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE THE
REDLANDS PASSENGER RAIL PROJECT
ISN'T DANCED REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION PROJECT DESIGNED
TO CONNECT RESIDENTS BUSINESSES
AND VISITORS TO A VARIETY OF
DESTINATIONS FOR LEISURE
EDUCATION.
AND HEALTH CARE AS WELL AS
OTHERS OTHER REASONS.
IN ADDITION THEY WILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO BE THE FIRST
RAIL PROJECT IN NORTH AMERICA TO
TEST THE BATTERY POWER TRAIN
FURTHERING OUR CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION GOALS.
SIMPLY AB FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN
WILL CREATE ON THE TRANS SPECIAL
DISTRICT IN ORDER TO BE BETTER
ABLE TO PROVIDE A NEW INNOVATIVE
AND VITAL TRANSPORTATION SERVICE
TO THE INLAND EMPIRE.
I HAVE AND WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH A HOST OF STAKEHOLDERS TO
ENSURE THIS TRANSITION IS ONE
THAT IS CONSISTENT WITH OTHER
SPECIAL DISTRICT TRANSFERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
HERE TO TESTIFY -- WITH ME IS
CYRUS DEVERS ON BEHALF OF ON THE
TRANS.
THANK YOU.
MISTER MEMBER SOLVE -- CONFINE
MY COMMENTS TO THE STATE OF
NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE LA IS
OPPOSITION MEDICAMENT WITH THE
CONTRACTORS WE HAVE CLOSED WITH
THEM WE WERE ABLE TO AFTER
TALKING ABOUT IT WE CAN ACCEPT
THEIR LANGUAGE SO I'VE
COMMUNICATED THAT TO THEM THAT --
THEIR LANGUAGE IS ACCEPTABLE NOW
TAMI TRENDS WITH THE CAL LAB
COAT WE HAD TO DISCUSSIONS AND
WE HAVE DIFFERENT ISSUES WE SEE
NO PROBLEMS WORKING THIS OUT BUT
WE DO NEED TIME TO HASH OUT THE
LANGUAGE IS NOT SIMPLE LANGUAGE
EVEN THOUGH THE CONCEPTS WERE
WORKING ON ARE NOT.
IN CONFLICT THEY'RE LOOKING
SPHERE OF INTEREST WE'RE LOOKING
AT ISSUES AROUND FORMATION AND
DISSOLUTION AND AGREEMENTS THAT
ARE ALREADY IN PLACE REGARDING
DISSOLUTION SO REALLY WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT DIFFERENT ISSUES
WE JUST NEED A MOMENT WORK OUT
LANGUAGE WE THINK WE CAN KNOCK
THIS OUT. FOR WE GET OUR PROBES
I THINK YOU DO.
THE OTHER MEMBERS THE PUBLIC
PLACE -- TO TEST FIND SUPPORT OF
THE AUTHORS BILL.
CHAIR MEMBERS TRUST NOT THE ON
HAVE THE SAME PER DAY OKAY
TRANSITION THIRTY IN SUPPORT.
Q..
ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NINETY ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC FEEL LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF CONCERNS WITH THE
AUTHORS BILL.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE PAMELA MILLER
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LEFT COAST.
AND A WE HAVE A AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION AND ARE POLICY
ISSUES RELATE TO GOVERNMENT'S
NOT TRANSPORTATION -- SO I WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND THE
SPONSOR FOR CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH US IN ADDRESSING OUR
CONCERNS -- AND WE SHARE THE
SAME OPTIMISM AS THE SPONSOR
THAT TIRE WE WILL WORK THROUGH
THOSE ISSUES SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
LET'S TAKE THIS THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS TAUGHT BLOOM STEIN
FOR THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION.
WE DO HAVE AN OPPOSE LESS
AMENDED POSITION -- WE HAVE
NEGOTIATED WITH THE SPONSORS AS
WELL THE AUTHORS OFFICE -- ONCE
THE BILL'S IMPRINT WITH OUR
CHANGES WILL REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION LIKELY BE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
ANY QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE OF
THE AUTHOR.
SEEING NONE.
WE SHOULD CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ONCE YOU
HAVE A QUORUM.
THANK YOU MISS REYES WILL BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY AND
IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU'RE WORKING
OUT WITH THE OPPOSITION ON SOME
OUTSTANDING ISSUES.
PLEASE KEEP COMMITTEE INFORMED
OF YOUR PROGRESS.
AND LOOK FORWARD TO POSITIVE
RESULT FOR YOU BUT I THANK --
YOUR WITNESS AND YOUR
PERSISTENCE ON MOVING FORWARD
GOING.
THANK YOU ON THAT SO WHEN WE DO
GET A FORM WE WILL -- WITH THAT --
THANK YOU.
YEAH.
A MISTER SANTIAGO.
I THINK IT WAS UNFAIR NOTICES
THE HEAVY WORKLOAD WITH
ENTERPRISE BE BRIEF.
AB TWO THIRTY EIGHT SIR.
I'LL REMIND YOU THAT YOU ARE
SUPPORT.
IT WOULD SIMPLY EXTEND THE
SUNSET DATE TO TWENTY TWENTY
THREE SIR.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GAVIN THE
QUEUE.
ON BEHALF OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AUDITOR'S MAILERS
ASSOCIATION -- WE SUPPORT THE
BILL THISBEEN A SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAM FOR THE LAST YEAR AND A
HALF TWO YEARS.
AND WE SUPPORTED GOING FORWARD
AND ARE ALSO LOOKING FORWARD TO
GETTING RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT ON HOW WE CAN ADDRESS
MORE FURTHER DRESSES PROBLEM.
OF AN LICENSES MANLY THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS NOT
DESIRING TO BE HAPPY CALIFORNIA
AUDITOR'S MAILERS RECYCLERS
ALLIANCES STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
ANY MEMBERS THE PUBLIC WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
THE AUTHORS BILL OR HAVE
CONCERNS.
SEEING NONE.
MISTER -- SEAL INCOME A
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE.
ASSEMBLY -- PERSPECTIVE THAT'S
RIGHT.
MR SANTIAGO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD TODAY
I WILL SUPPORT BILL TODAY BUT
WANT TO STATE FOR THE RECORD
THAT -- TO DMV THAT THE FOUR
MONTHS WAIT TIME ON THIS REPORT
IS.
UNACCEPTABLE -- THE DMV SHOULD
RELEASE A REPORT BEFORE THIS
BILLS FOR THE SENATE -- WITH
THAT -- GOING FORWARD I MEAN WE
HAVE A LOT OF EXTRA MONEY IN
AUGUST.
AND THEY'RE STILL NOT COMPLETING
THE ROLE -- WE WE DO GET A
QUORUM WE WILL PUT THE BUILT.
AND ALL THESE ROLE CAN HELP FOR
AB TWO MEMBERS THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER [inaudible]
MR.
TO THOSE MESSAGES FIRST.
FILERS DIFFER.
GOOD FOR OKAY [inaudible]
OKAY.
I WOULD TO FORM THE COULD HAVE.
MISTER CELIS PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
YOU WERE AVAILABLE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I KEEP THIS BRIEF IN
LIGHT OF YOUR LONG AGENDA.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE SEVENTY WOULD
HELP PROVIDE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION FOR SENIORS AND
THE DISABLED TO HELP.
HELP THEM GET TO HEALTH CARE
APPOINTMENTS PRECIADO YOUR WORK
AND I APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT.
I SEE YOU HAVE A WITNESS TO
SUPPORTER TESTIMONY -- MISTER
CELLS RESEARCH NAMELY
REPRESENTED PLEASE SIGN AND MORE
IN FROM CALIFORNIA SENIOR
LEGISLATURE.
IN WITH YOUR SPONSORS OF THIS
BILL.
AND WE WANT TO THANK THE
LEGISLATURE. FOR THEIR
TREMENDOUS EFFORT IN MAKING
HEALTHCARE AVAILABLE TO THE
CITIZENS OF CALIFORNIA HOWEVER.
THERE ARE SOME GROUPS OF
CITIZENS THAT DON'T HAVE ACCESS
TO IT BECAUSE OF TRANSPORTATION.
WE HAVE MANY SENIORS AND PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES WHO SUFFER
FROM CHRONIC AND SEVERE
ILLNESSES.
THAT LIMIT THEIR LOW MOBILITY.
BUT THEY ALSO LIVE IN ISOLATED
COMMUNITIES.
ACCESS TO THEIR HAIR CUT EALTH
CARE SERVICES A PRIME CONCERN.
SPECIALIZED HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES ARE USUALLY LONG
DISTANCE AWAY IN THE REGION.
MANY OF CALIFORNIA SMALLER
COUNTIES AND THAT'S OVER HALF OF
OUR COUNTIES.
THE ACTUAL NUMBER OF AND
SERVICED SENIORS IS UNKNOWN.
BUT GOVERNMENT POLICIES IN
FUNDING ARE PROPELLING SENIORS
TO AGE IN PLACE.
WHEN LACK OF HOUSING
ALTERNATIVES?
ARE THERE ARE -- MAKE IT SO THAT
THEY CAN NOT A MOVE.
AT LEAST ONE THIRD OF YOU
LEGISLATORS REPRESENT
CONSTITUENTS THAT FIT INTO THIS
DEMOGRAPHIC.
AND THOSE OF YOU WHO REPRESENT
URBAN AREAS HAVE VERY LARGE
ENCLAVES.
OF CITIZENS AND CONSTITUENTS
THAT ALSO FIT INTO THIS CATEGORY
WE FEEL THAT THESE INDIVIDUALS
DESERVE SERVICE ALSO.
WE'RE ASKING THAT YOU.
ADDRESS THE SENIOR AND DISABLED
COMMUNITIES NON EMERGENCY
TRANSPORT NEEDS WE'RE PROPOSING
THAT THIS TRANSPORT SOLUTIONS
THROUGH GRANTS TO THE COUNTIES
FOR THE PURCHASE OF ENERGY
RENEWABLE VEHICLES.
FROM THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUN WE ALSO ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE TO PASS THIS BILL.
THANK YOU FOR THE NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MARC WATTS
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTRY
COST OF THE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE.
APPRECIATE WORKING WITH THE
AUTHORS OFFICE OVER THE LAST
COUPLE WEEKS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS INJURY AND
WE WOULD SHOW YOUR AUNT'S WE
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
WESTERN FOR PAYING CAST
ASSOCIATION.
WE APPRECIATE THE IDEA WE HOPE
THAT THERE BE.
WIDE VARIATION OF FUEL SO THAT
THE VEHICLES CAN REACH FOLKS
WHEREVER THEY ARE.
AND WE CAN INCREASE THE MOBILITY
OF THESE -- SENIORS FOR THESE
CENTRAL TRIPS SUPPORT.
THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF THE AUTHORS BILL
OR SHARE THE CONCERNS.
SEEING NONE ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
I'M SORRY.
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAMES WE
REPRESENT PLACE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS KATHERINE
GARCIA AND I'M A POLICY ADVOCATE
FOR SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA.
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA'S
SUPPOSED TO SPECIFIC LANGUAGE
AND ASSEMBLY BILL. NINE SEVENTY
THAT WOULD UNDERMINE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE G. G. R.
HALF WE ASK THAT YOU REMOVE NEAR
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES FROM THE
BILL.
AB NINE SEVENTY CURRENTLY STATES
AT THE DEPARTMENT AGING WOULD
RECEIVE YOUR AFFECTIVE RELATIONS
FOR ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES AND
NEAR ZERO EMISSIONS.
ONLY ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
SHOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR D. G. R.
F. APPROPRIATIONS AND THERE ARE
CURRENTLY.
ZERO SHUTTLES TOLD IN CALIFORNIA
THAT ARE ADA COMPLIANT.
THE GT R. F. WAS INTENDED TO
HELP CALIFORNIA TRANSITION TO A
SUSTAINABLE FUTURE IN THE
APPROPRIATIONS SHOULD FUND
PROVEN PROGRAMS THAT REDUCE
EMISSIONS AND HELP CALIFORNIA
ACHIEVE ITS CLAIM IT GOALS.
WHEN IT COMES TO CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES PROVIDE THE MOST
EFFECTIVE PUBLIC HEALTH BENEFIT
BY REDUCING GHG?
GAS.
JG M. CRITERIA EMISSIONS.
WE WOULD REMOVE OPPOSITION IF
THE REFERENCE TO NEAR ZERO BUT
THE MINUTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU -- ANY QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE OF THE AUTHOR.
SEEING NONE MISTER CELLS WE LOOK
CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE WHEN THE TIMES APPROPRIATE
AND JUST.
TO THAT MENTIONED SOMETHING
ABOUT THE OPPOSITION WE JUST
DON'T WANNA LEAVE SENIORS ON THE
SIDE OF THE ROAD STRANDED -- FOR
RULE AREAS ESPECIALLY UP AND
DOWN THE ENTIRE STATE THAT DON'T
HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE TO
SUPPORT.
ANNOUNCER.
THAT'S WHY WE COLLUDED BOTH
LANGUAGES UNDERSTOOD -- THIS
RECENT CELL SERVICE FOR YOUR
BILL TODAY AND THANK YOU.
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION OF OUR
SENIORS AND THANKING THEM FOR
COMING.
AND TESTIFYING -- WE WILL KEEP
TO ROLL OPEN -- FOR ARE ABSENT
MEMBERS WE GET A QUORUM.
SO NOW WILL BE GOING. TO FIFTEEN
EIGHTY NINE THANK MISTER MEMBERS
I'D LIKE PERCENT ASSEMBLY BILL
FIFTEEN EIGHTY NINE WHICH WILL
REDUCE OFF ROAD VEHICLE
EMISSIONS.
BY HELPING FARMERS TRANSITION TO
CLEANER MORE EFFICIENT TRACTORS
THROUGH THE CARL MOYER PROGRAM
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND WHO
YOU REPRESENT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SYLVIA
SOLELY SHAUN BEHALF OF THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL DISTRICT.
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE TODAY OUR RECENTLY
ADOPTED AIR QUALITY ATTAINMENT
PLAN FOR THE VALLEY CONTAINS A
COMMITMENT TO REPLACE.
TWELVE THOUSAND OLDER HIRING
MISSION TRACTORS WITH NEW LOWER
EMISSION EQUIPMENT.
THE CHANGES PROPOSED BY THIS
BILL WILL ALLOW US TO FIND THE
REPLACEMENT OF UNCONTROLLED
GASOLINE POWERED EQUIPMENT WHICH
WILL PROVIDE REDUCTIONS OF
LOCALIZED CRITERIA POLLUTANTS.
WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
THANKS WITH THIS PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE LEARN
ON HATE CHECK ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA CONGENERS IN GROWERS
ASSOCIATION WESTERN PROCESSORS
ASSOCIATION AMERICAN.
STYLE SHE HAS AN EASY FARMERS
LEAGUE CALIFORNIA RICE
COMMISSION CALIFORNIA FRESH
FRUIT ASSOCIATION AFRICAN
AMERICAN FARMERS OF CALIFORNIA
ALL IN SUPPORT -- FOR THE
REASONS STATED BY THE AIR
DISTRICT FARMERS ARE READY TO
TRADE UP.
THEIR TRACTORS JUST WITH SOME OF
THESE EQUIPMENT THEY NEEDED
THESE INCENTIVE PROGRAMS TO HELP --
CARP HAS ACKNOWLEDGED THAT THIS
IS A GOOD PROGRAM AND THAT THIS
IS THE WAY TO ACHIEVE OUR AIR
QUALITY GOALS AND SO WE WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU THE OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC THE LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT.
SIGNAL NUMBERS THE PUBLIC THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION.
OR HAVE CONCERNS WITH AUTHORS
BILL.
AGAIN MY NAME IS KATHERINE
GARCIA WITH SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA -- SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA POSES AB FIFTEEN
EIGHTY NINE WHICH WOULD ALLOW
THE CAR MORE PROGRAM TO FIND THE
REPLACEMENT OF UNCONTROLLED GAS
ENGINES FOR FARM EQUIPMENT WITH
DIESEL ENGINES.
THE CAR MORE PROGRAM WAS
ESTABLISHED TO REPLACE OUTDATED
DIESEL ENGINES WITH CLEANER
DIESEL ENGINES IT IS INTENDED TO
PROVIDE A NET REDUCTION IN
DIESEL EMISSIONS.
INSTEAD THIS REPLACEMENT WOULD
INCREASE DIESEL PARTICULATE
MATTER TPM.
AND THE CAR MORE PROGRAM HAS
NEVER BEEN USED TO REPLACE GAS
WITH DIESEL THIS GOES AGAINST
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES.
THIS TYPE OF REPLACEMENT WOULD
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE DPM WHICH
HAS A DETRIMENTAL IMPACT ON
CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC HEALTH
APPROXIMATELY 70% OF CANCER RISK
RELATED TO THE STATE AIR TOXICS.
IS ATTRIBUTED TO DPM.
FUNDS MEANT TO IMPROVE AIR
QUALITY SHOULD NOT BE USED ON
EQUIPMENT THAT WILL LIMIT MORE
HEALTH THREATENING AIR
POLLUTANTS THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE OF
THE AUTHOR.
THE CELLS WHICH LIKE KLAS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR EITHER ONE
TIMES PER PREDICAMENTS CHAIRMAN
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THANK YOU MISTER CELL SERVICE
FOR YOUR BILL TODAY WHEN IT IS
APPROPRIATE WE HAVE A QUORUM
WILL TAKE A VOTE -- THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
MR [inaudible] TO FIVE SIXTY
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
COLLEAGUES FOR CONSIDERING AB
FIVE SIXTEEN A BILL THAT WOULD
REFORM A HANDFUL OF HARMFUL
TELLING PRACTICES.
THAT HAVE DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS
WE ALL KNOW TOWING TO BE A
STRESSFUL EXPERIENCE FOR
EVERYONE BUT FOR TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS EVERY
YEAR.
IT'S HAD A DEVASTATING ECONOMIC
IMPACT.
LET ME SAY THE OUTSIDE THEIR
MANY GOOD REASONS WHY CAR SHOULD
BE TOWED FOR PUBLIC SAFETY AND
TRAFFIC FLOW.
IN FACT WE DO NOT IN THIS BILL
TOUCH TWO DOZEN LEGAL GROUNDS TO
TOW CARS.
BUT THERE ARE THREE TOWING
GROUNDS THAT ARE NOT RELATED TO
PUBLIC SAFETY -- TRAFFIC THAT DO
PENALIZE YOU FOR MINOR OFFENSES
BECAUSE OF YOUR INCOME AS WELL
DOCUMENTED WAS STATE WIDE DATA.
THAT WE REFER TO AS POVERTY TOES
TOES WHEN YOU HAVE FIVE PARKING
TICKETS OUTDATED CAR
REGISTRATION SUPPORT LONGER THAN
SIX MONTHS WHEN YOUR CAR'S BEEN
LEGALLY PARKED FOR SEVENTY TWO
HOURS ON A PUBLIC STREET.
THE HEART OF THIS BILL IS THAT
USING TOàN AS A MINOR DEBT
COLLECTION TOOL HAS NOT ONLY
BEEN INEFFECTIVE BUT
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE ANY BECAUSE OF
POVERTY.
IF YOU CAN'T AFFORD TO PAY YOUR
PARKING TICKETS OR CAR
REGISTRATION YOU CAN'T AFFORD
THE AVERAGE FEE OF FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS TO GET YOUR CAR FROM A
TOW YARD OR ELEVEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS WHEN YOU ADD DALY
STORAGE.
PARKING TICKETS AND ADDITIONAL
FEES AND FINES.
ALMOST HALF OF ALL AMERICANS
LACK SAVINGS TO COVER AN
UNEXPECTED EMERGENCY OF OVER
FOUR HUNDRED DOLLARS.
AND IF YOU CAN'T GET YOUR CAR
OUT OF A TOW YARD WITHIN THIRTY
DAYS IT'S SOLD ADALINE CELL.
GETTING TOWED MEANS THAT YOU
PERMANENTLY LOSE YOUR CAR YOU
CAN'T GET TO YOUR JOB YOU COULD
LOSE YOUR JOB WHICH MEANS YOU
CAN'T PAY THE MINOR DEBT THERE
WAS A REASON FOR THE TELL.
IT'S HARDER TO GO TO SCHOOL
DEFENSE TO HANDLE FAMILY
OBLIGATIONS TO MOVE OFF OF
PUBLIC ASSISTANCE.
AND A TOW CAN OFTEN MEAN YOU
LOSE THE ONLY SHELTER YOU MAY
HAVE OF THE CAR.
AND CAR OWNERS NOT THE ONLY
PARTY WHO LOSES UNDER THIS
POLICY.
TOTAL YARDS ARE REQUIRED TO PAY
FOR THE EXPENSIVE STORE IN A CAR
FOR THIRTY DAYS BEFORE SELLING
IT IN A LIEN SALE.
AND THE COST OF STORAGE AND CAR
SALES TYPICALLY EXCEED THE LOWER
AVERAGE SALES PRICE OF THE CAR.
CITIES AT RUN TELLING PROGRAMS
LOSE MONEY FOR THE SAME REASON
TYPICALLY LOSING OVER TWO
THOUSAND DOLLAR PER CAR TOWED.
WHEN GOVERNMENT TOE SOMEONE
BECAUSE THEY'RE POOR IT CREATES
A CYCLE POVERTY THAT DOESN'T
BENEFIT ANYONE?
LOW INCOME PEOPLE LOSE TOTAL
YARDS LOSE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
LOSE THIS BILL WOULD HOPEFULLY
STOP A CYCLE THAT IS NOT WORKING.
AT THIS TIME LIKE TO TURN IT
OVER TO OUR WITNESSES INCLUDING
MERRY LOVELESS WHO IS
REPRESENTING ONE OF THE TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF VICTIMS OF POVERTY
RELATED TO US.
AS WELL AS A LISA TELAH KIANA
WITH THE LAWYERS COMMITTEE ON
CIVIL RIGHTS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHAIR -- AT MS
LOVELACE HAS DIRECT EXPERIENCE
SHE MY NAME IS MERRY LOVELESS I
LIVE IN SAN FRANCISCO.
I SUPPORT THIS BILL BECAUSE OF
THE CURRENT TOàN LAWS.
WHICH IT HAD THE DEVASTATING
IMPACT IMPACTS ON MY LIFE AROUND
TWO THOUSAND NINE DURING THE
RECESSION I WAS WORKING AS A
HOME IMPROVEMENT SPECIALIST.
I RELIED ON MY VEHICLE TO CARRY
SAMPLES OF MATERIALS INCLUDING
HARDWARE WINDOWS AND DOORS TO MY
CLIENTS HOMES.
MY VEHICLE WAS A BEAUTIFULLY
RESTORED FORD OR NINETEEN EIGHTY
TWO LINCOLN TOWN CAR.
FINANCIAL HARDSHIPS BEGAN AS A
THE ECONOMY WENT SOUTH AND I WAS
LAID OFF FROM MY JOB.
I LIVED IN A THREE THOUSAND
SQUARE FOOT HOME WITH A THREE
BEDROOM.
IN BRENTWOOD CALIFORNIA BUT I
WAS EVICTED DUE TO THE INABILITY
TO PAY MY RENT.
I HAD A NICE HOME IN LIFE AND
THEN I DIDN'T.
STRUGGLING TO SURVIVE ULTIMATELY
I RAN OUT OF OPTIONS.
AN EXPERIENCE INSURMOUNTABLE
HARDSHIPS.
I WASN'T ABLE TO SCRAPE ENOUGH
MONEY TO PAY MY BILL SUPPORT AS
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS RAN OUT I
COULD NOT AFFORD BASIC
NECESSITIES SUCH AS GASOLINE.
AND MY CAR FOR MY CAR AND
UTILITIES I BEGAN RECEIVING
PARKING TICKETS. FOR STREET
SWEEPING WHEN I MOVED BACK TO
SAN FRANCISCO.
THERE WOULDBE A MANY OF THEM
WERE NOT LEGITIMATE BECAUSE MY
CAR WAS PARKED ON THE OPPOSITE
SIDE OF THE STREET.
WITH THE SIGNS WERE POSTED IN
COMPLAINING TO THE CITY IT WAS
MY WORD AGAINST THE MEDIA MAN'S
AND FORTUNATELY I COULD NOT
PROVE -- NOR.
AFFORD THESE TICKETS THE PAYMENT
PLAN WAS NOT AN OPTION
ULTIMATELY THE CITY BOOTED AND
TOLD MY CAR.
CHARGING APPROXIMATELY TWO
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS TO
RETRIEVE IT I TRIED TO CONTEST
THE SF MTM DENIED BY MY REQUEST
FOR AN APPEAL AND MY CAR WAS
SOLD AT AUCTION FOR A HUNDRED
NINETY EIGHT DOLLARS.
THEY FILED A LIEN AGAINST ME FOR
ENTIRE AMOUNT OF TWO THOUSAND
SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS DAMAGING MY
CREDIT.
THE CITY IN TOW COMPANY COST
SEVERAL TRAUMAS IN MY LIFE AND
IT WAS IN.
POSSIBLE FINDING A HOME.
IMPROVEMENT DESIGN JOB WITHOUT A
CAR.
LIMITED EMPLOYMENT OPTIONS AS I
WAS UP AGAINST IMPOSSIBLE ODDS I
COULD NOT AFFORD TO PAY EVEN BUS
FARE.
AND THE BANKRUPTCY ENSUED.
I LOST MY DRIVER'S LICENSE AND I
AM WITHOUT A CAR TO THIS DAY.
THIS EXPERIENCE STRIPPED ME OF
MY CAR THREATEN TO ROB ME OF MY
DIGNITY AND I WAS DEMORALIZED
DEPRESSED AND HAD NO
TRANSPORTATION OPTIONS I
COULDN'T FIX ANYTHING INFILL
TOPLESS.
I BECAME PARALYZED BY SYSTEM
THAT IS SET UP TO MAKE POOR
PEOPLE FAIL.
MY HORRENDOUS EXPERIENCE CANNOT
BE EASILY SUMMARIZED BUT I
SINCERELY HOPE YOU CONSIDER
VOTING TO APPROVE AB FIVE ONE
SIX SO THAT OTHER VULNERABLE LOW
INCOME PEOPLE DO NOT SUFFER THE
PAINFUL SITUATION I EXPERIENCED.
AND ARE EMPOWERED TO OVERCOME
THE NEGATIVE DOMINO EFFECT
POVERTY.
ALSO KNOWN AS THE REMAINDER OF
THE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN.
AND MEMBERS THANK YOU AT WE HAVE
NEW DATA ON THIS THESE POVERTY
TOES ARE DEVASTATING THERE ARE
ALSO NOT A WIN FOR ANYONE THE
COST THE CITY MONEY THESE ARE
LOW VALUE VEHICLES.
AND JUST ONE NUMBER I'LL SHARE
WITHYOU AND RIVERSIDE COUNTY --
70% OF PEOPLE LOSE THEIR CARS
FOR THE FIRST STEP FOR SEVENTY
TWO HOUR TOES AND THAT MEANS
THAT THE CITY'S COST IS MORE
THAN TRIPLE -- THE VALUE OF THE
CAR AT AUCTION AT AND THE TOW
COMPANIES HAVE TO STORE LOW
VALUE CARS IN THEIR LOTS AND ALL
THE SAME TIME PEOPLE ARE LOSING
THEIR VEHICLES AND THEIR
LIVELIHOODS WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YEAR I'VE OF THE Q..
X. WITH THIS PLEASE MISTER CHAIR
MY CAR WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY WE ONE OF THE CO
SPONSORS OF THIS MEASURE AND WE
URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
WE'LL GO TO THE PUBLIC -- SO
WHAT I'D LIKE TO DO IS GO
FORWARD WITH -- WHO YOU
REPRESENT AND BASICALLY A ME?
TOO YES MISTER CHAIR TIFFANY
WHITE WITH AS A CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AFTER MR MEMBERS BEVERLY ON
BEHALF U. D. W. ASKED ME LOCAL
STATE I THIRTY INSTRUCTS THE
GOOD AFTERNOON EMILY MATHIS
SPEAKING ON BEHALF MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC TRANSPORT.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
HER CHILD DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
BRIAN B. SEND THE NATIONAL UNION
OF HEALTH CARE WORKERS IN
SUPPORT.
MY ANGER MAYES FAILURE OF
CALIFORNIA CO SPONSOR IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
DOES HE GROW UC WSJ'S COUNCIL IN
TED NORMAN CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME
CONSUMER COALITION IN SUPPORT.
DEBBIE ALBERT PRIVATE CITIZEN IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
DO YOU MEMBERS THE PUBLIC THAT
WOULD LIKE TAKE.
OFFER THEIR SUPPORT FOR THE BILL.
SEEING NONE HE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OR HAVE.
CONCERNS OF THE AUTHORS BILL.
SEE NINE QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE OF THE AUTHOR.
MR SHOWS LIKE TO RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR THE CONSIDERATION AND
SUPPORT IS GOING.
TO THANK YOU MISTER -- TO AS
THIS BILL MOVES FOR YOU SHOULD
CONTINUE TO HAVE AN OPEN
DIALOGUE WITH LOCAL COMMUNITIES
TO TO TRY TO FIND A BALANCE.
ON SOME OF THESE PROVISIONS
WHICH BILL. SIX TO REPEAL.
OF THE NEW AND I'VE HAD THAT
TALK AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO DO SO -- WE GET A
QUORUM WILL TAKE A VOTE ON THE
BILLS WILL LEAVE IT OPEN UNTIL
WE HAVE THAT ABILITY.
SO THANK YOU PROJECT THAT SO
WE'LL HAVE YOUR SECOND BILL
[inaudible] THREE FOUR AB.
FOURTEEN EIGHTEEN THANK YOU
EIGHTEEN WOULD MOVE FOR THE
VISION OF A CALIFORNIA THAT NO
LONGER HAS DIRTY POLLUTING
DIESEL SCHOOL BUSES -- AND
HOPEFULLY BUSES THAT REPLACED
WITH CLEAN ELECTRIC SCHOOL BUSES.
IT IS ESTIMATED IN THE UNITED
STATES THEY'RE OVER FIVE POINT
THREE MILLION TONNES OF
GREENHOUSE GASES THAT ARE NEEDED
EVERY YEAR BY DIRTY SCHOOL BUSES
IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE NEARLY
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND SCHOOL
BUSES ON A ROAD.
MOST OF WHICH ARE OLDER DIESEL
FUEL MODELS.
THESE ARE BUSES THAT CAUSE
RESPIRATORY DISEASES AND WORSEN
EXISTING HEALTH CONDITIONS LIKE
ASTHMA PARTICULARLY WHEN IT
COMES TO CHILDREN WHOSE LUNGS
ARE STILL DEVELOPING.
A LETTER TO BUSES NOT ONLY
PROVIDE KIDS WITH THE HEALTH
YOUR COMMUTE BUT THE OFFER
VALUABLE SAVINGS TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS.
WE KNOW OTHER OVER THE LIFETIME
OF AN AVERAGE ELECTRIC BUS
SCHOOL DISTRICTS CAN SAVE
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS A YEAR IN
REDUCED FUEL AND MAINTENANCE
COSTS COMPARED TO THEIR DIESEL
COUNTERPARTS.
LASTLY LET YOUR BOSSES CAN
PROVIDE ELECTRIC GRID AND
FINANCIAL BENEFITS BY
DISCHARGING ENERGY AT CRITICAL
MOMENTS OF THE DAY.
BUSES THAT WOULD CHARGE A TIMES
WHEN ENERGY DEMAND IS LOWEST IN
THE EVENING WHILE TRANSPORTING
STUDENTS DURING PEAK ENERGY
DEMAND TIMES -- WITH THAT.
INTERRUPT YOU ONCE.
I JUST GOT A QUORUM AND ONE OF
THE FOLLOWING CAPTURE I WANT. TO
MINUTES AGO [inaudible]
FREEZER RATHER [inaudible]
FONG HERE [inaudible]
AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
CHAIR [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
DEEP [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
GRAYSON [inaudible]
MEDINA [inaudible]
NAZARIAN O'DONNELL.
WE HAVE A QUORUM.
I APOLOGIZE AGAIN FOR THE
ERUPTION -- MYSTERY PLEASE
PROCEED NO POLICIES NECESSARY --
JUST BRIEFLY THIS BILL WOULD SET
UP THE INFRASTRUCTURE FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND UTILITY COMPANIES
TO SET UP PARTNERSHIPS -- WITH
STATE AGENCIES SO THAT WE CAN
BUILD IN OUR STATE IS ZERO
MISSION SCHOOL BUS FLEET.
THE BILL WOULD SAFEGUARD THE
HEALTH OF OUR SCHOOL CHILDREN
IMPROVE OUR AIR QUALITY AND
REDUCE OUR RELIANCE AND DIRTY
TRANSPORTATION -- AND I WANT AT
THIS TIME TO TURN IT OVER TO OUR
WITNESSES.
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME ONLY
REPRESENT PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MY NAME IS
A TO MARTINEZ AND I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF OUR JUSTICE -- JUSTICE
ALONG WITH NEXT GEN AMERICA AND
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA ARE CO
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL WE'RE HERE --
TODAY TO SUPPORT MOVING FOUR
ZERO MISSION SCHOOL BUSES WE
THINK THESE ARE IMPORTANT --
TOOL TO COMBAT THAT THE AIR
POLLUTION TO COMBAT CLIMATE
CHANGE AND TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THAT NEED TO ADD DESPERATE
RELIEF AND NEW BUSES -- THE THE
OTHER THING I'LL JUST POINT OUT
TODAY -- WE HEARD FROM ONE OF
THE REPRESENTED SOME TWIN RIVERS
SCHOOL DISTRICT THAT HIS
ELECTRIC BUSES ARE BECAUSE IT
ARE COSTING SEVENTEEN CENTS PER
MILE TO OPERATE WHERE IS THE
DIESEL BUSES ARE COSTING AROUND
EIGHTY SIX CENTS.
PER MILE SO THIS IS A WIN WIN
FOR THE ENVIRONMENT IT'S A WIN
WIN FOR THE HEALTH OF CHILDREN
AND IT'S A WIN WIN FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
ABOUT TO YELL I'M THE AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL OFFICER.
AND DIRECTOR OF THE SACRAMENTO
METROPOLITAN AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT.
THE PSYCHOMETRIC DISTRICT IS
PLEASED TO SUPPORT THE WIDER
DEPLOYMENT OF ZERO EMISSION
SCHOOL BUSES IN CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE LEADING THE CHARGE IN THE
NATION BY THE POINT TWENTY SEVEN
ZERO MISSION SCHOOL BUSES AND WE
ARE READY TO DO MORE WITH YOUR
SUPPORT.
WE'RE GETTING READY TO DEPLOY
NEARLY.
FIFTY YOUR MISSION SCHOOL BUSES
IN THE NEAR TERM WORKING IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS -- IN THE REGION THESE
ONLY REPRESENT A SMALL FRACTION
OF THE TOTAL WE HAVE TO DO.
SO AB FOURTEEN EIGHTEEN IS A
VERY SIGNIFICANT STEP FORWARD
AND WE'RE READY TO WORK WITH YOU
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO TO MAKE
THIS HAPPEN SOON THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE AUTHORS BILL.
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND WE
REPRESENT IN AND HOPEFULLY ME.
TOO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR DAVID
WEISS COUGH WITH NEXT IN
CALIFORNIA CO SPONSOR THE BILL
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CATHERINE GARCIA WITH SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NOTHING IN HOUSE ON BEHALF OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON IN
SUPPORT.
AARON RODRIGUEZ WITH THE UNION
OF CONCERNED SCIENTISTS IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
MARINA FRANCESCHI WITH
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
JUDY POPE THREE FIFTY BAY AREA
ACTION STRONG SUPPORT.
SYLVIA SO LEASE ON BEHALF OF
ADVANCED ENERGY ECONOMY AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT
HAVE -- OPPOSITION THE AUTHORS
BILL WOULD LIKE TO SHARE
CONCERNS.
SEEING NONE QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE OF THE AUTHOR.
THIS HOW YOUR CURRENT --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER -- TO QUITE A
WEEK CONSIDER OTHER BUS
TECHNOLOGIES YOU'RE ONLY
FOCUSING ON ONE TECHNOLOGY --
LEAVE REALLY WANT TO FOCUS ON
ZERO EMISSION TECHNOLOGY BECAUSE
STATE AIR QUALITY IN CLIMACOOL
SAY THAT WE REALLY NEED TO MOVE
THAT DIRECTION. FOR MEETING THE
CLEAN AIR AND CLIMATE STANDARDS
AND THEN THE OTHER THING IS WE
SEE THAT ELECTRIC SCHOOL BUSES
ARE -- A PLACE WHERE CALIFORNIA
CAN BE A LEADER AND SHOULD BE
LEADER TO MEET THESE AIR QUALITY
STANDARDS BUT ALSO BECAUSE
THERE'S A VIPER AND ZERO MISSION
BUS INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA.
SO ALL AGREE THAT WE NEED TO
CLEAN UP THE TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR THERE'S NO DOUBT ABOUT
THAT.
I ALSO A SUPPORT OF ELECTRIC
VEHICLES -- BUT WE NEED TO
SUPPORT MARKETS TO CREATE A
BENEFICIAL REUSE FOR URBAN IN OR
RURAL ORGANIC WASTE INCLUDING
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION FEELS LIKE
ORANGEY.
MY CONCERN THAT THIS BILL SIX
WINNERS OVER LOSERS OR VICE
VERSA.
AND PARTICULAR IN THIS MARKET
AND I WANT YOU TO SOMETIMES
THINK OUTSIDE THE URBAN AREA --
ARE RURAL AREAS MAY HAVE MORE
DIFFICULTY GETTING ON ELECTRIC
VEHICLES.
WE'VE BEEN TOLD THAT SOME BUSES
IN THE LA AREA.
ARE SITTING IDLE RIGHT NOW THE
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
POWER THE TECHNOLOGY IS NOT
QUITE THERE AND THAT'S A BIG
INVESTMENT THE PEOPLE ARE MAKING.
I'M ALSO FOR THE BILL TODAY BUT
I JUST WANT TO YOU TO BE AWARE
THAT WHEN IT COMES THE FLOOR I
MIGHT HAVE.
A DIFFERENT -- VOTE FOR YOU.
I APPRECIATE THAT I'M HAPPY TO
ENGAGE WITH YOU AND APPRECIATE
YOU RAISING THESE CONCERNS.
CERTAINLY INFRASTRUCTURE -- OF
HOW WE GET POWER TO THE BUSES IS
A CRITICAL ISSUE AND A VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT OF
UTILITIES WHEN IT COMES TO THIS
AND HOW WE BUILD OUT THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE -- PART OF THE
POINT OF THIS BILL IS TO HAVE
THAT CONVERSATION TO SAY IN ALL
PARTS OF THE STATE IF WE ARE
ACTUALLY GONNA HAPPEN ZERO
EMISSION.
WORLD -- PARTICULARLY IN RURAL
PARTS OF THE STATE OR PARTS THE
STATE THAT DON'T HAVE ACCESS AT
THIS POINT HOW DO WE DO THAT SO --
HOPEFULLY TO THIS BILL WILL BE
ABLE TO TO TO HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS PUSH TO THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AND FIGURE OUT HOW
WE ACHIEVE THAT.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE OF THE AUTHOR.
SEEING THEM WAS CHU IS LIKE
CLOSE APPRECIATE THE
CONSIDERATION AND SUPPORT OF
THIS MATTER.
I THANK YOU SO MEMBER CHIU OF
ALL THIS FOR YOUR BILL TODAY --
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
WELL I DON'T HAVE MUCH MUCH FOR
SECOND.
MR IS THE FIRST.
OF MR DEEP -- WAS THE SECOND.
AND THIRD DAY PLEASE CALL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEES ON UTILITY AND ENERGY.
FRAZIER [inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
CHIU [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
DEEP -- FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
GRAYSON [inaudible]
MEDINA [inaudible]
NAZARIAN [inaudible]
O'DONNELL.
IT HAS SEVEN LEAVE THE ROLL OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK AYE
SURE THANK YOU COLLEAGUES.
SO REALLY GO THROUGH A LITTLE
HOUSEKEEPING RIGHT NOW -- SO
WHAT I WANTED TO DO NOW THAT WE
HAVE A QUORUM -- JUST TO SHARE
WITH WE'RE GONNA GO TO WITNESSES
PER SIDE FOR TWO MINUTES EACH
GOING FORWARD -- BECAUSE WE
STILL HAVE A MEASURABLE AMOUNT
OF DOES TO GO -- MEASURES ON
FILE FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY TWO
AB FOURTEEN ELEVEN RACES TEMPLE
BY THE AUTHOR.
MEASURES ON CONSENT FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO AB ONE EIGHTY FIVE
GRAYSON.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB --
THREE THREE FIVE SO MEMBER
GARCIA.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE BABIES
THREE SEVENTY ONE FRAZIER.
FILE ITEM FIFTEEN A. B. ELEVEN
THIRTY FOR THE MALL.
FILE I'M TWENTY AB FORTINO ONE
FORM.
WHILE I'M TWENTY FOUR AB --
FOURTEEN FORTY TWO REVERSE.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY SIX AB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY FIVE POWER CON --
FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTY ONE IS
YOUR THIRTY EIGHT SALAS FILE
ITEM THIRTY TWO ACR FORTY SEVEN
BIGELOW.
FILE ITEM THIRTY THREE CA ARE
SIXTY SIX A YEAR CURRY.
IS THERE IS FIRST AND SECOND.
WE HAVEN'T FIRST I MISTER
[inaudible]
YES [inaudible]
DOESN'T CONSENT.
YES WELL I'M TWENTY SEVEN AB.
FOURTEEN NINETY TWO OKAY SO I
HAVE A FIRST BY MISTER.
BIGELOW.
SECOND BY MISTER PHONE -- MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
CONSENT.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR FRAZIER
[inaudible]
FONG HI [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
CHIU [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
DALY HI DAVE [inaudible]
I FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GIPSON.
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE MEDINA.
THIS AREA.
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE [inaudible]
GOOD.
THAT HAS TEN WITH THE ROLE IN --
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS WILL MOVE ON
TO AB.
SEVEN THIRTY FIVE SO MEMBER
MELENDEZ.
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MISTER HAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
HERE TODAY TO PRESENT TO YOU AB.
SEVEN THIRTY FIVE WHICH REQUIRES
A CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
TO CERTIFY THAT THE SUPPLY CHAIN
FOR ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES ARE
FREE FROM THE USE OF CHILD LABOR.
THIS BILL WOULD ALSO SUSPENDED
THAT MANDATE UNTIL CARD CAN
CERTIFY THAT THIS VEHICLES MEET
THE CHILD LABOR FREE STANDARD.
ZEBRA CHELATION TO REQUIRE
ARMENIAN FACTORIES TO OFFER FOR
SALE SPECIFIC NUMBERS OF THE
VERY CLEAN IS CARDS AVAILABLE
SUCH AS FULL BATTERY -- ELECTRIC
HYDROGEN FUEL CELL IN PLUG IN
ELECTRIC HYBRID VEHICLES.
CAL CALIFORNIA'S ELECTRIC CAR
FLEET ON THE RED WAY TODAY'S
OVER FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND WITH
BATTERIES BUILT ON THE BACKS OF
CHILDREN WHO ARE POOR.
THE SINGLE LINK IN THE ELECTRIC
CAR REVOLUTION IS THE MINERAL
COBALT.
COBALT IS PRESENT IN EVERY
LITHIUM ION RECHARGEABLE BATTERY
ON THE PLANET FROM SMARTPHONES
TO TABLETS TO LAPTOPS OBVIOUSLY.
BATTERIES IN IN VEHICLES COUPLE
IS THE MOST EXPENSIVE RAW
MATERIAL INSIDE A LITHIUM ION
BATTERY AND WORLDWIDE DEMAND
FROM THE BATTERY SECTOR HAS
TRIPLED IN THE LAST FIVE YEARS
SO ANYWHERE FROM 6270%.
OF THE WORLD'S COBALT COMES FROM
THE DEMOCRATIC REPUBLIC OF CONGO.
MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE
THOUSAND LOCALS MANY AMONG THEM
CHILDREN AS YOUNG AS SIX YEARS
OLD OUR TASK TO MIND THIS
MINERAL IN OFTEN HARSH
CONDITIONS.
THEY ALSO PRODUCE ABOUT 25% OF
THE WORLD'S COBALT -- MANY TIMES
IN AND CONDITIONS YOU YOU COULD
NOT IMAGINE.
AND THAT HAPPENS WITH REGULARITY
MONTHS -- WE HAD THIRTEEN MINERS
DIED IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
FIFTEEN MORE DIED AFTER THAT IN
CALL WAYS TO UNICEF ESTIMATED
200-012-40000 BOYS AND GIRLS
WORK IN THIS INDUSTRY -- THEY
ESTIMATE ABOUT FIVE THOUSAND
WORK JUST IN ONE PARTICULAR SIDE --
ALONE IN IN THE CONGO SO THE
BOTTOM LINE IS WE DON'T KNOW HOW
MANY KIDS -- REALLY ARE WORKING
IN THIS INDUSTRY WE JUST KNOW
THAT THEY ARE -- THE STUDIES
HAVE FOUND THAT RESIDENTS WHO
LIVE NEAR MINE TIED URINARY
CONCENTRATIONS OF COAL BUT THERE
WERE FORTY THREE TIMES HIGHER.
LEAD LEVELS FIVE TIMES HIGHER
CADMIUM AND URANIUM LEVELS. FOUR
TIMES HIGHER THAN THE CONTROL
GROUP -- WE HAVE A THEIR
INDUSTRIES THAT ARE LOOKING TO
MAKE HEADWAY IN THIS AREA APPLE
IS CERTAINLY -- HAVING A GOT A
GOOD AMOUNT OF SUCCESS -- AMAZON
AS WELL TESLA.
BUT WE CERTAINLY CAN DO MORE SO --
I KNOW THAT THIS PARTICULAR BILL
HAS HAS GIVEN SOME MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE -- SOME CONCERN
AND WONDERING WHAT TO DO WITH
THIS BUT I WILL.
I WILL ASK YOU TO CONSIDER THE
FACT THAT CALIFORNIA HAS A
MANDATE.
RATE WE WE HAVE A CERTAIN I MEAN
THIS IS WHY WE HAVE A CERTAIN
NUMBER OF JOBS WE HAVE TO PUT ON
THE ROAD.
AND CALIFORNIA'S THE LEADER IN
THIS TYPE OF GREEN AND YOUR
LEAST TRYING TO LEAD THE WAY OF
ALL THE OTHER STATES.
WHICH IS GREAT BUT WE CANNOT DO
THAT ON THE BACKS OF CHILDREN.
IN THE CONGO BECAUSE WE WANT TO
FEEL BETTER ABOUT OURSELVES.
IF WE'RE GOING TO BE GREEN IF
WE'RE GOING TO BE FRIENDLY TO
THE EARTH.
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO BE FRIENDLY
TO HUMANS AS WELL AND JUST
BECAUSE THEY'RE A WORLD AWAY.
DOESN'T MEAN THAT WE DON'T BEAR
SOME SORT OF RESPONSIBILITY WHAT
YOU THINK ABOUT THAT AS YOU'RE
CONTEMPLATING THIS BILL TODAY.
ON STEIN WHO IS THE FOUNDER AN
AMBASSADOR FOR ENERGY IN
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE COMMITTEE
CHAIRMAN FOR THE AMERICAN
SOCIETY OF CIVIL ENGINEERS.
INFRASTRUCTURE REPORT CARD ON
THE ENERGY SECTOR IN CALIFORNIA
IS HERE I TO TESTIFY TODAY
BEFORE YOU AND WITH -- WITHOUT
RUN GO AHEAD.
I DON'T REMEMBER THAT YOU RUN ON
THE CLOCK FOR TWO MINUTES.
THERE ARE NO KNOWN CLEAN SUPPLY
CHAIN FOR LITHIUM COBALT.
YET THE RICHEST MOST POWERFUL
COMPANIES OF WORLD IS STILL
MAKING NUMEROUS CREATIVE AND
COMPLEX EXCUSES FOR NOT
INVESTIGATING.
THEIR SUPPLY CHAINS AND HAVE
BEEN DOING SO FOR TWENTY YEARS.
IT'S NOT IN THE BEST INTEREST
FOR A FOR A FOR PROFIT COMPANY
TO TURN DOWN A GOOD DEAL.
WHEN IT COMES TIME TO BUYING RAW
MATERIALS IN A CROWDED
MARKETPLACE?
THAT'S WHAT'S MOST LARGE I'M
TALKING ABOUT ONE TIME OF
BILLION DOLLAR COMPANIES.
DON'T REALLY DO THE RESEARCH
THEY SHOULD ON COMPANIES WITH
PRICES ARE SO GOOD.
I'M BOB AND HEROES THEY REALLY
DON'T KNOW WHERE THEY'RE COMING
FROM.
THE TURN A BLIND EYE THE
REALITIES OF THE DIRTY SECRETS
OF LITHIUM COBALT ACQUISITION
AND PROCUREMENT SIDE.
IS THE MAN FOR RECHARGEABLE
BATTERIES GROWS COMPANIES ARE
RESPONSIBILITY TO PROVE THEY
HAVE AN ETHICAL SUPPLY CHAIN.
A PRIORITY WHEN IMPLEMENTING
GREEN POLICIES AND NOT PROFITING
FROM THE MISERY OF MINERS
WORKING IN TERRIBLE CONDITIONS.
LIKE CLOTHES AND SHOES AND SOUTH
AMERICA.
THE ENERGY SOLUTIONS OF THE
FUTURE WILL NOT BE BUILT ON
HUMAN RIGHTS ABUSES.
BY NOT HOLDING MAJOR AUTOMAKERS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR SUPPLY
CHAIN INTEGRITY.
BY THE CALIFORNIA TRANSFERENCE
SUPPLY CHAIN LAW ALREADY ON THE
BOOKS.
WELL BUILDING THOSE COVERS
CONSUMERS AND BUSINESSES ARE
INVERSELY PROMOTING AND
SANCTIONING THESE CRIMES.
THROUGH THE PURCHASE OF GOODS
AND PRODUCTS THAT HAVE BEEN
TAINTED IN THE SUPPLY CHAIN AND
THAT.
ABSENT PUBLIC AVAILABLE
DISCLOSURES CONSUMERS OR
DISADVANTAGE IN BEING ABLE TO
DISTINGUISH ETHICAL COMPANIES.
ON THE MERITS OF THEIR EFFORTS
DESPITE PRODUCTS FREE FROM THE
STENCH OF SLAVERY AND HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
THE FEEDING A. B..
SEVEN THIRTY FIVE WOULD BE YOUR
WAY OF EXEMPTING AUTOMOBILE
MANUFACTURERS.
FROM THE LAWS ALREADY ON THE
BOOKS IN CALIFORNIA FOR SUPPLY
CHAIN TRANSPARENCY IN OF THE
FEDERAL. FOR BUSINESS SUPPLY
CHAIN TRANSPARENCY IT WOULD
ENCOURAGE CONTINUED EXPLOITATION
OF HORRENDOUS LABOR AND
ENVIRONMENTAL CONDITIONS.
OUR MANUFACTURERS LAST ASKING
WRAP IT UP PLEASE.
YOUR TO PASSING WE ENCOURAGE
PASSING AB SEVEN THIRTY FIVE
WHICH AND A STRONG MESSAGE TO
THOSE COMPANIES TO CLEAN UP
THEIR ACT TO HEAR TO LAWS
ALREADY ON THE BOOKS. TO ENSURE
THAT HE THESE HAVE CLEAN
BATTERIES.
THANK YOU.
SO FIRST BY MR FUNG SECOND BY
MISTER BIGELOW -- ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THE
AUTHORS BILL.
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO
THAT ARE IN OPPOSITION OF THE
AUTHORS BILL.
I'LL REMIND YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
THE MIX.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS KATHERINE GARCIA
AND POLICY ADVOCATE FOR SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIA -- I DO WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT EVEN THESE ARE
NOT JUST TO HAVE PEOPLE MAKE
THEMSELVES FEEL GOOD ABOUT
THEMSELVES -- WE HAVE TWELVE
YEARS TO REDUCE EMISSIONS OR
RISK CLIMATE CHANGE CATASTROPHE.
AND TODAY IS EARTH DAY SO I ASK
YOU TO VOTE.
OF WITH THIS IN MIND --
REGARDING EIGHTY SEVEN THIRTY
FIVE SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA
URGES ASSEMBLY MELENDEZ ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MELINDA'S KATHY. TO
EXPAND THE SCOPE AND AMEND THE
BILL TO INCLUDE ALL VEHICLES NO
VEHICLE OF ANY KIND SHOULD BE
USING MATERIALS ACQUIRED THROUGH
CHILD LABOR.
INTERNAL COMBUSTION ENGINE
VEHICLES ARE NOT EXEMPT FROM
CHILD EXPLOITATION.
THE TERROR TO OWNS A WHICH IS AN
INTERNATIONAL NGO HAS REPORTED
THAT MIKE A MINING WHICH IS A
MINERAL USE FOR HIMMERY CARPETS
AND PARTS ACROSS.
ELECTRICAL MECHANICAL SYSTEMS
IT'S CARRIED OUT BY CHILDREN IN
INDIA MADAGASCAR CHINA SRI LANKA
PAKISTAN AND BRAZIL.
SIERRA CLUB ASKS THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MELENDEZ ALSO EMIT THE
SECTION ABOUT AMENDING THE STATE
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN AND RE
SUBMITTING TO THE US EPA.
THIS WAS LIKELY TO LAY PROGRESS
ON EMISSION REDUCTIONS THANK YOU
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE JOHN
MOFFITT ON BEHALF OF THE
ALLIANCE OF AUTOMOBILE
MANUFACTURERS.
I'M IN THE UNIQUE POSITION OF
GETTING TO THE SAME PLACE BUT
FOR DIFFERENT REASONS THAN THAN
MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE SIERRA
CLUB.
WE'RE ALSO OPPOSED TO THE BILL --
IN NO WAY DO WE WANT TO DIMINISH
THE THE ISSUE THAT THE AUTHORS
RAISING HERE WE DO THINK IT'S AN
IMPORTANT CONSIDERATION.
AND AND WHETHER IT'S ELECTRIC
VEHICLES OR ANY OF OUR VEHICLES
WE ALWAYS STRIVE TO DO THE BEST
TO TO PROVE UP OUR SUPPLY CHAINS
AS BEST WE CAN RECOGNIZING THAT.
AT TIMES WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT OUR SUPPLIES OF MATERIALS
THAT ARE. EIGHT TEN FIFTEEN
SUPPLIERS AND MANUFACTURERS AND
RE MANUFACTURERS AND
DISTRIBUTORS AND AND ASSEMBLERS
AWAY FROM WHEN WE ACTUALLY
INCORPORATE THAT COMPONENT INTO
THE VEHICLE -- YES OUR OUR
PRINCIPAL OBJECTION TO THE BILL
TODAY IS YOU KNOW THAT WE DON'T
BELIEVE THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT.
THAT THE SAID MANDATE SHOULD BE
HELD HOSTAGE OVER.
AND AND THERE'S A BIT OF A
DISCONNECT BETWEEN WHAT DESERVE
MANDATE IS AND WHAT THE BILL
DOES -- YOU KNOW THE SAID
MANDATE ON ON MY MEMBERS ON EACH
AUTO MAKER IN IN THAT.
HEARING CALIFORNIA IS AN ANNUAL
MANDATE.
THE BILL REQUIRES A RB TO GO OUT
AND TO CONDUCT THIS
CERTIFICATION IN SIX MONTHS.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE EFFECT OF
THE SIX MONTH FREEZE IF YOU WILL
IS ON THIS HAVE MANDATE GIVEN
THAT IT'S AN ANNUAL MANDATE --
YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S A START STOP
THAT I THINK IS DIFFICULT FOR
MEMBERS TO TO FIGURE OUT.
AND AT THE END OF THE DAY -- YOU
KNOW I THINK HAS NO PRACTICAL
FACT ON ON THE REQUIREMENTS IS
THAT MANDATE AND AND THE
REQUIREMENT THAT THAT OUR
COMPANIES MEET THAT MANDATE ON
AN ANNUAL BASIS. FOR THESE
REASONS WERE POSTED THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE
OF THE AUTHOR.
MR RISEN.
THANK YOU AND I WANT TO COMMEND
THE AUTHOR -- FOR THE CONCERN
YOU HAVE FOR CHILDREN -- AROUND
THE WORLD ESPECIALLY THOSE THAT
ARE BEING EXPLOITED TO DO WORK
THAT IS.
A DANGER TO THEIR HEALTH -- JUST
IT CAUGHT MY EAR WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT LITHIUM ION BATTERIES.
ARE LITHIUM ION BATTERIES THE
ONLY. FOR IS.
A LIVE VIA MY OUT I ON BATTERIES
ONLY HOUSTON'S THEIR VEHICLES.
OR ARE THOSE BATTERIES USED AND
OTHER ITEMS THAT.
YEAH -- USED IN ALL KINDS OF
SOCIAL MEDIA DEVICES AS WELL.
WHAT DO YOU MEAN BY SOCIAL MEDIA
DEVICE IPADS IPHONES?
OKAY SO.
IF THEY'RE USED ON IPADS AND
IPHONES IS THERE A PARTICULAR
REASON WHY AS AN AUTHOR YOU
CHOSE TO SPECIFICALLY.
POINT OUT JUST VEHICLES WHEN
PROBABLY YOU COULD TAKE ALL THE
BATTERIES AND LAPTOPS.
AND IT WOULD WASTE -- PAST --
USE AS FAR AS THE VEHICLES GOING
YES -- FIRST OF ALL YOU'RE RIGHT
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF OTHER
PRODUCTS TO HAVE THIS MATERIAL
IN THEM -- WE'RE NOT GONNA SOLVE
ALL THE PROBLEMS OF THE WORLD
TODAY IN ONE BILL SO IT'S ALWAYS
I MEAN I GUESS IT TOOK ME BY
SURPRISE THAT WE HAD SOME
OPPOSITION THAT SAID WELL.
IF THE BILL INCLUDED EVERYTHING.
THEN WE COULD SUPPORT IT.
THAT'S NONSENSE SURE OKAY AND
YES THERE ARE A LOT OF OTHER
PRODUCTS OUT THERE HAVE IT WE
STARTED WITH THIS BECAUSE
CALIFORNIA HAS A MANDATE THAT WE
HAVE A CERTAIN NUMBER OF
VEHICLES THAT ARE ON THE ROAD
THIS TYPE OF VEHICLE WITH THIS
TYPE OF BATTERY.
WHICH CARRIES POUNDS LIKE TWENTY
TO THIRTY POUNDS OF THIS
MATERIAL AS OPPOSED TO HOW MUCH
YOU TALK IN GRAHAM'S OF THIS
MATERIAL IN AN IPHONE OR AN IPAD.
HERE'S A BIG DIFFERENCE OKAY
THANKS.
THE BIG DIFFERENCES.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE OF THE AUTHOR.
MS MELENDEZ WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE YES I WENT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN I AM
DISAPPOINTED THAT SO MANY
MEMBERS SUDDENLY DISAPPEARED
FROM THE COMMITTEE BUT I WOULD
JUST SAY THIS THAT -- YOU KNOW
WE'VE WE'VE GOT THIS MANDATE IN
CALIFORNIA TO GET A CERTAIN
NUMBER OF THESE CARS ON THE ROAD
THAT IS.
IT THAT'S THAT'S HOW
CALIFORNIANS CHOSEN TO LEAVE BUT
I AGAIN I WILL SAY TO YOU THAT.
THERE IS NO POSSIBLE WAY THE
CALIFORNIA CAN THÅU ITSELF IS
THE LEADER.
IN IN HUMAN RIGHTS THE LEADER IN
ENVIRONMENTAL THINGS A LEADER IN
ALL OF THESE THINGS THAT ARE
VIRTUOUS.
BY THE STANDARDS OF CALIFORNIANS
HOW DO WE DO THAT WHEN THEY'RE
WAY WE'RE GETTING THERE.
IS BY PUTTING KIDS THAT ARE SIX
YEARS OLD IN THE MINDS DIGGING
WITH THE SHOVEL WHO ARE BAREFOOT.
THIS THIS IS NOT AN ATTACK ON
ZEDD'S.
IT'S NOT A I MEAN WE HAVE THEM
AND CALIFORNIA'S 50% OF THEM IN
IN THE ENTIRE NATION THAT'S NOT
GOING TO CHANGE MUCH TRYING TO
ATTACK THESE CAR WHAT I'M SAYING
IS.
WE'RE GONNA WALK THE WALK WAY TO
TALK THE TALK.
THAT'S WHAT I'M SUGGESTING TO
YOU SO WITH THAT I WOULD ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU -- IS MELENDEZ -- I'LL
BE.
NUMBER IN YOUR BILL TODAY.
I BELIEVE WE SHOULD HOLD CAR
MANUFACTURERS.
ACCOUNTABLE ENSURE ALL CHILDREN
ARE PROTECTED.
HOWEVER THIS BILLS TO ME IS THE
WRONG APPROACH.
I BELIEVE THIS BILL DOES.
NOTHING TO ACTUALLY PROTECT
CHILDREN.
AB SEVEN THIRTY FIVE ONLY
FOCUSES ON A VERY SPECIFIC
INDUSTRY IN COMMODITY -- ONE OF
THE THINGS IF YOU'RE A TRULY
CONCERNED WITH CHILD LABOR I
INVITE YOU TO THINK OF THIS
MATTER HOLISTICALLY.
AND SUBSTANCE SUBSTANTIVELY.
SIR JUST SINGLE ELECTRIC
VEHICLES ANY TAKEN THE
OPPORTUNITY WHEN YOU HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA RESOURCE FOR YOU CAN
GET A REPORT THAT WAS DUE.
IN DECEMBER.
AND YOU THINK THAT THEY'RE GOING
TO BE THE ONES TO BE ABLE TO DO
THIS.
AT THIS IMPOSSIBLE -- WITH THAT --
MAN SECRETARY WE DO HAVE A FIRST
BY STATE -- MISTER FARMS TO
BIGELOW SWELL REITERATE THAT
ABSENT A PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
FRAZIER [inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
JUNE [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
DEEP -- FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON NOT VOTING MEDINA.
IS THERE AN O'DONNELL.
AS FOR AS WELL AS FOR ICE WILL --
LEAVE THE ROLE PERHAPS MEMBERS.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
MISTER GARRETT.
THIS GABRIEL WE'RE GONNA GO OUT.
TO SEVEN FIVE TWO PLEASE PROCEED
WHEN YOU'RE READY.
MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TODAY 2% AB
SEVEN FIVE TWO A BILL THAT WOULD
ENSURE THE NURSING WOMEN ARE
PROVIDED WITH AN ADEQUATE SAFE
AND HYGIENIC SPACE TO BREAST
FEED.
OUR PUMP BREAST MILK WHILE
TRAVELING.
IN TWO THOUSAND FOR THE BILL.
THANK YOU GOVERNOR BROWN SIGNED
AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN WHICH
REQUIRES MOST AIRPORTS IN
CALIFORNIA TO PROVIDE A LOCATION
SEPARATE FROM A RESTROOM WHERE
WOMEN CAN EXPRESS BREAST MILK
WOMEN TRAVELING BY BUS AND RAIL
ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO ARE
TRAVELING LONG DISTANCES TO AND
FROM WORK TO SERVE THE SAME.
AB SEVEN FIVE TWO WOULD ADDRESS
THIS FUNDAMENTAL IN EQUITY BY
ENSURING THAT STATIONS TO MEET
CERTAIN CRITERIA PROVIDE A SAFE
AND ADEQUATE LACTATION SPACE.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT STEP TO
PROMOTE EQUITY SUPPORT FAMILIES
IN A POWER CALIFORNIANS TO MAKE
IMPORTANT DECISIONS RELATED TO
THE HEALTH OF THEIR CHILDREN.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IS
DEBBIE ALPERT ELECT TATIAN
CONSULTANT AT UC DAVIS MEDICAL
CENTER THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU A REMINDER WITNESSES
WE HAVE TWO MINUTES FOR
TESTIMONY THANK YOU HI MY NAME
IS DEBBIE ALBERTA NUMBER
CLINICAL NURSE THREE LACTATION
CONSULTANT UC DAVIS I'M
PRESIDENT ELECT OF THE
SACRAMENTO BREASTFEEDING
COALITION.
AND WE SUPPORT THIS BILL I'VE
WORKED IN FLORIDA TEXAS AND
CALIFORNIA IN PRIVATE PRACTICE
HOSPITALS IN CORPORATE LACTATION
THERE IS EXTENSIVE DOCUMENTATION
OF BREAST FEEDING HEALTH
BENEFITS. FOR BOTH MOTHER AND
BABY AND ALSO THE BENEFITS TO
OUR EMPLOYERS REGARDING
ABSENTEEISM.
AND SO.
WE HAVE SO MANY WOMEN WHO ARE
TRAVELING USING A BUS USING
TRANSIT USING ALL SORTS OF
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION AND WE
HAVE MANY STATIONS IN OUR
COUNTRY ACROSS THE U. S.
INCLUDING WASHINGTON DC'S UNION
STATION.
BALTIMORE PENN STATION
PHILADELPHIA'S THIRTIETH STREET
STATION WE EVEN HAVE THEM AT
GOLDEN ONE ARENA.
AND UC DAVIS LACTATION ALSO USES
THERE ARE -- A POD LIKE THIS
THESE STATIONS ARE SELF
CONTAINED LACTATION SUITES WITH
COMFORTABLE BENCHES FALL DOWN
TABLES AN ELECTRICAL OUTLET FOR
PLUGGING A BREAST PUMP IN A DOOR
THAT CAN BE LOCKED. FOR PRIVACY
THESE ADA COMPLIANT PODS ARE
DESIGNED FOR INDIVIDUAL USE BUT
CAN BE -- OKAY A LARGE ENOUGH
FOR MOTHERS WHO HAVE BABIES AND
SMALL CHILDREN IN TOW -- WE ARE
HOPING THAT YOU WILL PROVIDE
THIS SUPPORT FOR MOTHERS WHO ARE
CONSISTENTLY WORKING IN OUR
STATE.
AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THIS IMPORTANT LET'S SEE
LEGISLATION THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE REMIND YOU.
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME I AM
ROBBIE GONZALEZ DOWN THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA BREASTFEEDING
COALITION.
IN OUR VISION IS THAT ALL
PARENTS CAN MEET THEIR
BREASTFEEDING GOALS IN SO WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN
FIVE TWO THIS BILL HELPS PARENTS
TO MEET THEIR GOALS WE DO GET
COMPLAINTS FROM PARENTS WHO.
ARE TRAVELING THEY'RE TRYING TO
MAINTAIN LACTATION TO WORK IN
TRAVEL IN WHAT WE GOT IN THE CAR --
COMPLAINT LAST YEAR SOMEONE
WHO'S TRAVELING FROM LA TO SAN
DIEGO SHE NEEDED A PLACE TO PUMP
WHILE SHE WAS TRAVELING.
THEY ALLOWED HER ONE DAY TO USE
SOMEBODY'S OFFICE THEN THE NEXT
DAY WHEN SHE TRIED TO USE THAT
SOMEBODY CAME IN WALKED IN ON
HER AND ASKED HER WHY ARE YOU
HERE WHERE YOU'VE BEEN USING THE
SPACE.
SHE WAS EMBARRASSED AND SHE JUST
SHE DIDN'T KNOW WHAT TO DO SO
THE NEED IS THERE WE HAVE
TRAVELING PARENTS.
MANY OF THE STATIONS TO OUR IN
LOW INCOME AREAS WHERE THERE'S
HIGH AMOUNTS OF TRAFFIC SO CAN
PROVIDE ACCESS TO MANY PARENTS
WHO ARE TRYING TO MEET THEIR
BREASTFEEDING GOALS.
AND WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- WHEN THIS IS
SUPPORT MY AND I'M A SILLY OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU?
THE OTHER WITNESSES FOR THE
AUTHORS BILL.
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC ELECT
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OR
HAVE CONCERNS WE AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE OF THE AUTHOR.
THE BILL MISTER GIBSON.
IS THE THIRD.
MOST FIRST.
SO WOULD YOU -- WOULD LIKE.
TO CLOSE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER A REAL -- THIS
FOR YOUR BILL TODAY.
I HOPE YOU'LL KEEP THE COMMITTEE
INFORMED ISSUES CONTINUE WORK
WITH THE TRANSIT OPERATORS.
ON THE BILL -- SO IMPORTANT
SUBJECT AND LEAD YOU DOING IT
ABSOLUTELY -- MA'AM SECRETARY
WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WE DO HAVE A FIRST WHERE YOUR
CURRY -- CYCLE GRAYSON -- PLEASE
CALL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE FONG FONG BY
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY I
BERMAN.
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE JUNE [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
DALY DALY AYE DEEP.
DEEP I FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON HI GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE MEDINA.
THIS AREA IN [inaudible]
O'DONNELL [inaudible] EIGHT
WHERE THEY WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
CONTRACTS MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
SEE THEN WE HAVE NO.
MEMBERS -- IN THE AUDIENCE WILL
MOVE ON TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
PRESERVATION. 3%.
WE WANT TO AB.
TEN TWENTY FIVE GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB TEN
TWENTY FIVE REMOVES THE
OBLIGATION FOR CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY TO REIMBURSE.
THE STATE OF TRANCE -- THE STATE
FOR THE TRANSPORTATION PLANNING
AND DEVELOPMENT ACCOUNT GRANTS
USED TO DEVELOP THE SAN RAMON
BRANCH CORD OR HOME TO THE IRON
WORST REGIONAL TRAIL.
IT WILL ALSO REQUIRE THE COUNTY
TO INCLUDE A REPRESENTATIVE FROM
THE C. C. T. A CONTRA COSTA
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY.
ON THE IRON WORST RECORDER
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM ADVISORY
COMMITTEE AND I WILL HAVE MY
WITNESS SELF INTRODUCE.
PLEASE FISHING GERMAN MEMBERS --
MARC WATTS REPRESENTING THE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS FOR
CONTRA COSTA THIS WE ARE TODAY --
AND I WALKED HOW QUICKLY MY
TESTIMONY DEVON WITH THE AUTHOR
CONTINUE THANK YOU.
LIKE TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THREE NINE PEOPLE FROM THE
PUBLIC LIKE THAT [inaudible]
AND YOUR THOSE [inaudible]
ANOTHER QUESTION [inaudible]
MY MICROPHONE.
SO -- I CAN DO THAT ALL OVER
AGAIN [inaudible]
OR NOT -- ANY QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE WE DON'T CLOSE
MISTRESSES SOMEBODY LIKE TO
THANK THE CHAIR FOR HIS GOOD
WORK ON THIS AS WELL AS THE
COMMITTEE JUST ASK FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION.
RESPECTFULLY ASK ONE HAVE A
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON
WILL BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL
TODAY -- MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE FONG.
FONG I THANK YEAR CURRY.
AGIR CURRY I BERMAN.
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE CHIU [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
DALY.
DALY AYE DEEP.
DEEP I FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE MEDINA [inaudible]
NAZARIAN [inaudible]
O'DONNELL.
THAT HAS A BELIEVE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
MYSTERIES [inaudible]
WE'LL.
SO LET'S GO AHEAD AND DO A
REFRESH ON LIFTING THE CALL.
ON STARTING FROM SCRATCH
[inaudible]
YEAH.
I'M SECRETARY WHEN YOU'RE READY
PLEASE PROCEED.
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE AB ONE
SEVENTY NINE DO PASSED THE OKAY
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER FONG.
AND A SECOND BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
FRAZIER HI.
FRAZIER AYE FONG.
FONG I AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
I BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
BIGELOW IQ [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
DALY RIVERSIDE.
DALY AYE DEEP.
DEEP I FRIEDMAN.
GIVE CENTER HI GIPSON AYE
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE MEDINA.
THIS AREA IN.
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I I'M GONNA SWITCH OF
MY VOTE MADAM SECRETARY FROM --
HI TO NOT VOTING.
I KIND OF THE MOMENT.
AB ONE SEVENTY NINE RAY AS
FRAZIER AYE TO NOT VOTING.
BUT IS HE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
THEN PERHAPS MEMBERS.
MISSION IS WHICH WAS A PHONE.
NINE THREE WE WE NEED A MOTION
ON FILE ITEM.
THREE CAN YOU GET THAT FROM THIS
PHONE MISTER BIGELOW.
THIS CALL ROLE.
FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE A. B. TWO
THIRTY EIGHT SANTIAGO THE MOTION
IS TO PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS FRAZIER.
HI FRAZIER AYE FONG.
FONG AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
I GEAR CURRY I BERMAN
[inaudible]
BIGELOW.
THEY LOW IQ [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
DALY
DALY AYE DEEP.
DEEP I FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE MEDINA.
NAZARIAN O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I IT IS.
NINE LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS.
GO TO SIX AB FOOT.
AB FIVE SIXTEEN NEW MOTION.
MISTER GIBSON'S FIRST OR SECOND.
MR RECENT SECOND.
MA'AM SECRETARY SKINNING PLEASE
CALL ROLE.
AB FIVE SIXTEEN THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE FONG.
FONG AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I BERMAN.
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE CHIU [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
DALY.
DALY AYE [inaudible]
DEEP [inaudible]
WITH [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON HI GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
IS AN AYE MEDINA.
THIS AREA IN.
O'DONNELL. TO MOVE AS THERE IS
SEVEN LEAVE THE ROLE CONTRACTS
MEMBERS -- WILL MOVE ON TO
NUMBER SEVEN MS MELENDEZ A. B..
SEVEN THIRTY FIVE AM WE ARE TO
BELIEVE I THINK WE WE DID THAT
ONE RIGHT YEAH SO WHERE DID.
SO IT'S JUST COULD LOVE TO CALL
IN ON THAT CAN CATCH UP.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SEVEN THIRTY
FIVE MELENDEZ THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN
[inaudible]
CHIU [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
GRAYSON [inaudible]
MEDINA [inaudible]
NAZARIAN [inaudible]
O'DONNELL [inaudible]
YEAH.
THAT IS FORMALLY THE ROLE OPEN --
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
IT WILL [inaudible]
MODES COMMA.
WHICH ONE YOU WANT TO GO TO NEXT
[inaudible] HUNDRED ELEVEN
LIMóN.
FILE ITEM.
ELEVEN AB [inaudible] NINE
SEVENTY I MISS BIGELOW MISTER
GIBSON IS FIRST AND SECOND --
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
AB NINE SEVENTY THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE FONG AYE FONG AYE
AYE GEAR CURRY.
FILE ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN AB.
NINE SEVENTY AGUIAR-CURRY I
BERMAN.
BIGELOW ON THE LOW IQ.
CUNNINGHAM.
DALY.
DALY AYE DEEP.
DEEP I FRIEDMAN GIPSON AYE
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE MEDINA.
NAZARIAN O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE.
THAT IS NOT A LIBERAL OF OPEN
FOR UP TO MEMBERS.
NUMBER SIXTEEN A. B..
WELL TWENTY SIX SO MEMBER HOLDEN
[inaudible] THIRTEEN MOTIONS.
MR DOES FIRST.
THE THREE OF SECOND MAN
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB ONE TWO TWO SIX THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE FONG [inaudible]
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I BERMAN
[inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
SURE [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
DALY ON DAILY I DEEP.
DEEP I FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON R. GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE MEDINA.
THIS AREA IN O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I AB -- IS AB. TWO
FOURTEEN EIGHTEEN WELL IN NUMBER.
TWENTY THREE SOME REMEMBER JUNE --
ENTERTAIN MOTION.
WELL AS A MOTION THIS COULD LIVE
CALL IN.
AB FOURTEEN EIGHTEEN THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO UTILITIES AND
ENERGY [inaudible]
TO FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON.
GIPSON I MEDINA.
THIS AREA [inaudible] FIFTEEN
TWENTY NUMBER.
TWENTY AB -- FOURTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN WE DON'T HAVE A MOTION.
ENTERTAINER MOTION [inaudible]
FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN CURRY FIRST.
FOR THE SECOND [inaudible]
O'DONNELL.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
AB FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE FONG.
AGUIAR-CURRY.
I GEAR CURRY I BERMAN
[inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible] TO
CUNNINGHAM.
DALY.
DALY AYE DEEP.
DEEP I FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
ABSENT.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE MEDINA [inaudible]
NAZARIAN [inaudible]
O'DONNELL [inaudible]
O'DONNELL I SEVEN IT IS SEVEN WE
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. FIFTEEN EIGHTY NINE WE
HAVE A MOTION [inaudible]
A MISTER. FOR SOFTWARE MISTER
FARM.
I'M LOOKING FOR A SECOND.
THE SAME YEAR CURRY. FIFTEEN
EIGHTY NINE FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY AMOUNT SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL THE MOTION IS TO
PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE FONG.
FONG I AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I BERMAN
[inaudible]
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE CHU [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
DALY.
DALY AYE DEEP [inaudible]
THAT I DEEP I FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON AYE GRAYSON
AYE MEDINA [inaudible]
NAZARIAN [inaudible]
O'DONNELL [inaudible]
ALL I THAT AS NINE LEAVE ROLE TO
FRAPH SOME MEMBERS METRO
O'DONNELL WOULD YOU LIKE.
TO PROCEED TO THE PODIUM --
WOULD YOU WANT TO START WITH THE
AB SEVEN FIFTY THREE FIRST.
PLACE [inaudible]
GARCIA [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
YES.
THANKS SIR PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY YES -- FOURTEEN A
YOUR FORTINO SIX FIRST CORRECT.
THAT'S FINE IF YOU WANT TO DO
THAT.
WHERE THEY'RE FORTINO? SIX ZERO
SIX THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT AB
FORTINO SIX WHICH RESTORES WHICH
REQUIRES THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION. TO ALLOCATE 10% OF
THE FUNDS OF THE ALTERNATIVE AND
RENEWABLE FUEL VEHICLE A
TECHNOLOGY PROGRAM. TO
ALTERNATIVE FUEL AND ADVANCED
TECHNOLOGY VEHICLES.
ALTERNATIVE FUEL PROGRAM WAS
ESTABLISHED IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN TO DEVELOP AND DEPLOY
INNOVATIVE TECHNOLOGIES THAT
TRANSFORM CALIFORNIA'S FUEL AND
VEHICLE TYPES.
OVER THE LAST DECADE THE PROGRAM
HAS SUCCESSFULLY HELP ATTAIN.
STATE CLIMATE CHANGE GOALS BY
INVESTING IN A BROAD PORTFOLIO
OF TRANSPORTATION IF YOU'LL
PROJECTS.
THAT.
THAT REDUCE GHG EMISSIONS.
RIGHT IN HERE TODAY IT'S TO
TESTIFY ON I'M ON BEHALF OF THE
BILL IS -- THE INDIVIDUALS FROM
THE CALIFORNIA NATURAL GAS
VEHICLE COALITION.
A REMINDER NGUYEN SAYS YOU HAVE
TO MENTOR CY YOUNG I'M SORRY.
PLEASE MAKE YOU SOME REMEMBER
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE -- WE'RE HERE AS
SPONSORS OF FORTINO SIX FORTINO
SIX STEMS FROM THE AN INABILITY
TO RESOLVE ISSUES WITH GETTING
CONSISTENT FUEL NEUTRAL FUNDING.
FROM THE A. R. FPTP PROGRAM AS
THE PROGRAM WAS CREATED IN
AUTHORIZED TO DO.
THE LAST TWO FUNDING PLANTS HAVE
PROVIDED ZERO INCENTIVE TO THE
NATURAL GAS VEHICLE INCENTIVE
PROGRAM.
AT THE END THE JUSTIFICATIONS
BEING MADE THAT THERE'S NO
DEMAND FOR THESE VEHICLES
HOWEVER WE BELIEVE THAT'S AN
ACCURATE THE CURRENT WEIGHTLESS
FOR THESE VEHICLES IS AROUND SIX
MILLION DOLLARS WHICH MEANS THAT
FEES HAVE GONE THROUGH THE
PROCESS.
OF TRYING TO ACCESS THESE GRANTS
THAT HAVE BEEN PUT ON HOLD.
THE CALIFORNIA NATURAL GAS FIELD
GOAL COALITION IS A MEMBER OF
THE A. R. FPTP ADVISORY
COMMITTEE WE'VE ENGAGE WITH C.
C. COMMISSIONERS AND STAFF TO
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE MEETINGS.
AND WE HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO
GIVE RESOLUTION ON THESE ISSUES
TODAY THERE'S NO PLAN PRESENTED
FOR HOW THE ENERGY COMMISSION OR
STAFF WILL ADDRESS THIS WAIT
LIST AND FUN THIS WAIT LIST AND
DEVELOP A PLAN -- FOR NOW UNTIL
WHEN THE END OF THE PROGRAM
EXPIRES AND TWENTY TWENTY SIX SO
WE JUST URGE YOU TO FOCUS ON
WHAT WE CAN DO NOW FOR THESE
COMMUNITIES IN AREAS WHERE THERE
AREN'T THE REDUCTIONS.
NATURAL GAS VEHICLES RUNNING ON
RENEWABLE FUELS ARE AVAILABLE
RIGHT NOW TO PROVIDE RELIEF AND
THE ONLY OTHER OPTION WE'RE
PROVIDING IS KEEPING THE STATUS
QUO OF DIRTY POLLUTED TRUCKS
THANK YOU.
SO JUST FOR THE RECORD SIR CAN I
GET YOU STATE YOUR NAME AND WHO
YOU REPRESENT OUT PART OF THE
GERMAN MY NAME'S JOSIAH YOUNG ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA NATURAL
GAS VEHICLES COALITION I THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU.
I SURVEYS REMEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE I'M RYAN KENNYWOOD
CLEAN ENERGY JUST IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME LIKE MAKE ONE
MAJOR POINT -- BACK IN DECEMBER
THE ELLIE -- RELEASED A REPORT
ON TRANSPORTATION AND THEY FOUND
THAT TRANSPORTATION GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS PROGRAMS HAVE NOT
REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
OVERALL IN A RELATIVELY
EXPENSIVE IT ALSO FOUND THAT THE
ONLY REDUCTION.
IN TRANSPORTATION GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS IS IN THE HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLE SECTOR AND OF COURSE
MOST OF THE HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES
IN THE CLEAN -- TRUCKS ACTOR ARE
LOW -- KNOCKS AT VEHICLES WITH
RENEWABLE FUEL SO WE BELIEVE
THIS PROGRAM WILL GET MORE THOSE
TRUCKS ON THE ROAD WE URGE AN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU. FOR THE
PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
AUTHORS BILL.
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME THE
REPRESENTING PLEASE A CHAIRMAN
IF I MAY ALSO WANT TO SAY ON
BEHALF OF THE BIO ENERGY
ASSOCIATION WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL I APPRECIATE THAT
THANK YOU.
MA'AM.
VERONICA PART ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA REFUSE RECYCLING
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT OF AB
FOURTEEN OF SIX TODAY THANK YOU.
THANKS WITH THIS PLACE.
GOOD AFTERNOON TIM CARMICHAEL
AND HAVE A SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
GAS COMPANY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THIS WILL MORE PARTICIPANTS.
HI HAT MATCH MISTER CHAIRMAN OF
THE COMMITTEE OF ANY GARCIA ON
BEHALF OF THE SEA ARE IN OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL SERVICES AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT
ARE IN OPPOSITION THE AUTHORS
BILL HAVE CONCERNS PLEASE
[inaudible]
I'M.
FOR WE'RE GONNA GET YOU FIT THE
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M CATHERINE
GARCIA AS A POLICY ADVOCATE FOR
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA.
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA OPPOSES
AB FORTINO SIX WHICH WOULD
INVEST IN BIO FUELS PRODUCTION
AND ALTERNATIVE FUEL VEHICLES.
THIS LEGISLATION WOULD UNDERMINE
CALIFORNIA'S AFFECTS EFFORTS
TOWARDS ZERO MISSION
TRANSPORTATION FUTURE BIO FUELS
GENERALLY ARE NOT EMISSIONS FREE
AND THEIR USE IN COMBUSTION
ENGINES CONTINUE TO CONTRIBUTE
TO CLIMATE AND LOCALIZED AIR
POLLUTION.
A COMMITMENT TO BIO FUELS AND
ALTERNATIVE FUEL VEHICLES WOULD
HINDER CALIFORNIA'S EFFORTS TO
ACHIEVE OUR CLIMATE AND CLEAN
AIR GOALS AND THE STATE SHOULD
NOT INVEST IN STOP GAP MEASURES.
TO THE DETRIMENT OF OUR
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE OF THE AUTHOR.
HEARING NONE DISTRO DONALD WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THAT'S WHEN I
WROTE.
THANK YOU MISTER O'DONNELL ALL
THESE FOR YOUR BILL TODAY -- I
HAVE A FIRST WITH MISTER GIBSON
SEC WHETHER YOU'RE CURRY -- MAP
SURGERY PLEASE CALL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE FONG HI FONG I
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I BERMAN
[inaudible]
BIGELOW.
Q. BIGELOW AYE [inaudible] TO
CUNNINGHAM.
DALY AYE DALY AYE DEEP.
DEEP I FRIEDMAN GIPSON HI GIPSON
AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE MEDINA [inaudible]
NAZARIAN O'DONNELL.
HI O'DONNELL AYE.
AS NINE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PROCEED WITH
AB.
SEVEN FIFTY THREE YES -- MISTER
THANK YOU.
MISTER GIBSON THAT MR GRAYSON
FIRST AND SECOND.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB SEVEN
FIFTY THREE A BILL TO HELP LOW
CARBON FUELS COME TO MARKET.
DESPITE HAVING AMBITIOUS CLIMATE
GOALS.
ADMIRED THROUGHOUT THE WORLD
EMISSIONS FROM CALIFORNIA'S
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR.
ARE ON THE RISE. ONE OF THE KEY
OBSTACLES TO REDUCING
TRANSPORTATION RELATED EMISSIONS
IS DEMONSTRATING. TO VEHICLE
OWNERS THAT FUELING CAPACITY
EXIST THROUGHOUT THE STATE FOR
ALTERNATIVE FUEL VEHICLES.
ADDITIONALLY.
CALIFORNIA DOES NOT HAVE A
DEDICATED COURSE OF FUNDING FOR
LOW CARBON FUEL PRODUCTION AND
INFRASTRUCTURE AN ESSENTIAL
COMPONENT.
OF THE STRATEGY TO DE CARBONIZED
ARE TRANSPORTATION SECTOR.
AND WITH ME HERE TOUCH. TO
TESTIFY TODAY IS -- IS -- ALONE
LOOKING FOR THE REBEKAH BORDEAUX --
FROM OVER ON FUELS AND JAKE
DONAHUE ON BEHALF OF HYDROGEN
SHARE -- STAKEHOLDERS.
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME IN THE
REPRESENT PLEASE I HAMMER BACK
AT THE JOB PRESIDENT OVER ON
FEELS I'M TRAINED AS A PC CAM AS
IN FOR THE LAST FIFTEEN YEARS WE
HAVE WORKED WITH EARLY STAGE
COMPANIES.
AB SEVEN FIFTY THREE IS ABOUT
SUPPORTING PROMISE PROMISING AND
EVADE OF AN EMERGING FUELS THAT
CAN BE MADE FROM HARMFUL MISSION
SUCH AS METHANE FROM DAIRY FARMS.
THAT CAN BE MADE FROM
PROBLEMATIC FEEDSTOCKS SUCH AS
WOOD WASTE.
THAT CAN MAKE ULTRA LOW CARBON
OR CARBON NEGATIVE FUELS AND
HELP CALIFORNIA REACH CARBON
NEUTRALITY.
AS AS WELL AS FUEL SECOND POWERS
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES AND HELP
THE STATE REACHES ZERO EMISSION
GOALS.
O'BRIEN IS A CALIFORNIA MAY
COMPANY THAT FOCUSES ON
CONVERTING WASTE STREAM CITY IN
ME A CLEAN BURNING DESIRE
PLACEMENT AND THE CARRIER FOR
RENEWABLE HYDROGEN.
OVER THE PAST EIGHT AND HALF
YEARS OVER THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS AND PRIVATE FUNDING HAS
BEEN INVESTED IN -- RUN WITH
ZERO GRANT FUNDING FROM
CALIFORNIA IN ZERO FEDERAL
FUNDING ONLY RECENTLY WAS -- RON
NOTIFIED OF THE PAINTING GRANT
AWARD FROM THE CC BUT IT WAS
EIGHT YEARS IN THE MAKING.
O'BRIEN HAS A PRIVATE FACILITY
IN IMPERIAL VALLEY THAT HAS FUEL
GLOBAL DE MI VEHICLE
DEMONSTRATIONS WITH VOLVO TRUCKS
MACK TRUCKS IN FORT.
BUT WITH ALL THIS PROGRESS
HOWEVER WE'RE STILL NOT AT THE
POINT OF COMMERCIALIZATION NOT
THROUGH THE VALLEY OF DEATH.
IN CLOSING THREE REASONS THIS
BILL AS IMPORTANT AS ABOUT
CALIFORNIA MAY FUELS AND
INNOVATION OVER HAS ONE COMPANY
AMONG MANY IN THIS SPACE.
IT HELPS SOUGHT SUPPORT
INNOVATION THAT CAN SOLVE
CALIFORNIA'S FEED STOCK AND A
MISSION CHALLENGES WHILE
CREATING LOCAL ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY.
NUMBER TWO MANY'S PROMISING
TECHNOLOGIES THAT CAN HELP
CALIFORNIA REACHES EMISSIONS
GOALS WILL DIE ON THE VINE THE
STATE DOES NOT SUPPORT.
BRIDGING THE VALLEY OF DEATH AND
HELP THESE FUELS LAUNCH INTO THE
COMMERCIAL MARKET.
MOST COMPANIES ARE NOT AS
FORTUNATE AS US VENTURE
COMPOSITION IS DOWN LONG AGO AND
THIS PURPOSE BILL PROVIDES AN
AVENUE TO SUPPORT INNOVATION.
AND FINALLY NUMBER THREE THIS
BILL PAVES THE WAY FOR THE NEXT
GENERATION OF GREAT MOLECULES
WHILE RENEWABLE DME HYDROGEN AND
RENEWABLE PROPANE OR INNOVATIVE
FUELS I WILL BENEFIT FROM THIS
BILL.
WE WANTED WE NONE OF US WANT TO
BE INNOVATIVE FOREVER WE WANT TO
REACH COMMERCIALIZATION AND KEEP
COULDN'T SUPPORTING INNOVATIVE.
TO WRAP IT UP.
LET'S CONTINUE TO MAKE
CALIFORNIA THE LODGING PLACE TO
THE NEXT GENERATION OF
INNOVATIVE LOW CARBON FUELS ARE
YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE
TWO MINUTES.
THIS CHAIR MEMBERS CHECKED ON
HE'LL BE HAVE A BALLOT FUEL CELL
SYSTEM SOME LINE TRANSIT AGENCY
RED WHITE FLEET AND GOLDEN GATE
ZERO MISSION MARINE THESE
ORGANIZATIONS REPRESENT A BROAD
SWATH OF THE HYBRID INDUSTRY --
FROM BOTH THE ENGINEERING
MANUFACTURING AND END USER
PERSPECTIVES.
THESE DIVERSE VIEWPOINTS PUT
TOGETHER COLLECTIVE
UNDERSTANDING OF THE NEED FOR
HYDROGEN TECHNOLOGY IN
TRANSFORMING OUR HEAVY DUTY
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR ZERO
MISSION.
I WALL BELABOR THE POINT THAT
THE ASSEMBLY MAN AND MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE MADE HERE BUT I
DO OR DRIVE VOTE ON THE BILL I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AS
TO HOW THIS BILL CAN HELP US
TRANSFORM OUR HEAVY DUTY SECTORS
ZERO MISSION.
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
NEXT ONE IS WE STATE YOUR NAME
AND WE REPRESENTING.
CHRIS OF OUR BEHALF OF PROPEL
FUELS AND THE ASSOCIATION OF
GLOBAL AUTOMAKERS IN SUPPORT OF
THE MEASURE.
I'LL BE HALF OF THE AT THREE
ORGANIZATIONS WHO WEIGHED IN
WITH AN OPPOSE LAST MINUTE
POSITION WE'RE CHANGING
OPPOSITION POSITION TO SUPPORT
ADMITTED.
THAT BE THE CALIFORNIA ADVANCED
BIOFUELS ALLIANCE PACIFIC
ETHANOL AND CLINICALLY ENERGY.
AND WE'RE HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS.
THANK YOU JUST AYE YOUNG ON
BEHALF OF THE BIO ENERGY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WE'RE
IN A SUPPORTIVE AMENDED POSITION
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. FOUR
COALITION FOR ANY OF OUR NATURAL
GAS AND SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT
ARE.
IN OPPOSITION TO THE AUTHORS
BILL.
NOW I HAVE CONCERNS.
EITHER.
MY NAME IS KATHERINE GARCIA AND
I'M POLICY ADVOCATE FOR SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIA.
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA POSES AB
SEVEN FIFTY THREE IN ORDER FOR
CALIFORNIA TO MEET ITS ENERGY
AND CLIMATE TARGETS WE NEED TO
TRANSITION TO ZERO CARBON
RESOURCES.
HOWEVER.
AB SEVEN FIFTY THREE WILL
ENCOURAGE INVESTMENT IN LOW
CARBON ENERGY RESOURCES THAT ARE
DAMAGING TO THE ENVIRONMENT FOR
INSTANCE HYDROGEN PRODUCTION CAN
RESULT IN GHG EMISSIONS.
WHEN IT IS CREATED FROM FACT GAS
METHANE GAS OR MADE USING AN
ELECTRONIC?
ELECTOR LIKE.
GIVE ME PROCESS IS POWERED BY
FOSSIL FUELS.
AB SEVEN FIFTY THREE WOULD
INCENTIVIZE THE USE OF BY A
METHANE WHICH COULD EXPAND
POLLUTING DAIRY FARMS AND COSTLY
AND INEFFECTIVE BIOTECH JESTERS.
THIS BILL COULD DELAY OUR
TRANSITION TO TRULY CLEAN
RENEWABLE RESOURCES SUCH AS
SOLAR AND WIND BY
INAPPROPRIATELY INCENTIVIZE IN
THE DEVELOPMENT.
OF POLLUTING ENERGY RESOURCES
THANK YOU.
ANY QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE
OF THE AUTHOR.
SELECT CLOSE.
BEST FRIEND I'VE OF I HAVE A
FIRST BY MR GIPSON A SECOND BY
MISTER GRAYSON -- THANK YOU FOR
STANDING IN FOR MR GARCIA TODAY
I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CULTURAL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
[inaudible]
FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE FONG.
AGUIAR-CURRY.
I YEAR CURRY I BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE BIGELOW [inaudible]
Q. [inaudible]
CHU I CUNNINGHAM.
DALY.
DALY AYE DEEP [inaudible]
I FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE MEDINA [inaudible]
NEWS ARIAN.
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I IT HAS NINE LEAVE
THE ROLE CONTRAST SOME MEMBERS
THANK YOU [inaudible]
MR TANK.
SO WE'LL START WITH -- AB ELEVEN
FORTY SIX PLEASE OKAY TO TEN
FORTY SIX OR FORTY SIX ABSTAINED.
THANK YOU MISTER FIRST LET ME
JUST THANK YOU AND THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THE WORK ON THE BILL --
THE BILL INCREASES THE FOCUS OF
THE ANNUAL FORECAST OF THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD MUST CONDUCT FOR
THE STATE'S ELECTRIC VEHICLE
REBATE PROGRAM.
JUST CODIFIES THE DIRECTION THAT
WE WORKED ON A RAID LAST YEAR
REALLY APPRECIATE THE CHAIR
SUPPORT AND COMMITTEES HELP
THANK YOU RESPECTFULLY ASK FINAL.
YEAH ME WITNESSES POORLY MISTER
TANK.
ANY MEMBERS THE PUBLIC THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF MR TING STILL.
LOOKING FORWARD TO THAT THERE
YOU GO.
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME WE
REPRESENT PLEASE.
DAVE ISIKOFF WITH NEXT GEN
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU.
MICHAEL DRAFT WOULD CHARGE POINT
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
RUNNING RC ON BEHALF OF THE
ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
SENSATION IN SUPPORT.
CATHERINE GARCIA ON BEHALF OF
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
STILL BE A SOLUTION ON BEHALF OF
BOUNCED ENERGY ECONOMY IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OR HAVE
CONCERNS WITH THE OFFICE BILL.
PLEASE STEP FORWARD.
CAN YOU PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
AND WHO YOU'RE REPRESENTING FOR
THE RECORD PLEASE.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JOHN MOFFITT ON BEHALF
OF THE ALLIANCE OF AUTOMOBILE
MANUFACTURERS WERE OPPOSED TO
THE BILL TODAY -- YOU KNOW IT IS
I LOOK AT THE BILL AYE AYE I
FIND IT'S HELPFUL TO ACTUALLY
LOOK AT THE END OF THE BILL AND
WORKED MY WAY BACKWARDS.
AND WHAT THE WHAT THE BILL ENDS
WITH I THINK FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE IS ESSENTIALLY WAY
TO BACK US INTO A MANDATE OF
FIVE MILLIONS ADS ON CALIFORNIA
ROADS.
BY THE YEAR TWENTY THIRTY WHICH
IS CERTAINLY A LAUDABLE GOAL BUT
TO MANDATE THAT IN THE LAW WE
THINK IS PROBLEMATIC.
WHY DO I THINK IT'S A MANDATE
THE END OF THE BILL THE STATE
BOARD SHALL ADOPT CRITERIA AND
OTHER REQUIREMENTS? TO ENSURE
THE REBATE LEVELS CAN BE PHASE
DOWN.
IN INCREMENTS BASED ON
CUMULATIVE SALES LEVELS.
IT DOESN'T SAY THAT THE THE
REBATE SHALL BE FAILURES DOWN IT
SAYS THAT OTHER REQUIREMENTS AND
OTHER CREDIT CRITERIA SHALL BE
ADOPTED. TO MAKE SURE WE CAN
PHASE THOSE THINGS DOWN.
SO WHAT ARE WE ADOPTING AND NEW
CRITERIA BEING PUT INTO PLACE SO
THAT REBATES COULD BE PHASED OUT
WHAT IS THE BILL.
ASKING THEY ARE BE TO LOOK AT
AND WE LOOK THROUGH AND WE SEE
MARKETING EFFORTS BY AUTOMOBILE
MANUFACTURERS WE SEE DIFFERENT.
DIFFERENTIAL PRICING IN ELECTRIC
VEHICLES PURSES INTERNAL
COMBUSTION ENGINE VEHICLES AND A
NUMBER OF OTHER THINGS THAT.
INCLUDING.
A MANDATE OF WHAT DOES THE
REBATE NEED TO BE AT WITH THESE
OTHER CRITERIA TO GET US TO FIVE
MILLION.
JOBS ON THE ROAD AND THEN IT
STARTS WITH CODIFYING THAT IN
STATUTE.
THAT'S VERY CONCERNING TO US --
CERTAINLY THESE ARE LAUDABLE
GOALS AS IS BEEN REPORTED
CALIFORNIA HAS THE VAST MAJORITY
OF STEPS ON THE ROAD MORE THAN
ANY OTHER STATE -- COMBINED AND
AND THESE ARE OBVIOUSLY THINGS
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO EVERY
SINGLE DAY. TO GET THERE AND GET
MORE RESERVES ON THE ROAD
[inaudible]
BUT MANDATES [inaudible]
IN LAW.
LACK OF AMBITION IS NOT OUR
PROBLEM. TOO MANY INCENTIVES IS
NOT OUR PROBLEM THERE ARE OTHER
WAYS TO INVESTORS WHICH YOU TO
PLEASE INCENTIVES AND OTHER
THINGS WE THINK ARE MORE HELPFUL
FOR THOSE REASONS WERE OPPOSED
TO THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME IN HERE REPRESENTING
PLEASE.
YES OVER THORN CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE EVEN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION TO THE
EXTENT THAT THE BILL SEEKS TO
IMPOSE THE FIVE MILLION SEVENTH.
WE PREFER TO SEE AN TECHNOLOGY
NEUTRAL MANDATE THAT WOULD ALLOW
FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF DIFFERENT
TECHNOLOGY TO MEET CALIFORNIA'S
GREENHOUSE GAS GOALS.
THANK YOU.
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE OF
THE AUTHOR.
QUICK READ IT SO QUESTIONS THIS
IS EXCLUDE HYBRIDS -- DOESN'T
EXPERT HARPER'S.
THANK YOU.
SO I DO HAVE A FIRST -- WITH
MISTER GIBSON I'M.
ENTERTAIN MOTION FOR SECOND.
SO MISTER BERMAN'S OUR SECOND --
MISTER TING REJECT.
THE AGAIN THE THE BILL DOES NOT
HAVE A MANDATE THE FIVE MILLION
VEHICLE GOAL WAS -- PART OF THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER THAT GOVERNOR
BROWN ISSUES LAST YEAR JUST TRY
TO RESTATE THAT GOAL -- IN
ADDITION IT IS -- NOT -- IT IS
DEFINITELY TECHNOLOGY NEW TOOLS
ON THE TECHNOLOGY DOES NOT HAVE
ANY EMISSIONS -- IN IN ADDITION
WE'VE ALREADY PASSED -- VERY
STRINGENT GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION GOALS -- EVERYONE
KNOWS THAT IN ORDER TO REACH
THOSE PROGRESSIVE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION GOALS WE'RE GONNA NEED
TO GREATLY REDUCE THE EMISSIONS
OF OUR TRANSPORTATION SECTOR
WHICH ACCOUNTS 440% OF THAT
EMISSIONS.
IN ADDITION THIS IS OUR MONEY TO
TAKE A LOOK AT OUR INCENTIVE
REBATE PROGRAM -- ONE OF THE
BIGGEST BENEFICIARIES ARE THE
AUTO MANUFACTURERS WHO HAVE
GOTTEN A HUGE SUBSIDIES -- ABOUT
FOR THE STATE SO THAT OUR
CONSUMERS CALIFORNIA'S WILL GO
BY THEIR CARS SO.
AGAIN THE I THINK THIS IS A A
GOOD.
SIMPLE BILL ASKING THEIR
RESOURCES BOARD TO TAKE A LOOK
AT THE REBATE PROGRAM.
AGAIN THANK YOU THANKS THE CHAIR
AND THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
ASSISTANCE IN JUST RESPECT AS
RIVAL.
THANK YOU MISTER KING OF NOT
ONLY DO WE HAVE TO LOOK AT THE
PRODUCTION GOALS WITH THE
VEHICLES.
BUT I THINK WE ALSO HAVE TO LOOK
AT THE WELL FIRE DAMAGE IS DONE
EVERY YEAR -- GOING FORWARD ALSO
IS A BIG FACTOR THAT SETS US
BACK EVERY TIME -- WITH THE WE
TRY TO MAKE GAINS AND ALSO IN WE
HAVE WELFARE SO SUSPECTED LEASE --
ZERO AS YOU KNOW I STRUGGLE THE
FACT THAT A OR B. DOESN'T SEEM
INTERESTED IN FOLLOWING EXISTING
LAWS.
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORT TO
HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE.
ON THIS ISSUE -- LOBBYIST FOR
YOUR BILL TODAY -- MADAM
SECRETARY WELL WE DO HAVE THE
FIRST.
FROM GIPSON SECOND FROM BERMAN --
ANSWER PROPOSAL.
THE MOTION IS DO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
FRAZIER.
HI FRAZIER AYE FONG [inaudible]
FONG NO.
AGUIAR-CURRY I BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NO JOKE [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
DALY.
DALY AYE DEEP [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN.
PERCENT.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON [inaudible]
MEDINA [inaudible]
NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE O'DONNELL. SIX IT
IS SIX WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
PERHAPS MEMBERS MISTY WE LIKE TO
CONTINUE WITH THE AB SIXTEEN OH
FIVE I ABSOLUTE THANK YOU.
AGAIN LET ME JUST THANK THE
COMMITTEE AND THEIR STAFF FOR
THEIR HELP ON THIS BILL A P.
SIXTEEN OH FIVE IS A DISTRICT
BILL.
IT AUTHORIZES THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO TO
ESTABLISH A RESERVATION PROGRAM
THROUGH THE BILL BETTER CONTROL
THE TRAFFIC ON ARE VERY FAMOUS
LOMBARD STREET -- RESPECTFULLY
ASK DR.
THANK YOU WITNESSES WERE
MISTREATING.
OF MY NUMBER.
HELLO CHAIR FRAZIER AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU MY
NAME IS Y. DONNA AND ALL ITS I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF SUPERVISOR
CATHERINE STEPHANIE OF DISTRICT
TWO IN SAN FRANCISCO WHICH
INCLUDES LOMBARD STREET -- SHE'S
BEEN WORKING. FOR SEVERAL YEARS
WITH TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY ON
DIFFERENT METHODS TO MANAGE
CONGESTION -- ON A BUSY DAY
THERE WILL BE OVER TWENTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE VISITING THE
STREET -- AND WE'VE IMPLEMENTED
SEVERAL OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS
BUT WHEN THE KEY ONES IS THIS
RESERVATION SYSTEM WE SEE IT AS
A POTENTIAL WIN WIN.
FOR TOURISTS AND RESIDENTS IN
THE NEIGHBORHOOD ON TAURUS YOU
WON'T HAVE TO WAIT A FORTY FIVE
NOW LINE DID DRIVE DOWN THE
STREET.
AND RESIDENTS IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD WHO THAT REALLY
SEVERAL BLOCKS AROUND THE
GARBAGE STREET ARE CONGESTED --
SO WE HAVE TO HAVE YOUR SUPPORT
TODAY THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
VERY BRIEFLY TELL YOU CHANGE
TRANSPORTATION AT THIRTY
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR SAN
FRANCISCO WERE LAID OUT THERE'S
ON THE PLANNING CITY FOR THE
TOUGH FOR THE PROPOSED BILL.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC.
THEY LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THE AUTHORS BILL.
ANY MEMBERS THE PUBLIC THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OR SHARE CONCERNS
WITH OTHERS BILL [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
MANY BLACKS COMMITTING QUESTIONS
OF THE AUTHOR FROM THE
COMMITTEES.
LISTING WE LOOK CLOSE.
THEY JUST RESPECT FAST BY THE
THIS TING I WILL BE --
SUPPORTING YOUR CROOKED STREET
BILL TODAY.
I AM THINKING THAT YOU'RE NOT
GOING AYE THREE SB ONE FUNDS TO
STRAIGHTEN IT OUT.
ABSOLUTELY NOT THANK YOU AND
I'LL BE SUPPORTING THANK YOU --
AND SECOND WE DO HAVE FIRST
MAGYAR CURRY SECOND LEG GIPSON
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE FONG.
FONG NO AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE BIGELOW.
THE LOW NOTES YOU [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
DALY.
DALY AYE DEEP [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON AYE GIPSON AYE GRAYSON
[inaudible]
MEDINA [inaudible]
THIS AREA.
JERRY AND I O'DONNELL.
THAT IS SIX WILL READ THE ROLE
THEN PERHAPS MEMBERS THANK YOU
[inaudible]
MYSTERY S..
WE'RE GOOD.
TWELVE SIXTY SIX AB. TWELVE
SIXTY SIX ONE STEP UP AND WHEN
YOU'RE READY TO GO SIR.
IT'S GREAT TO BE HERE.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE --
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNIY TO
SPEAK ON ASSEMBLY BILL -- TWELVE
SIXTY SIX WHICH PROMOTES BIKE
SAFETY AND GUIDANCE ON OUR ROADS
IN INTO CERTAINLY FIRST I WANT
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THE ANALYSIS.
A IT WAS -- YOU KNOW A GOOD
ANALYSIS I THANK YOU FOR
PROVIDING THE AMENDMENTS ALL
HAPPY TO ACCEPT THEM AS A YOU'LL
SEE ARE SHOWN IN PRINT.
I NOW THIS BILL AIMS TO SOLVE A
PROBLEM -- SOLVE A PROBLEM FOR
CYCLISTS IN FOR OUR LOCAL
AGENCIES.
AND SO I THINK THAT WE CAN ALL
AGREE THAT VEHICLE INTERSECTIONS
POSE A SAFETY RISKS FOR BOTH
DRIVERS AND CYCLISTS -- AND THIS
IS PARTICULARLY TRUE WHEN A BIKE
LANE ENDS ABRUPTLY.
UPON MERGING WITH A RIGHT TURN
LANE.
AND SO THAT'S WHY THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF CITY
TRANSPORTATION OFFICIALS.
A RECOMMENDS CREATING SHARED
BIKE AND RIGHT TURN LANES LANES
THAT DIRECT DRIVERS AND CYCLISTS
ON SAFE PATHS THROUGH
INTERSECTIONS -- AND THIS SHARED
LÏNG CONCEPT IT GUIDES OR AT
LEAST IT WILL GUIDE -- ARE CYCLE
IS TO CONTINUE THROUGH THE
INTERSECTION IN THE FAR LEFT
PORTION OF THE TURN LANE.
WELL CARS ARE PROVIDED SPACE TO
SAFELY TURN RIGHT -- THUS
AVOIDING POTENTIAL VEHICLE TO
PEDESTRIAN COLLISIONS -- AND YOU
CAN SEE AN ILLUSTRATION IN IN
THAT THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS I
THINK THEY DID A GOOD JOB -- IN
DOING THAT -- AND CERTAINLY --
THE REASON FOR THIS BILL IS THAT
CURRENT STATE LAW HERE IN
CALIFORNIA STATES THAT ALL
VEHICLES AND CYCLISTS INCLUDED.
MUST OBEY THE RIGHT HAND TURN
LANE.
EVEN IF THE BIKE LANE MARKINGS
DIRECT CYCLISTS TO TRAVEL
STRAIGHT -- AND SO CERTAINLY AS
A RESULT OF THIS DETERS ME --
ARE MUNICIPALITIES AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS FROM CREATING SHARED
LANES -- DESPITE THEIR
WIDESPREAD ACCEPTANCE AS A AS AS
AS A BEST PRACTICE IN IN THE
NAME OF SAFETY.
AND SO AGAIN THIS BILL WOULD
CLARIFY THAT PRACTICE IS LEGAL
AND WOULD REQUIRE CALTRANS TO
DEVELOP STANDARD LANE MARKINGS
FOR CYCLISTS WHEN APPROACHING AN
INTERSECTION AND SO CERTAINLY
WITH ME TODAY IS DAVE SNYDER
FROM THE CALIFORNIA BICYCLE
COALITION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
I STAY SNYDER CALIFORNIA BICYCLE
COALITION THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SAID WELL I WILL I JUST URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE.
GOOD DEAL. SEVEN ANY OTHER
MEMBERS OF PUBLIC THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OR SHARE
CONCERNS OF THE AUTHORS BILL.
I'LL BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE TO
THE AUTHOR [inaudible]
MR FUNG.
HAVE YOU TALKED TO APPRECIATE
YOU BRING THE THE BILL FORWARD
HAVE YOU TALKED TO THE FEDERAL
HIGHWAY ADMINISTRATION HOW DID
THEY FEEL ABOUT.
THE CONFORMITY CONCERNS -- IF
THE CITY CALIFORNIA DECIDED TO
DO SOMETHING THAT IS NOT
CONFORMITY WITH THE FEDERAL
HIGHWAY STANDARDS.
I'LL -- ALL THE FURNACES -- NINE
THE FEDERAL PLACE.
THE FEDERAL HIGHWAY
ADMINISTRATION HAS -- DESIGNS TO
ACCOMMODATE THIS MANEUVER -- THE
CALTRANS A MANUAL DOES NOT SO
WITH THIS BILL.
WE CAN ENSURE THAT THE CALTRANS
MANUAL -- CONFORMS WITH WHAT THE
IF IF IT'S W. A. SAYING.
SO MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE
THE FH A TWO EIGHT HAS CONCERNS
WITH THIS TYPE OF I GUESS
STRUCTURE OF THE LANE AND THAT
THAT RIGHT NOW IT'S NOT.
IT'S NOT ALLOWED UNDER FEDERAL
CENTER SO I'M JUST CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT THE CONFLICTING --
KNEES YEAH I UNDERSTAND IS THAT
IT DOES. TO BE HONEST I MIGHT BE
THINKING OF THE IMMINENT.
DESIGN MANUAL THAT I SAW AT A
CONFERENCE THAT IS GOING TO
INCLUDE THIS DESIGN AND NOT THE
CURRENT.
ONE SO YOUR YOUR FROM YOUR
ANALYSIS OR FOR YOUR FREE THE
RESEARCH YOU'VE DONE THE YOU
YOU'RE SAYING THE FEDERAL
STANDARDS DOES ALLOW THIS.
ALLOWS YOU TO PUT -- SHERO OR IN
IN THE RIGHT TURN LANE OR WHAT'S
GOING A POCKET BIKE LANE BETWEEN
THE RIGHT TURN LANE AND THE
THRILLING.
OKAY BUT MY CONCERN IS ONLY THAT
IFWE HAVE CONFLICTING STANDARDS
THAT AND SOMEHOW YOU NOW WE'RE
NOT ALLOWED THAT THE ROADS THAT
YOU CURRENTLY.
GET FEDERAL FUNDING ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO GET FEDERAL FUNDING
IF SOMEHOW WERE CALTRANS OUT OF
COMPLIANCE SO THAT'S WHY I'M
JUST I'M TRYING UNDERSTAND -- IF
IF THE IF THE IF THERE IS A
CONCERN OR THAT COULD BE ADDRESS
IN SOME WAY.
YES I I LIKE I SAID I THOUGHT
THAT THE FEDS WERE AHEAD OF THIS
ONE IF I'M MISTAKEN ON THAT
THEY'RE ABOUT TO BE THIS IS --
ALREADY APPROVED BY THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF CITY
TRANSPORTATION OFFICIALS AND THE
FHWA IS CATCHING UP.
OKAY IF IF YOU COULD PROVIDE IF
IT IF YOU COULD JUST.
YEAH SURE SURE YEAH THEY ARE
VERY MUCH.
YEAH QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE
OF THE AUTHOR. THREE THIS WAS
LIKE CLOSE YOU KNOW THE ONLY
CONCLUSION I HAS IT HAVE IS I
RESPECT THE ASPEN AYE BONES ONLY
THIS IS GOOD PLANNING THIS IS --
YOU KNOW A GOOD CHANGE IN POLICY
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE.
DO DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
ENCOURAGE SAFETY ON OUR STREETS
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES IN
CYCLES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT MR IS
ALWAYS FOR YOUR BILL TODAY MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THERE'S A
WORKING GROUP BECAUSE OF THIS
BILL.
WILL BE PUTTING OF W. HHA
TOGETHER WITH CALTRANS AND OTHER
INTERESTED PARTIES TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE'S NO.
QUESTION WHEN IT IS IT IS AND IF
IT IMPLEMENTED.
A MAN AS A CYCLIST MYSELF I
SAFETY IS IMPORTANT TO ME ALSO.
HAS TO CONTINUE TO PROMOTE MORE
ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION.
INCLUDING THE DOUBLING ITS
FUNDING.
FROM SB ONE WE MUST WORK ON
MAKING SURE THE MORE THE
MOTORIST.
CYCLISTS AND PEDESTRIANS CAN CO
EXIST SEC YOU KNOW.
SAFELY.
AND WITH THAT WE HAVE A FIRST
MISTER BERMAN SECOND FROM MR
DAILY -- MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
FRAZIER.
HI FRAZIER AYE FONG.
PHONE NOT VOTING AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NOT VOTING [inaudible]
TO CUNNINGHAM.
DALY.
DALY AYE DEEP [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE MEDINA.
NAZARIAN.
IS THERE AND I O'DONNELL.
THAT IS SEVEN LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN CRAP SOME MEMBERS THANK YOU.
I SAW SOME THE OTHER YAWNING
MISTER A JONES SAWYER.
HEY GET YOUR GET YOU FIRED UP.
IT'S OKAY WITH YOU WILL START
WITH A B..
THIRTEEN TWENTY FIVE DELYLAH.
NO I WASN'T YANNI KNOWS SAYING
HEY I'M NEXT.
I MEAN BECAUSE GOOD AFTERNOON
GOOD EVENING GOOD NIGHT CHAIRMAN --
I COME BEFORE YOU TODAY TO
PRESENT AB THIRTEEN TWENTY FIVE
A BILL THAT WOULD PROVIDE
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PAY PARKING AND
TRAFFIC TICKETS.
THE A COMMUNITY SERVICE
CALIFORNIA FACES A HOUSING
CRISIS AND LOS ANGELES ALONE
THERE ARE OVER FIFTY THOUSAND
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS MAYES
INDIVIDUALS ARE LIVING IN THE
STREETS PARKS OR EVEN IN THEIR
VEHICLES. FOR THESE INDIVIDUALS
LOSING THEIR VEHICLE DOESN'T
JUST MEAN THAT LOSING THAT THAT
THEY'RE LOSING ONLY MODE OF
TRANSPORTATION IT ALSO MEANS ARE
LOSING THEIR HOME.
CITIES AND NONPROFITS IN LOS
ANGELES SAN DIEGO.
SANTA BARBARA AND SAN JOSE
EXPLORED NEW APPROACHES TO HELP
YOUR VEHICULAR HOMELESS THROUGH
SELF PARKING PROGRAMS.
THESE INNOVATIVE PROGRAMS
PROVIDE TO VEHICULAR OF HOMELESS
A SAFE PLACE TO PARK FOR FREE
OVERNIGHT WITHOUT FEAR OF BEING
A RASTER TICKETED.
PROGRAMS PROGRAMS LIKE SAFE
PARKING LA CONNECT INDIVIDUALS
WITH COUNSELING AND A SYSTEM
WITH FINDING HOUSING.
HOWEVER WHEN PROVIDED THE
SERVICES THE VEHICULAR HOMELESS
REMAIN AT RISK OF LOSING THEIR
VEHICLE OR BEING BURDENED WITH
DEBT.
IT IS UNFAIR TO NOT PROVIDE
THESE INDIVIDUALS AN OPPORTUNITY
TO PAY OFF THEIR TICKETS THROUGH
COMMUNITY SERVICE WHEN WE
REVIVED THAT OPTION FOR CRIMINAL
VIOLATIONS.
I WANT TO BE CLEAR HAVING PEOPLE
LIVE IN YOUR VEHICLE IS NOT A
PERMANENT SOLUTION UNFORTUNATELY
WE HAVE FAILED CALIFORNIANS AND
LEFT MANY WITHOUT ANY OTHER
CHOICE.
MUST PROVIDE PEOPLE A CHANCE TO
SUCCEED IN AB THIRTEEN TWENTY
FIVE DOES THAT BY GIVING PEOPLE
REASONABLE WAY TO PAY OFF THEIR
TICKETS WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY.
IS AMY PERKINS DIRECTOR OF IN A
HIGHS AND STRATEGIES FOR THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES SPONSORS OF
THE BILL.
AND IT'S SOMEBODY ELSE --
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK THREE
RIGHT THOUGH.
THANK YOU MISTER JONES.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME THE RIVERS I AM ANY PERKINS
REPRESENTING THEM MAYOR CARCETTI
FROM LOS ANGELES THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN FRAZIER VICE CHAIR FONG.
THANK YOU SO MUCH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JONES SAWYER FOR
AUTHORING THIS REALLY IMPORTANT
BILL.
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE CALL THEIR
CAR HOME THIS BILL PROMISES TO
PROVIDE INCREDIBLY NEEDED RELIEF.
LOS ANGELES HAS A VERY
SUCCESSFUL CAP PROGRAM ALREADY
OPERATING WHICH IS THE COMMUNITY
ASSISTANCE PARKING PROGRAM.
WHAT I LOVED ESPECIALLY ABOUT
THIS PROGRAM IS THAT IT MATCHES
PEOPLE WHO ARE HOMELESS WITH A
PROVIDER WHO WILL ASSIGN THEM
TASKS AS THEY'RE WORKING OFF
THIS COMMUNITY SERVICE IN LIEU
OF PAYING THEIR CITATIONS?
THIS GIVES THEM AN OPPORTUNITY
TO CONNECT TO AN EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITY CONNECT TO A
PROVIDER WHO MAY END UP HIRING
THEM OR GIVING THEM SOME
EXPERIENCE ON THEIR RESUME OR
EVEN GIVING THEM A GENERAL
REFERENCE FOR ANOTHER JOB.
SO WE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR FOR
BRINGING THIS TODAY IT'S
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT AND
APPRECIATED AND WE ENCOURAGE
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS WOULD YOU STAND UP
AND INTRODUCE YOURSELF.
PLAYSTATION. FOR THE RECORD
MISTER CHAIR.
MY CAROL WITH THE WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY A WE TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL WE'RE UP HERE
EARLIER TODAY WITH MR CHOO'S
BILL ON TOWING.
AND WE SEE THIS IS A COMPLETE
COMPLEMENT TO WHAT -- THAT BILLS
GOALS ARE WHICH IS TO REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF TOES MAKE SURE THE
PEOPLE ARE GETTING THE SERVICES
AS A REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE
CITY OF LA SAID.
AND HELP THESE PEOPLE GET THE
SERVICES THAT THEY NEED AND THEN
I THINK MOST IMPORTANTLY HERE BY
THIS IS A VERY CREATIVE USE OF
COMMUNITY SERVICE WE THINK.
IT REALLY WELL AND SET UP YOU
KNOW HAVING PEOPLE DO TASK THIS
WILL ALLOW THEM TO KIND OF WORK
AUTHOR FIND.
AND GET THE SERVICES THEY NEED
HOPEFULLY TO GET HOUSE AND OUT
OF THE CAR SO WE SUPPORT THE
BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT THE
AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE.
IN MEMBERS THE PUBLIC FEEL LIKE
SAYS FINE OPPOSITION OR SHARE
THE CONCERNS.
WITH THE AUTHORS BILL.
MOVE BACK TO THE COMMITTEE MAKE
HAVE QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR.
MISTER JONES SAWYER WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK
THE AYE BOAT THANK YOU -- I WILL
REALLY THANK YOU FOR COMING TO
GET OUR COMMITTEE ON THIS AND TO
EXPAND THE APPLICATION OF THIS
BILL TO ALL.
HOMELESS.
INDIVIDUALS NOT JUST WANT TO
HAVE ACCESS TO SAFE PARKING
PROGRAMS AND FOR THAT I AM VERY
THANKFUL AND THEN I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY.
I DO HAVE A FIRST BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON THE SECOND
WAY SOMEONE OR BIGELOW.
I'VE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE FONG.
FONG I YEAR CURRY.
I BERMAN.
HI BERMAN AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE CHIU [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
DALY.
DALY AYE DEEP.
DEEP I FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON HI GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE MEDINA [inaudible]
NAZARIAN [inaudible]
DONALD [inaudible]
OR DON'T [inaudible]
AND I WITH.
IT IS TOTALLY THE ROLE PERHAPS
MEMBERS WE LIKE TO PROCEED.
ON TO YOUR NEXT BILL WHICH IS --
SIXTEEN EIGHTEEN CENTURY -- GOOD
AFTERNOON OR GOOD EVENING
MEMBERS I'M HERE TO PRESENT
EVERY FEELS A CAT A COURT'S
AUTHORITY TO SUSPEND DRIVERS
PRIVILEGES FOR VANDALISM IN
RECENT YEARS.
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN MOVING
TOWARDS ANY TO PRACTICE OF
SUSPENDING DRIVING PRIVILEGES
FOR INFRACTIONS I'M RELATED TO
DRIVING SUCH AS UNPAID FINES AND
TRUANCY.
CURRENTLY A COURT WAS REQUIRED
TO SUSPEND OR DELAYED DRIVING
PRIVILEGES. FOR ONE TO THREE
YEARS WHEN A PERSON IS CONVICTED
OF VANDALISM SUSPENDING DRIVING
PRIVILEGES FOR INFRACTIONS I'M
RELATED TO DRIVING CREATED
UNNECESSARY BURDEN OF PEOPLE WHO
HAVE TO COMMUTE TO SCHOOL.
AND MEDICAL VISITS OR WORK.
ACCORDING TO THE WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW POVERTY LOW INCOME
FAMILIES AND PEOPLE OF COLOR ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED BY
LICENSE SUSPENSIONS THE ABILITY
TO DRIVE IS CRUCIAL FOR MANY LOW
INCOME FAMILIES.
THEY'RE OFTEN THEY OFTEN COMMUTE
TO WORK AT A FARTHER DISTANCE TO
WORK LATE SHIFTS MAKING IT
HARDER TO RELY ON PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION.
AB SIXTEEN EIGHTEEN WHAT
CONTINUE TO PUT THE FOCUS ON
INFRACTIONS RELATED TO DRIVING
BY REMOVING COURTS ABILITIES HAS
BEEN A PERSON'S LIFE AND FOR
VANDALISM.
HERE TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS IS IS FROM MY INGRAM
FROM THE ACLU MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE GUY THOUGH.
MY ANGER -- ACLU OF CALIFORNIA
AND SUPPORT DRIVERS LICENSE
SUSPENSIONS CAN CREATE A VICIOUS
ECONOMIC CYCLE FOR INDIVIDUALS I
CAN BE VERY HARD TO BREAK WE'VE
SEEN THAT CALIFORNIA'S LEGACY OF
USING THIS AS A PUNISHMENT FOR
OFFENSES NOT RELATED TO SAFE
DRIVING.
HAS DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
CALIFORNIANS WHEN WE SUSPENDED
LICENSE FOR FAILURE TO APPEAR OR
PAY A TICKET WE SAW THAT THE
HIGHEST SUSPENSION RATES FOR
NEIGHBORHOODS WITH HIGH POVERTY
RATES.
AND HIGH PERCENTAGES OF BLACK
AND LATINO RESIDENTS BLACK
LATINO RESIDENTS WITHIN
DISPROPORTIONATELY ARRESTED FOR
DRIVING ON A SUSPENDED LICENSE.
CALIFORNIA HAS TAKEN BY PARTISAN
INITIATIVE TO REVERSE THIS
COURSE AND WE BELIEVE THIS IS A
COMMON SENSE OF BILLS THAT
ALIGNS WITH THAT PATH THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE [inaudible]
IN SUPPORT.
OKAY -- MY CARE WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY ALSO
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HEAR THEM WHAT THIS IS FOR THE
AUTHORS BUILT [inaudible]
SEEING NONE [inaudible]
ANY.
MEMBERS THE PUBLIC THERE LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OR HAVE
CONCERNS WITH AUTHORS BILL --
MOTION.
MR OF OF QUESTION COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
THE AUTHORED [inaudible]
NONE.
WE JUST CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE.
HI MISTER JONES SAWYER THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AGAIN BRING THIS
FORWARD.
THE ASSEMBLY TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE WAS RIGHT TWENTY NINE
YEARS AGO.
WHEN THEY SAID SUSPENDING
DRIVER'S LICENSES FOR VANDALISM?
IS BAD POLICY.
DRIVING IS ESSENTIALLY SHOULD BE
RESERVED FOR DANGEROUS DRIVERS
OR ONE FEDERALLY REQUIRED.
AND WITH THAT I'LL BE SUPPORTING
YOUR BILL TODAY THAT THIS FIRST
BY MR GRAYSON.
SECOND BY MISTER GIPSON.
KIND OF SECRETARY CULTURAL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE FONG.
FONG NO AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE BIGELOW [inaudible]
CHIU.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
DALY.
DALY AYE DEEP [inaudible]
DEEP NOW [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON HI GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
AND I MEDINA.
THIS AREA.
HI NAZARIAN AYE O'DONNELL.
THAT IS THE WILL LEAVE THE RULES
AND PERHAPS A MEMBERS THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
MISTER LACKEY. THIRTEEN FIFTY
ONE PLEASE [inaudible]
PLEASE PROCEED.
UP TO A GOOD START.
THANK YOU A MISTER CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I'D FIRST LIKE TO BEGIN BY
THANKING -- MISTER CHAIR AND
FIRST AFTER WORKING.
WITH OUR OFFICE ON THIS BILL.
A SECOND SECOND WAS REALLY
APPRECIATED I APPRECIATE THAT.
AB I'LL TRY TO BE QUICK I
PROMISE.
AB THIRTY FIFTY ONE WHAT
AUTHORIZES THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY TO CONSULT
WITH PUBLIC TRANSIT. TO ASSESS
THE PROCEDURES IN ADMINISTRATION
OF RIDE SERVICES FOR INDIVIDUALS
WITH PHYSICAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES.
YOU COULD TAKE NEARLY A MONTH.
FOR A PERSON WITH A DISABILITY
CAN USE AND AGENCIES PARA
TRANSIT SERVICE FROM CONSIDERING
THE ENTIRETY OF THE APPLICATION
PROCESS.
MOREOVER IT'S EVEN MORE
BURDENSOME FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES WHO NEED A RIDE IN
A JURISDICTION.
OUTSIDE OF THEIR ORIGINALLY
APPROVED SERVICE AREA. FOR
EXAMPLE IF AN INDIVIDUAL WAS
DEEMED ELIGIBLE FOR SERVICES
SACRAMENTO.
BUT WAS VISITING IN THE LOS
ANGELES SERVICE AREA.
THAT INDIVIDUAL WOULD HAVE TO GO
THROUGH A LENGTHY PROCESS TO
PROVE THEIR ELIGIBILITY WHICH
INVOLVES A FAX MACHINE.
THIS BILL INITIATES THE PROCESS
OF AND I'M NOT KIDDING -- IN
WHICH OUR STATE CAN BEGIN
IDENTIFYING GAPS IN THE DIAL THE
RIGHT PAIR TRANSIT SYSTEM AND
BEGIN STREAMLINING THE PROCESS
WHICH INDIVIDUALS WITH PHYSICAL
AND DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
CAN -- USE RIGHT SERVICES FREE
THEY WITH ME TODAY REAL BRIEFLY
WILL BE DANIEL SABINO.
DANIEL SERVING -- ASSOCIATION OF
REGIONAL CENTER AGENCIES BRIEFLY
IF ANY OF YOUR CONSTITUENTS CAME
UP HERE TO VISIT YOU NEED PARA
TRANSIT THAT HAVE TO GO THROUGH
A LONG PROCESS TO GET THAT SAME
SERVICE APPROVED UP HERE.
THIS IS A VERY SIMPLE ISSUE OF
X..
EQUITY OF ACCESS AND WE VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE MEMBERS --
LEADERSHIP ON THIS AND OF COURSE
THE COMMITTEE'S CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THE LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THE AUTHORS BILL.
ANY MEMBERS THE PUBLIC TO LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THE
AUTHORS BILL OR SHARE CONCERNS.
ME SO FOR STATE YOUR NAME WHO
YOU'RE REPRESENTING.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN VERSE
MICHAEL CAM TELL THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSIT ASSOCIATION -- FOR
REGRETTABLY IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL -- THE BILL BEFORE YOU
TODAY WOULD REQUIRE AS YOU KNOW
THE CAN CALVINISTIC
TRANSPORTATION ASSIST -- AGENCY
TO ASSESS THE PROCEDURES PUBLIC
TRANSIT AGENCIES USED TO GRANT
VISITOR STATUS FOR EDA AND
GOTTEN DOWNRIGHT SERVICES. TO
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES
AND AUTHORIZES THEM TO ADOPT
GUIDELINES ESTABLISHED A WIDE
RECIPROCITY -- WE BELIEVE THAT
GENERALLY THE STATEWIDE PERSON
THAT STATEWIDE RECIPROCITY IS
ALREADY THE LAW OF THE LAND AND
SPOKEN TO CLEARLY AN EXISTING
FEDERAL AND STATE LAW.
INTO THE CENTER THERE'S
FRAGMENTATION THE PROCEDURES
AGENCIES HOLOGRAM VISITOR
SARACEN AND AND WE RECOGNIZE
THAT THERE IS -- RESULTS FROM
DIFFERENCES IN STAFFING
RESOURCES FUNDING BILL ABILITY
IN THE USE OF IN HOUSE VERSUS
CONTRACT -- SERVICE PROVIDERS ON
THIS SORT OF FRAGMENTATION IS
NOT DISSIMILAR FROM WHAT WE SEE
ELSEWHERE IN TRANSIT OPERATIONS
WHETHER THAT'S FAIR PAYMENT WE
FINDING.
RATHER MEANS -- FOR MANY OF THE
SAME REASONS -- WE BELIEVE
WHAT'S NEED IS GREATER
CONSISTENCY IN HOW PROCEDURES
FOR OBTAINING THIS OR STATUS ARE
COMMUNICATED TO THE INDIVIDUALS
WITH DISABILITIES OR THE ELDERLY.
AND TO THAT END WE SUGGESTED A
DIFFERENT APPROACH TO THE ISSUE
THIS BILL SEEKS TO ADDRESS.
WHICH WHATEVER PARTY TRANSIT
AGENCY TO POST ON THE FRONT PAGE
OF THE INTERNET WEBSITE -- IN
PLAIN LANGUAGE AND IN A COMMON
FORMAT THE PROCEDURES FOR
OBTAINING VISITOR STATUS FOR EDA
AND DOLLAR RIGHT SERVICES.
SURE THING -- THIS REQUIREMENT
COULD BEEN EXTENDED TO A COMMON
SCRIPT -- FOR FOR PHONE CALLS --
AND MOREOVER WE UNDERSTAND AS
THE AUTHOR NOTED THAT SOME
AGENCIES ARE STILL USING FAX
MACHINES WE WOULD HAVE ENDORSED
A STRATEGY THAT WOULD REQUIRE
THAT THE EXCEPT ELIGIBILITY
CERTIFICATION V. ELECTRONICS THE
MIDDLE.
AND WITH THAT -- BECAUSE WE
WEREN'T ABLE TO REACH AGREEMENT --
WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
LEGISLATION THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR THAT.
THE OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THAT HAVE IN OPPOSITION TO THE
AUTHORS BILLER CONCERNS.
CINEMA BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE OF THE AUTHOR.
MR LIKE HE WAS LIKE CLOSE.
JUST WITH US FOR YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THIS VERY IMPORTANT BILL FOR
THESE PEOPLE WHO NEED YOUR HELP --
MISTER.
I KIßM THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD.
AS YOU KNOW IN THE CHAIR OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE FOR ALL THE
INTELLECTUAL.
AND DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
IN CALIFORNIA.
I HAVE HEARD ABOUT HOW MUCH
TRANSPORTATION CONTRIBUTED
PEOPLE'S INDEPENDENCE AND
QUALITY OF LIFE.
AS A STATE WE MUST DO EVERYTHING
WE CAN DO TO MAKE TRANSPORTATION
OPTIONS FOR PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AN EASIER AND
SEAMLESS AS POSSIBLE.
EVEN WHEN THEY ARE VISITING
ANOTHER JURISDICTION.
I'M DISAPPOINTED IN THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION SO
ASSOCIATIONS POSE THE ASSESSMENT
OF THE BILL BECAUSE WE HIGHLY
SUBSIDIZED.
PUBLIC TRANS THANK YOU.
I HOPE THAT THE IS THIS BILL
MOVES FOR THEY WILL DECIDE TO
WORK WITH YOU.
BECAUSE IF NOT I'LL HELP YOU
PUSH IT ALL THE WAY TO THE
GOVERNOR.
THANK YOU CHAIR -- MADAM
SECRETARY HAVE THE FIRST AYE MR
FONG IS SECOND BY MISTER GIBSON --
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
FRAZIER HI FRAZIER AYE FONG AYE
FONG AYE AYE GEAR CURRY.
I I BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE TI<c.cyan>.</c>
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE DALY AYE DALY AYE
DEEP.
DEEP I FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON HI GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE MEDINA.
I MEDINA I IN THIS AREA.
JERRY AND I O'DONNELL
[inaudible]
IT OVER [inaudible]
BERMAN I THAT IS THIRTY MILLION
ROLLED IN PERHAPS MEMBERS THANK
YOU MISTER LACKEY MAKES CHEN MY
HELP LET ME KNOW PLEASE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
SO WE'RE GONNA GO WITH MR CHOO'S.
MR TO REALLY LOOK AT EIGHT OO
EIGHT ABA FADE AWAY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF A WALLACE THANK YOU
COMING STAFF FOR YOUR WORK ON
THIS BILL -- THAT THIS BILL
ORIGINALLY WAS WRITTEN TO
REQUIRE.
DAD WHEN TO THE DRIVER TURN ON
DAY OR WHITE PER.
OF OF A WHILE WE NOTE THAT IT
ACTUALLY IS THE EXISTING LAW.
DEV MINDED ONE WHEN YOU'RE
DRIVING IN THE RAIN YOU TURN ON
YOUR WIPERS YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO
TURN ON YOUR HEADLIGHTS.
BUT IT IS THIS A VERY VERY HARD
TO ENFORCE YOU KNOW THIS BILL
WAS BROUGHT TO ME BY SOME
MEMBERS IN THE COMMUNITY.
THAT ONE DAY YOU WILL DURING THE
RAINY SEASON THE CITY OF ABOUT
ONE IN FIVE CARDS ACTUALLY TURN
ON THEIR HEADLIGHTS.
THEN IN BECAUSE IS VERY VERY
DIFFICULT -- TO TO TO ENFORCE IT.
SO WHAT WHAT THAT -- TO PROMPT
ME FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD.
BUT AFTER.
REVIEWING OF WHAT WE'RE TALKING
TO SOME OF THE OTHER CAR
MANUFACTURERS.
YOU KNOW THEY USE.
WHAT I LEARNED THAT THE RIGHT
NOW LIKE IN GM GENERAL WALTER
THE ALL THEIR FLEETS?
WILL HAVE TO RUN THE LIGHT TOM.
WIN WIN -- ALL THE TIME.
AND ALSO THIS IS THE ALSO AGREED --
LOGGING IN CANADA I REQUIRE ANY
CARS THAT THE ASSAULTING CANDOR
THAT WILL HELP THEIR HEADLIGHTS
ON AND TELL LIKE TOM.
SO.
JUST TO MAKE THEY IMPLEMENTATION
EASIER.
OF ALL I WOULD JUST DO THE
AMENDMENT TO SAY WHAT WILL
FOLLOW THAT THE THAT THE
CANADIAN LAW. TO SAY YOU KNOW TO
ALWAYS HALF THE HEADLIGHTS ON
AND THE TAIL LIGHT ON OF AND
WHEN YOU'RE DRIVING.
THEM I ALSO KNOW THE BENEFIT
LIKE OF THE A LOT OF THE
CALIFORNIA FREEWAYS LIKE BUT ONE
FIFTY TWO THIS ALSO APPLIED AT
THE DISTRICT WHICH CONNECT THE
INTERSTATE FIVE AND WHILE.
ONE THERE'S A SESSION TO JUST
TELL YOU TO TURN ON YOUR HELLO
YOU MEN IN IN THE BROUGHT BRIGHT
DAYLIGHT AND AGAIN.
IN A A VERY -- FEEL PEOPLE
REALLY REALLY -- OF OF FOLLOW
THAT THE LAW TO TURN ON THE
LIGHT SO OF THE DUE DATE TO CUT
THEY A MEMBER IN THIS.
TOO I HAVE STILL ALL THE CAR
MANUFACTURERS.
NEWS WOULD BE A DETERRENT.
TO HOW THE HELL HELL LIGHT THAT
THE THAT THE RUNNING LIGHTS ON
AND THE AND THE TAIL LIGHTS ALL.
ON ALL THE CARS THAT THIS SHOW
TO TO WORK A CALIFORNIA.
AND THIS IS NOT THE FIRST TIME
THOUGH THE CALIFORNIA SET THE
PACE. FOR A PHOTO FOR THE NATION --
I UNDERSTAND THERE'S A TWENTY
SOME DIFFERENT STATE ALREADY
HEALTH TO SIMILAR LAW TO SAY HEY
TURN TURN ON YOUR HEADLIGHTS.
ON WHEN YOU TURN ON YOUR WIFE.
ESPECIALLY THE THE TELL LIGHTS
IMPORTANT FOR PEOPLE. TO TO TO
SEAL TO TO MAKE SURE YOU YOUR
VISIBLE.
AND IT DID DEPART DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION ALSO HAS SOME
STUDY THERE'S A THE THE WEATHER
RELATED ACCIDENT MAKE UP TO
ABOUT 21% OF ALL ACCIDENTS ON
THE ROAD.
AND AND ALSO THE ODORS SOME
STUDIES YOU SHOULD THE SHOWED
THAT -- CARS WHICH WERE.
RUNNING LIGHTS ON WILL REDUCE
THE ACCIDENT RATE JUST TO UP
210% ONE STUDY CONCLUDED BY DIET
PILL CARS WITHOUT THE LIFESAVING
LIGHT.
A WITH ALL THE LIGHT RUNNING
LIGHT ON A ONE POINT SEVEN THREE
TIMES MORE LIKELY TO BE INVOLVED
WITH THE COLLISION BANK CARD --
WITH -- DAYLIGHT SAVING TIME ON
SO I THINK THIS IS A BILL I I
WOULD ILL DAY DAVE THE
MANUFACTURERS OF OF HOLES IN A
IN PRINCIPLE CON MAN THIS IS
TRULY AND THE IMPLEMENTATION TO
THEY KNOW HOW TO DO IT.
THEY AGREED THAT IS A GOOD
SAFETY FUTURE.
AND I AND I BELIEVE THAT THIS
ACTUALLY -- A GOOD MARKET BASED
ARGUMENT FOR THEM.
AND THE CARS HE QUIPPED DID WAS
THE OF WAS JUST FUTURE PROBABLY
WILL SELL BETTER THAN OTHERS
WITHOUT IT.
SO -- GM ACTUALLY AND MADE THE
PETITION TO THE NATIONAL HIGHWAY
TRAFFIC SAFETY ADMINISTRATION --
TO REQUIRED THAT THE LIFESAVING
DAYLIGHT WHEN THE LIGHTS ON AS
THE NATIONAL STANDARD IN.
TWO THOUSAND NINE I KNOW I CAN'T
WAIT FOR THE DAY CONGRESS TO TO
ACT ON ON ON ISSUES LIKE THAT.
BUT I FAILED THAT -- THE
CALIFORNIA WE CAN DEMONSTRATE TO
TO TO TO COME TO TO THE OTHER
STATE.
AND TO THE CONGRESS THAT WE
VALUE OUR A DAYS CALIFORNIANS
LIFE BETTER THAN ALL THE OTHER
STATES.
SO INSTEAD OF WAITING FOR THE
CONGRESS TO ADD ON THIS BILL I
DECIDED TO OF A MOVE FOR AN
INDUSTRY TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE.
MY CONGRESSMAN A REAL CON THE
OLD ALSO COMMITTED TO CARRY THE
BILL IN THE AND IN THE CONGRESS
BUT AGAIN.
IN CELL AWAITING I WILL LIKE --
TO PRESENTED. TO TO TO THIS
COMMITTEE AND I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY AND ASK FOR YOUR IBM.
MR SHOULD YOU HAVE A WITNESS IN
SUPPORT.
THIS IS FROM THE PUBLIC THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SEE. TO A
SUPPORTER AUTHORS BILL.
MEMBERS THE PUBLIC THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
THE AUTHORS BILL OR SHARE
CONCERNS.
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME ONLY
REPRESENT PLEASE.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JOHN MOFFITT ON BEHALF
OF THE ALLIANCE OF AUTOMOBILE
MANUFACTURERS WE WE APPRECIATE
THE THE AUTHORS CONCERNING THE
CONVERSATIONS WE'VE HAD ABOUT
THIS PARTICULAR BILL BUT
UNFORTUNATELY WERE OPPOSED --
THE VEHICLE SAFETY VEHICLE
DESIGN IT WE BELIEVE IS THE THE
EXCLUSIVE JURISDICTION OF THE
NATIONAL HIGHWAY TRANSPORTATION
SAFETY ADMINISTRATION -- WE
RESIST YOU KNOW BILLS AND PRETTY
MUCH ANY STATE WHERE -- THEY
THEY LOOK TO IMPOSE STATE
SPECIFIC REQUIREMENTS -- THE THE
AUTHOR NOTED THAT AND IT'S A
LOOKED AT THIS ISSUE IN TWO
THOUSAND AND NINE AT THAT TIME
THEY REJECTED -- THE THE
PROPOSITION TO ADOPT THAT IS A
SAFETY -- MANDATORY SAFETY
STANDARDS IF IT BECOMES
NECESSARY IN THE FUTURE THEY CAN
ALWAYS LOOK AT IT AGAIN. FOR
THESE REASONS PROPOSED THE BILL.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS A CRISP
OUR ON BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION
OF THE GLOBAL AUTOMAKERS.
AGAIN THE CONCUR WITH MISTER
MOFFETT'S REMARKS AND ALSO WANT
TO WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO THE
AUTHOR OF POINT OUT THAT NOT
ONLY DOES OUR CLIENT HAVE
CONCERNS.
ON PRINCIPLE WITH WITH THIS BILL
BUT ALSO POINT OUT THERE'S ALSO
HUGE LOGISTICAL PROBLEMS WITH
REGARDS -- TO OUR MANUFACTURES
IN TERMS OF THE AMOUNT OF TIME
IT TAKES FROM GOING FROM --
PLANNING DEVELOPMENT AND GETTING
A CAR TO MARKET IS A
CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT OF TIME MUCH
LONGER THAN WHAT THIS BILLS TIME
ONE WOULD PROVIDE IS COMPLETELY
UNREALISTIC AND WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT A VIRGIN A NO VOTE ON
THE BILL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THESE ARE TO STATE YOUR NAME AND
WE REPRESENT PLEASE YES OVER
THORN CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE WHILE WE APPRECIATE THE
OTHER SCHOOLS OF SAFETY WE ARE
OPPOSE FOR THE REASONS OUTLINED
BY MY COLLEAGUES.
THANK YOU ANY MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE WILL BRING IT BACK.
QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR.
MISTER IS THERE IN [inaudible]
UP.
WHAT IS A REASONABLE TIME LINE
TO IMPLEMENT SOMETHING LIKE THIS?
YOU DON'T GENERALLY VEHICLE
DESIGN FROM FIRST IDEAS AND
ENGINEERING IS EIGHT TO TEN
YEARS.
I MEAN ON ON SORT ON ANY ASPECT
OF OF THE VEHICLE.
AND HAVE YOU WORKED WITH THE
AUTHOR -- TO TRY TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE.
WE'VE HAD SEVERAL CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE DOCTOR'S OFFICE WITH
THE STAFF AND AND AND EXPLAIN
OUR CONCERNS WITH THE BILL I
MEAN AGAIN.
NOT ONLY DO WE HAVE CONCERNS
WITH THE LOGISTICS IN TERMS THE
PRACTICAL IMPACT WOULD PLACE ON
THE AUTO MANUFACTURES THE OTHER
RIGHT REALITY IS IS THAT WE
STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT --
ANYTHING THAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WOULD DO PURSUANT TO
THIS PARTICULAR MISSION WOULD BE --
PRECLUDED FROM NOT PREEMPTED BY
FEDERAL LAW -- THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I DID YOU SEE TWENTY SEVEN
STATES I'M SORRY DID YOU SEE
THAT TWENTY SEVEN STATES HAVE
ALREADY. TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR IS ROUTE THE STATE HOUSE
THE LAW ALL THOSE WHO REQUIRED A
DRIVER TO TURN ON THEIR HOW
LIGHT -- WHEN WHEN WHEN THEY
TURN ON THEIR WIPER BUT AGAIN?
THAT'S VERY VERY DIFFICULT TO
TWO ONE FOUR FIVE I DON'T KNOW
IF TO SEE IF YOU HAD WRITTEN ANY.
OF THE TICKET FOR FOR THE
VIOLATORS.
IN IN CALIFORNIA SO.
AND AND THIS IS WHY I ASKED FOR
THE MANUFACTURERS TO TAKE SOME
RESPONSIBILITY.
THE TO TO TO TO MAY MAKE OR
THROUGH A SAFER SAVE SOME LIVES.
HI PAM IF I MAY SIR JUST TO
CLARIFY TO WITH REGARDS.
TO INCORRECTLY IF I'M WRONG SIR
RIGHT AT THE AUTHOR DISTRICT
SECURE IS REFERRING TO THE THIS
MEDIUM BILL CENTER SO MANY OF
BILL THAT.
REQUIRED FOLKS DRIVERS -- IN
INCLEMENT WEATHER THIS IS BACK
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN TO TURN ON
YOUR HEADLIGHTS.
WITH THE WIN SHARP WINDSHIELD
WIPERS ARE DR.
I'M NOT AWARE OF ANY -- STATE --
STUDIES -- HAVE HAD LOOKED INTO
THE EFFICACY OF THAT LAW SINCE
IT'S BEEN IN IN ENACTED FOR THE
LAST TEN YEARS.
WITH REGARD TO THETWENTY SEVEN
STATES I BELIEVE AGAIN -- 323-
STATES THAT'S WITH REGARDS TO
SOMETHING SIMILAR TO WHAT --
THAT THIS MEDIAN BILL REQUIRES
ITS OF THE DRIVER THIS BILL IS
DIFFERENT IT'S UNIQUE IT'S IT'S
PRESCRIBING A SPECIFIC DESIGN
REQUIREMENT OF THE VEHICLE.
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT THAN WHAT
MR SO MANY IS BILL DID BACK IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN THIS EXISTING
LAW AND THE OTHER. TWENTY THREE
TWENTY SO THEY ARE SIX SORRY.
SORRY I DIDN'T MAKE IT CLEAR
WITH THE TWENTY THREE STATES
THIS TO DRIVERS THE THE WIPERS
ON THE HAT TAILLIGHTS ARE.
RIGHT AND THIS BILL IS TRYING TO
SHOULD.
ASK THE MANUFACTURERS TO TAKE UP
SOME RESPONSIBILITY [inaudible]
SO.
WE'RE WERE THE FIRST CALIFORNIA.
I I'M WILLING TO SUPPORT IT SO
THAT MOVING FORWARD HOPEFULLY --
YOU'RE ABLE TO COME TO SOME
CONCLUSION OF WHERE YOU SEE.
THE APPROPRIATE MEDIUM IS -- BUT
FOR TODAY I'LL BE SUPPORTING IT
TO ME AT LEAST -- SEE IT MOVE
FORWARD.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE OF THE AUTHOR.
SEARCH USUALLY CLOSE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ON THE AGAIN -- I
BELIEVE THIS IS SOMETHING THAT.
ALL OF THEM MOST OF OUR CAR
MAKERS KNOW HOW TO DO.
IT -- TO THE TURN ON THAT THE
RUNNING LIGHTS AND THE
HEADLIGHTS WHEN YOU TURN ON THE
ENGINE.
I DON'T THINK THEY'RE REQUIRED
OF ME MAJOR.
ENGINEERING CHANGER TO SIGN.
AND I AM REALLY HOPING THAT THE
PRIVATE SECTOR CAN MOVE A LITTLE
BIT.
FASTER THAN OURS THE GOOD THE
GOOD GOVERNMENT AND AND I'M NOT
TAKING THE TEN YEAR TO IMPLEMENT
THIS.
AND ALSO BECAUSE OF THE BECAUSE
THIS IS ALREADY A CANADIAN LAW.
I THINK THE THE ANY HARDER STILL
THE MOVE. TO BE SOLD IN CANADA
WILL HAVE TO COMPLY WITH THIS --
AND THE HEADLIGHTS AND AND HELL
LIGHTS ALL IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
I BELIEVE SO -- WILL DISCUSS THE
PALE PRETTY MUCH YEAH THAT'S
COMING LINE WHAT WAS THE TIMING
FOR THE CANADIAN BILL TO TAKE
EFFECT -- AND AND TO DO IT AT
TWENTY TWENTY ONE IN I DO
BELIEVE THIS IS A IS A ADORABLE.
AND AGAIN I'LL ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
I'M NOT GONNA BE SUPPORTING YOUR
BILL TODAY COULD AND UNITED HAVE
THAT DISCUSSION.
OF I BELIEVE MOTOR VEHICLE STACY
SAFETY STANDARDS SHOULD BE UP TO
NHTSA NOW -- ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT YOU KNOW YOU TALK ABOUT THE
C. H. P. -- WE DID TRY TO ADD
OFFICERS LEISURE TO AID IN THAT
BUT IT WAS VETOED BY THE
GOVERNOR -- ACTUAL IS FOUR
HUNDRED EIGHTY OFFICERS OVER
FOUR YEARS -- BUT THAT WAS --
NOT CONSIDERED IMPORTANT.
THE OTHER THING IS IS WHEN YOU
TALK ABOUT HOPING IN RELYING ON
CONGRESS.
I WOULD NOT RELY ON ME EITHER.
SO I UNDERSTAND YOUR CONCERN IN
AND WANTING TO MOVE THE SCORE --
AS A COURTESY TO YOU AND RESPECT
AS A MEMBER OF THIS COMMITTEE
AND NOT CAN BE VOTING TODAY.
A WE HAVE A MOTION.
MISTER IS THERE IS FIRST.
MY SECOND IT'S JUST REPORTER TO
PULL IT UP FOR VOTE.
WE HAVE THE BLOOD.
THE BILL WILL DIE WITHOUT A LACK
OF THE SECOND [inaudible]
THE SEASON.
YEAH HE CAN.
SECOND YOU VOTE.
YOUR SECOND IN A SECOND OKAY
[inaudible]
MADAM SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL -- CALDERON.
THE MOTION IS TO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
FRAZIER.
FRAZIER NOT VOTING FONG
[inaudible]
CHRONO.
AGUIAR-CURRY NOT VOTING BERMAN.
BERMAN NOT VOTING BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NOW JUNE.
ALL RIGHT CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NO DALY.
DALY NOT VOTING FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN NOT VOTING GIPSON.
HI GIPSON HI GRAYSON.
GRAYSON NOT VOTING MEDINA.
MEDINA NOT BURNING NAZARIAN.
IS THERE AN AYE O'DONNELL.
IT HAS THREE MISTER -- TRULY THE
ROLE OPEN PRESS MEMBERS ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU [inaudible]
MR DATE.
MR CHEAP NUMBER. THREE THIS
FRIEDMAN.
AB.
ONE ONE ONE TWO THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB ELEVEN
TWELVE ESTABLISHES A BASIC LEVEL
OF STATEWIDE STANDARDS FOR LOCAL
REGULATION OF MOTORIZED SCOOTERS.
TO ENSURE CLARITY IN THE LAW TO
ENABLE ZERO EMISSION
TRANSPORTATION REDUCE TRAFFIC
CONGESTION AND INCREASED SAFETY
ON THE ROAD.
IN THE US 35% OF VEHICLE TRIPS
OR TWO MILES OR LESS IN LENGTH
ONE SOLUTION TO THESE CHALLENGES
IS THE GROWTH OF MICROBES
MOBILITY OPTIONS LIKE YOU
SCOOTERS.
THIS GROWING OPTIONS ARE AN
AFFORDABLE AND CONVENIENT
SOLUTION FOR THE SHORT CAR TRIPS.
EASE CRITTERS ARE A LAST MILE
LINK TO PUBLIC TRANSIT ENABLING
PEOPLE TO FLEXIBLY TRAVEL TO BUS
STOPS AND TRAIN STATIONS WITHOUT
THE NEED TO PARK A CAR OR SECURE
CURRENTLY THERE'S A PATCHWORK OF
ORDINANCES REGULATING EAST
COOTER SINCE MIMES NO REGULATION
AT ALL IN SOME LOCALITIES WITH
VERY REQUIREMENTS THAT MAKE IT
DIFFICULT FOR WRITERS UNDERSTAND
WHERE THEY'RE IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THERE'S NOT IN COMPLIANCE.
THIS ALSO MAKES IT COMPLICATED
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT TO A FOREIGN
FORCE AMONG THE DIFFERENT LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS WITHIN THEIR
TERRITORIES.
I INTEND TO WORK WITH THE LEAGUE
OF CITIES AND OTHER LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THAT HAVE CONCERNS
WITH THE CURRNT LANGUAGE OF THE
BILL TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE
SOMETHING THAT'S WORKABLE FOR
MUNICIPALITIES.
THANK YOU MEMBERS I BELIEVE THIS
BILL PROVIDES A REASONABLE
STATEWIDE FRAMEWORK AND IS
NECESSARY FOR THIS GROWING
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR.
WITH ME TODAY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN TWELVE
ARMORIES HENDERSON DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT PARTNERSHIPS A BIRD
SCOOTERS.
AND JULIE AND THE CANAL --
CONNECT WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HISPANIC CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
WHOEVER WOULD LIKE TO START.
THANKS THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB. ELEVEN
TWELVE MY NAME IS MAURICE
HENDERSON AND I'M DIRECTOR
GOVERNMENT PARTNERSHIPS WITH
BIRD SCOOTERS I'D ALSO LIKE TO
THANK THE AUTHOR AND HER STAFF
FOR THE WORK THEY DON'T US TO
DATE.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL AND
AS THE AUTHOR NOTES BELIEVE IT
IS PART OF THE STATE'S SOLUTION
TO REACHING CALIFORNIA'S
ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS.
BIRD IS A LAST SMILE ORCHARD
VEHICLE SHARING COMPANY
DEDICATED TO BRINGING AFFORDABLE
ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY
TRANSPORTATION SOLUTIONS TO
COMMITTEE TO COMMUNITIES.
ACROSS THE WORLD.
BIRDS MISSION OFFERS A MORE
EFFICIENT WAY TO MOVE PEOPLE
AROUND CITY STREETS YOU CAN MOVE
SEVENTY FIVE HUNDRED PEOPLE PER
HOUR IN A PROTECTED BIKE LANE.
AND APPROXIMATELY A THOUSAND
VEHICLES PER HOUR AND A HALF IN
THE AVERAGE CARLIN.
AFTER ONE YEAR OF OPERATING MORE
THAN. FOURTEEN MILLION MILES
HAVE BEEN WRITTEN ON BIRDS
AROUND THE WORLD.
WHICH IS PREVENTED MORE THAN
TWELVE MILLION POUNDS OF CARBON
EMISSIONS FROM ENTERING THE AIR.
IN ADDITION TO THE ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACTS OF BIRD WE HAVE INSURED
EQUABLE ACCESS CREATING MORE
AFFORDABLE AND RELIABLE
TRANSPORTATION OPTIONS FOR ALL
COMMUNITIES.
WE CREATED ONE BIRD FOR LOW
INCOME INDIVIDUALS WHO QUALIFY
FOR ASSISTANCE. TO HAVE THE ONE
DOLLAR UNLOCK FEE WAIVED FOR
EACH RIDE IN ADDITION WE CREATED
RED WHITE AND BIRD WHICH DOES
THE SAME FOR ACTIVE MILITARY AND
VETERANS WHO HAVE SERVED OUR
NATION.
FINALLY BIRD HAS HAD A POSITIVE
ECONOMIC IMPACT ON THE
COMMUNITIES WE SERVE IT IS
ESTIMATED THAT FOR EVERY ONE
THOUSAND BIRDS IN A CITY BURKE
CREATES AN ESTIMATED TWO AND A
HALF MILLION ANNUAL EARNINGS FOR
CHARGERS AND THREE HUNDRED
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES. FOR
EXAMPLE IN OAKLAND WE HAVE FOUND
THAT BIRD CAN SAVE MORE THAN
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND FOR
WRITERS IN AN AVERAGE MONTH WHEN
COMPARED TO THE COST OF TAKING A
TAXI UBER OR LIFT FOR SIMILAR
TRIPS. FOR THESE REASONS MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT A. B. ELEVEN TWELVE IN
ORIGIN I VOTE THANK YOU.
MAN UNION TWO MINUTES.
NEXTEL WITH THIS PLEASE THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY AND AND THANK YOU --
TO MEMBER FRIEDMAN FOR
INTRODUCING -- ELEVEN TWELVE
CALPERS MEDIC CHAMBERS FULLY
SUPPORTS -- ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN
TWELVE WITH PHYLLIS DEVILISH IS
MUCH NEEDED CLARIFICATION.
ELECTRIC SCOOTER REGULATIONS --
AS CALIFORNIA'S VEHICLE COLD
CURRENTS GOOD REGULATIONS ARE
CONFUSION AND I'M CLEAR.
CURRENTLY THERE IS A HAPHAZARD
AN ILL CONCEIVED PATCHWORK OF
ORDINANCES REGULATING ELECTRIC
SCOOTERS WITH VARYING
REQUIREMENTS THAT MAKE IT
DIFFICULT FOR WRITERS.
ENFORCEMENT AGENTS TO UNDERSTAND
COMPLIANCE.
AB ELEVEN TWELVE SOLVE THESE
ISSUE BY PROVIDING A CLEAR
STATEWIDE FRAMEWORK THAT ALSO
GIVES MUNICIPALITIES LOCAL
CONTROL OVER OR IMPORTANT
ASPECTS OF ELECTRIC SCOOTER
ADOPTION.
BY PASSING AB ELEVEN TWELVE
CALIFORNIA WILL ESTABLISH
UNIFORM REGULATORY GUIDELINES
THAT BRING THE STATE'S VEHICLE
CODE.
INTO ALIGNMENT WITH ITS
AMBITIONS TRANSPORTATION AND
CLIMATE GOALS.
IN CALIFORNIA 87% OF THE
POPULATION RESIDES IN URBAN
AREAS AND THOSE AREAS ARE
STRUGGLING TO MEET GROWING
TRANSPORTATION CONGESTION AND
PARKING NEEDS NOT EVERY WEEK
EVERYONE CAN LIVE OR WORK WITHIN
EASY WALKING DISTANCE OF A
TRANSIT STATION OR BUS STOP.
THE US -- CITIES EVEN ONES WITH
EXCELLENT PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEMS MUST RELY ON CAR TRANSIT
AND THEREBY SUFFER FROM TRAFFIC
CONGESTION.
PARKING -- PROBLEMS AND
EXCESSIVE AUTO EMISSIONS.
EASING CONGESTION AND EMISSIONS
IS CRUCIAL CRITICAL. TO OUR
HEALTH AND WELLNESS POOR AIR
QUALITY IS THE LARGEST
ENVIRONMENTAL RISK IN THE UNITED
STATES ACCORDING TO A STUDY SET.
TO BE PUBLISHED IN THE
PROCEEDINGS OF THE NATIONAL
ACADEMY OF SCIENCES FINE
PARTICULATE MATTER POLLUTION.
IS ESPECIALLY HARMFUL AND IS
RESPONSIVE FOR MORE THAN A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DEATHS EACH
YEAR FROM HEART ATTACKS STROKES.
LUNG CANCER AND OTHER DISEASES.
MICHAEL MOBILITY OPTIONS LIKE A
SCOOTER OFFER AFFORDABLE
CONVENIENT SOLUTIONS.
AS MY COLLEAGUE SAID THAT
PROVIDE FIRST SMILE AND LAST
MILE LINKS TO PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION WHERE 35% OF ALL
VEHICLE TRIPS IN UNITED STATES
OUR TWO MILES OF LASSEN LATE.
SO NATURAL TO WORK AROUND THOSE
PLEASE I'M GONNA MORE SENSE OF
AB ELEVEN TWELVE HELP
FINANCIALLY GOING TO ASK YOU TO
WRAP OKAY -- ENCLOSING A. B.
ELEVEN TWELVE OFFER HELPS ENABLE
A NEW FORM OF CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION IN CALIFORNIA AND
REMOVES CARS FROM THE ROAD
PROVIDES ACCESS TO PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION.
AND REDUCES TRAFFIC CONDITIONS
AND ULTIMATELY HELPING
CALIFORNIA ME TO CLEAN AIR --
TARGETS THANK YOU TO LEARN I WAS
A SUPPORT UNTIL THEN
[inaudible]
SO -- OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF THE AUTHORS BILL.
ALICIA CREATE ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL DIVERSITY COALITION AND
THE NATIONAL ASIAN AMERICAN
COALITION IN SUPPORT.
GOOD EVENING ANDREA DIVO FOR
CLEANING BECAUSE DEL CAMINO RIEL
IN VENTURA COUNTY CLINIC AS
DON'T DEL VALLEY IN MONTEREY
COUNTY IN THE CENTRAL COAST
HEALTH NETWORK IN SUPPORT.
TENER KELLY ON BEHALF OF FIXING
ANGELINO STUCK IN TRAFFIC
FASTING DOWNTOWN LA IN THE
ENVIRONMENTAL ENVIRONMENTAL
DEFENSE FUND IN SUPPORT THE UC
STUDENT ASSOCIATION HAS THAT
SUPPORT OF AMENDED POSITION. TO
AMEND TO INCLUDE COLLEGE
CAMPUSES THANK YOU.
ALIGNMENT SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GETTY ME MORE ABOUT IT WITH
CALIFORNIA ADVISERS ON BEHALF OF
COOPER WE HAVE A SUPPORT AMENDED
POSITION AS SPECIFICALLY AS
RELATES THE DATA PROVISIONS IN
THE BILL TRIP DATA AND THINGS
LIKE THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO
CONTINUE OUR CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE AUTHOR.
AT THE BILL MOVES FORWARD
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CATHERINE GARCIA WITH YOUR CLUB
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
DAVE SNYDER CALIFORNIA BICYCLE
COALITION IN SUPPORT IF AMENDED.
STEPHEN BOX TRANSIT COALITION IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE OF THE
AUTHOR [inaudible]
MISTER NAZARIAN.
I GUESS I'M THE ONLY ONE WHO HAS
A QUESTION SO YOU KNOW MISTER
NAZARIAN LET ME GO TO OPPOSITION
FIRST.
PLEASE -- I'M SORRY ABOUT THAT.
MEMBERS THE PUBLIC THE LIKES
TESTIFYING OPPOSITION.
OR HAVE CONCERNS OF THE BILL
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
S. A LEASH ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO MUNICIPAL
TRANSPORTATION -- AT THE AGENCY
SORRY -- AFTER THE UNREGULATED
LAUNCH OF SCOOTER.
SHARE PROGRAMS ACROSS THE STREET
ACROSS THE STATE IN TWO THOUSAND
AND EIGHTEEN MANY LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS SUCH AS SAN
FRANCISCO RESPONDED TO PUBLIC
SAFETY CONCERNS.
AND INSTITUTE A REGULATIONS TO
GUIDE MOTORIZED MOTOR -- SHARED
SCOOTER PROGRAMS -- THIS CAME
ASKED AFTER MANY SAFETY CONCERNS
FROM OUR LOCAL RESIDENTS
REGARDING INJURED WRITERS AND
SCOOTERS LEFT IN THE PUBLIC
RIGHT OF WAY INHIBITING
PEDESTRIAN.
ACCESS AS WELL AS EDA ACCESS --
AS VERY SPECIFICALLY IN REGARDS
TO INJURED WRITERS SINCE THESE
PROGRAMS WERE AT SINCE THESE
GOOD OR SHARE PROGRAMS BECAME
AVAILABLE IN LATE.
TWO TWENTY SEVENTEEN OVER
FIFTEEN HUNDRED PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
INJURED AND A UCLA STUDY FOUND
TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY NINE
PEOPLE WHO REQUIRED MEDICAL CARE
WITH SEVERE INJURIES MANY OF
THOSE INCLUDING HEAD TRAUMA --
SFM TA ARE CREATED A POWERED
SCOOTER SHARE PERMIT AND PILOT
PROGRAM THAT ADDRESSES KEY
SAFETY CONSUMER PROTECTION AND
EQUITY CONCERNS WITH THIS NEW
MOBILITY SERVICE.
HOWEVER IF THIS BILL PASSES HE
WOULD NO LONGER BE ABLE TO
REQUIRE AND FORCED KEY
COMPONENTS OF OUR PROGRAM.
INCLUDING OUR AUTHORITY TO CITE
SCOOTERS LEFT IN THE PUBLIC
RIGHT OF WAY AND OUR ABILITY TO
REQUIRE COMPANIES TO PROVIDE LOW
INCOME PROGRAMS.
THE BILL ALSO INCLUDES LANGUAGE
THAT PROHIBITS AUTHORITIES FROM
IMPOSING ANY UNDULY RESTRICTIVE
REQUIREMENTS ON SHARED SCOOTER
OPERATORS WITHOUT DEFINING THIS
TERM OUTSIDE OF COST.
THIS AMBIGUITY CONCERNS AS AND
IT COULD IMPACT OUR ABILITY TO
ENFORCE KEY SAFETY IN EQUITY
ELEMENTS OF OUR PILOT PROGRAM.
LASTLY THE DATA PROVISIONS OF
THE BILL MAY PROHIBIT SHARING OF
ANY DATA WITH THE PUBLIC AND
WITH NO EXCEPTIONS FOR SHARING
AND ON A MAIS TRIP DATA PUBLIC
TRANSPARENCY WOULD BE NEGATIVELY
IMPACTED. FOR THESE REASONS WE
OPPOSE THIS MEASURE I'D ALSO
LIKE TO VOICE THE OPPOSITION ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SANTA
MONICA WHICH SHARES SIMILAR
CONCERNS AS THE S. SEVENTY EIGHT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THIS ONE IS PLEASE.
CITY ATTACK OR THE CONSUMER
TWENTY THE CALIFORNIAN
OPPOSITION WE AGREE WITH THE
AUTHOR'S INTENT TO TRY TO BRING
SOME REGULATIONS OF THESE THESE
SCOOTERS.
ARE THE SOLUTION IS PROBLEMATIC
I WON'T REPEAT THE ARGUMENTS
ALREADY MADE WITH A LINERS OF
THOSE ARGUMENTS AND ALSO ADD
THAT WE BELIEVE INSURANCE
REQUIREMENTS ARE TOO LOW.
AND THEY'RE FAR BELOW AND CITIES
LIKE SANTA SANTA MONICA SAN
FRANCISCO AND LOS ANGELES THANKS
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU.
SO MISTER NAZARIAN HOME BRING
BACK TO SINCE -- MY INTERRUPT
YOU APOLOGIZE NOT AT ALL NO
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- I I'VE
STRUGGLED WITH THIS BECAUSE AND
I APOLOGIZE I DIDN'T GET A
CHANCE TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT THIS
EARLIER ON THE FLOOR WHEN I
ACTUALLY.
HAD A MOMENT TO TO SIT WITH YOU --
I I'VE GENERALLY NOT SUPPORTED
BILLS THAT WOULD ALLOW CERTAIN
TYPES OF OF MODES OF
TRANSPORTATION.
IF WE DID NOT PLAY CERTAIN.
SAFEGUARDS TO MAKE SURE FOR
EXAMPLE HEAD GEAR AND OR OTHER
SAFETY PRECAUTIONS.
WERE PUT INTO PLACE SO -- YOU
SPEAK TO THAT IS THIS DOES WITH
THIS BILL I UNDERSTAND IT ALLOWS
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS. TO MOVE
FORWARD BUT WOULD WE HAVE AN
OVER.
ARCHING VIEW OF SAYING WELL
THESE ARE THE SAFETY STANDARDS.
THAT NEED TO BE ADDRESSED
BECAUSE I WASN'T EVEN SURE IF
ANYONE WAS GOING TO SPEAK TO IT
BUT I'M NOT SURPRISED ABOUT THE
HEAD TRAUMA INJURY.
THE BILL DOES ALLOW LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO DICTATE FOR
INSTANCE WERE SCOOTERS ARE
ALLOWED TO SO IT WOULD ALLOW
LOCAL JURISDICTION TO SAY YOU
CAN'T RIDE SCOOTERS ON THE
SIDEWALK YOU CAN ONLY BE A
PROTECTED LANES.
IT DOES GIVE A WIDE -- BIRTH TO
LOCALITIES TO HAVE THE SCOOTERS
WORK FOR THEIR COMMUNITIES AND
WAYS THAT THEY BELIEVE ARE SAFE
FOR PEOPLE -- SO WE TRY TO
REALLY BALANCE THE ABILITY FOR
LOCALITIES TO REGULATE SCOOTERS --
WITH YOU KNOW TRYING TO
ENCOURAGE THEM TO COME UP WITH
THOSE REGULATIONS BECAUSE A LOT
OF THEM JUST AREN'T AND THAT'S
PROBLEMATIC -- AND SORT OF JUST
SAYING YOU KNOW WHAT WE'RE NOT
GONNA HAVE ANY SCOOTERS IN OUR
COMMUNITY WHERE IT RIGHT YOU
KNOW YOU CAN REALLY HAVE.
PROBLEMS WITH -- YOU KNOW THE
THE SITUATION WHERE SOMEONE
RENTS A SCOOTER AND WON CITY AND
IS THE WRITING INTO THE NEXT ALL
OF A SUDDEN THINGS RADICALLY
CHANGE THE MACHINE JUST STOPS
WORKING ARE ALL OF A SUDDEN
YOU'RE NO IN AND FLAT OUT THE
LEGAL ENVIRONMENT WITHOUT ANY
NOTICE FOR THE USERS.
WE WANTED TO HAVE SOMETHING THAT
GAVE SOME BASIC FRAMEWORK BUT
STILL GAVE THE LOCALITIES A LOT
OF LEEWAY TO REGULATE.
I'M HOW THIS TUTORED SCOOTERS
ARE GOING TO WORK IN THEIR
COMMUNITY SO WE ARE AND WE'RE
CONTINUING TO DISCUSS.
THAT WITH THE LEAGUE OF CITIES
AND AND YOU KNOW WE'RE HAPPY TO
TALK WITH ANY OF THE CITIES THAT
HAVE CONCERNS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ALLOW.
THEM TO HAVE THE CAN SPLIT THE
SCOOTERS IN A WAY THAT'S
COMFORTABLE FOR THEM AND THAT
SAY FOR THE COMMUNITY -- BUT WE
NEED TO ALSO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE SOME ABILITY TO HAVE A
STATEWIDE REGULATION THE SAME
WAY THAT WE DO WITH BICYCLES AND
WITH CARS AND ANY OTHER VEHICLE
WHERE WE DON'T TO FOR A 100% TO
LOCALITIES WE HAVE SOME OVER
ARCHING -- REGULATORY FRAMEWORK
AND THEN THEY CAN OPERATE WITHIN
THAT SO THIS IS REALLY IT'S
ISN'T TO NEW TECHNOLOGY THAT'S
YOU KNOW BEING VERY QUICKLY AND
RAPIDLY.
DEPLOYED ACROSS THE STATE AND WE
THINK IT'S TIME FOR US AS A
STATE NOW TO STEP IN WAS SOME
JUST BASIC PARAMETERS AND THAT'S
WHAT THE BILL'S ATTEMPTING TO DO.
SO IT IS STILL A BIT OF A WORK
IN PROGRESS WE STILL HAVE YOU
KNOW TIME WE HAVE OTHER
COMMITTEES TO GO IN FRONT OF
WHERE I'M SURE THEY'LL HAVE
THEIR IDEAS SO.
YOU KNOW WE DO ASK -- I WOULD
ASK FOR KIND OF THE LEEWAY TO
LET US CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION
WITH EVERYBODY WE KNOW WE STILL
HAVE TO BRING IT TO THE FLOOR WE
KNOW HAVE WE HAVE TO GET IT TO
THE SENATE BUT I THINK IT'S TIME
FOR THE STATE TO START ACTING IN
A IN.
A STATEWIDE WAY TO HAVE SOME
CONSISTENCY ACROSS THE STATE
WITH THIS MODE OF TRANSPORTATION --
RESEARCHER.
THANK YOU.
EIGHT SO IF THERE'S WELL I GUESS
I SHOULD JUST IF I SHOULD JUST
ASK IF THERE'S NO BARE MINIMUM
SAFETY STANDARD.
I'M GOING TO WITHHOLD SUPPORTING
IT TODAY.
BUT CAN YOU SPEAK.
TO IS THERE ANYTHING THAT AT
LEAST REQUIRES A BARE MINIMUM
STANDARD OF SAFETY MEASURES.
BECAUSE YOU CAN IMAGINE WHAT IT
ISSUE THIS IS AND DENSE AREAS
AND I DON'T NEED TO SPEAK TO YOU
ABOUT DENSE AREAS YOU REPRESENT
A VERY DENSE AREA YOURSELF.
MISTREATMENT BUT IN MONDAY IN MY
DISTRICT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A
VERY SMALL.
NO LESS THAN TEN SQUARE MILES
AREA THAT HAS SEVERE DENSITY OF
JUST WHERE I LIVE.
WITHIN FIVE BLOCKS OF WHERE I MY
RESIDENCE IS WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
ABOUT FOUR THOUSAND NEW
APARTMENT UNITS COMING IN WITHIN
THE NEXT TWO HOURS LET ME JUST
SAY THAT THE THE MAN YOU'RE THE
MANUFACTURERS ARE UNDER FEDERAL
STANDARDS FOR SAFETY FOR THE
VEHICLE ITSELF AND THEN IN TERMS.
OF WHERE THEY'RE SAFE AND NOT
SAFE TO RIDE FOR INSTANCE OF
THEIR CERTAIN AREAS THAT ARE SO
DENSE THAT THERE'S JUST NO PLACE
FOR THEM.
UNDER A BILL THAT'S STILL IS UP
TO THE LOCALITY TO DETERMINE
WHERE THE SCOOTERS WE'RE GONNA
ARE GONNA BE ALLOWED SO WE'RE
NOT SET A STANDARD WELL THAT'S
UP TO EACH CITY TO SAY FOR
INSTANCE.
LOS ANGELES MIGHT VERY WELL OR A
SOME CITY MIGHT CHOOSE TO SAY WE
ONLY WANT THE SCOOTERS IN A
PROTECTED.
ENVIRONMENT -- WE ONLY WANT THE
SCOOTERS ON CERTAIN TYPES OF
STREETS AND THEY'RE FREE TO DO
THAT THAT'S RIGHT THINK THE
STATE SHOULDN'T COMMENTS AND TRY
TO TELL CITIES EXACTLY WHERE AND
WHERE NOT.
IN THEIR COMMUNITY THEIR SAFE
JUST THE WAY WE DON'T WITH
BICYCLE WITH -- YOU KNOW WHERE
WE DON'T DEMAND THAT CITIES.
CREATE PROTECTED BY CLAIMS LET'S
SAY ON CERTAIN STREETS WE LEAVE
IT UP TO THEM TO DO THAT AND I
THINK IT'S UP TO EACH
MUNICIPALITY TO SAY.
HEY THERE'S A LOT OF SCOOTER
INTEREST IN MY CITY I BETTER SET
UP SOME SAFE PLACE FOR PEOPLE TO
RIDE AND I THINK THAT'S THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE CITY TO
TAKE A LOOK AT THEIR COMMUNITY.
THERE'S A LOT OF YOUNG PEOPLE
THERE'S A LOT OF YOU KNOW PEOPLE
WHO ARE DISSIDENTS SCOOTERS THE
CITY SHOULD INSTALL SAFE PLACES
FOR THOSE SCOOTERS BECAUSE
OTHERWISE THEY ARE GOING TO END
UP WITH SCOOTERS.
YOU KNOW ON THE STREET UNSAFE
CONDITIONS SO I THINK IT'S
REALLY UP TO THOSE LOCALITIES TO
LOOK AT THEIR CONSTITUENCY.
YOU KNOW IN SOME CITIES THEIR
BABY THERE ARE A LOT OF SCOOTERS
RAINY SCOOTER SO I WOULDN'T
FORCE THEM TO GO AHEAD AND DO SO
YOU KNOW PROTECTED SCOOTER LANES
BUT OTHER CITIES PROBABLY SHOULD
DO THAT AND I THINK THAT THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT MAYBE IS BEST.
CITY TO CITY BUT IN TERMS OF THE
THE DEVICES THEMSELVES THERE
CERTAINLY ARE MANDATES AS TO YOU
KNOW SAFETY FOR THEM AND I THINK
WE'LL SEE THAT INCREASING AT ALL
AT THAT.
FOLKS YOU KNOW ONE OF MY
WITNESSES TESTIFY -- SO THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION SIR.
I'D SAY A COUPLE THINGS --
NUMBER ONE IN.
IN OUR IN APP -- FEATURES WHEN
YOU OPEN UP THE THE BIRD OUT FOR
THE FIRST TIME -- AMONGST THE
MANY THINGS THAT YOU GO THROUGH
IT AS AN ATTESTATION INCLUDING --
A TESTING THAT YOU ARE EIGHTEEN
YEARS OF AGE OR OLDER OLDER --
WE TALK THROUGH THE DON'T KNOW
NO WRITING ON SIDEWALKS OPTION
WE ALSO MAKE SURE THAT WE
DECLARED -- THAT HELMET USE IS
DEFINITELY THE PREFERRED OPTION --
WE DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY.
TO CALL MANDATE THAT -- BUT WE
CERTAINLY -- PREFER THAT PEOPLE
WEAR HELMETS -- SECONDLY -- TO
THE ASSEMBLYMEMBERS POINTS OUT
WE HAVE SOMETHING CALLED A GEO
FENCING SO FOR EXAMPLE ON SANTA
MONICA BIKE -- BEACH BIKE PATH --
WERE ABLE TO GEO SPEED -- THE
SCOOTER DOWN THE BIRD DOWN TO
ABOUT I THINK NOW WE'RE WE'RE
GOING ABOUT THREE MILES AN HOUR --
IN THAT AREA THEY'RE ALSO AREAS
LIKE IN A SCOTTSDALE ARIZONA FOR
EXAMPLE I JUST WAS RECENTLY --
WE'VE GEO FENCE AROUND A A DENSE
AREA THAT -- HAS A LOT OF
PEDESTRIAN FOOT TRAFFIC -- SO
THAT WE EITHER -- SLOWLY MOVE
THE VEHICLE TO ZERO MILES PER
HOUR WE MAKE SURE THAT THE
PREFERRED PARKING AREAS ARE
OUTSIDE OF THAT TESTIFIED.
AREA SO THERE'S A LOT OF SAFETY
PRECAUTIONS THAT WE'VE TAKEN --
BOTH AS A COMPANY AND AND WIDELY
IN THE INDUSTRY TO ADDRESS THOSE
KINDS OF SITUATIONS.
AND ARE ALSO ALLOWS LOCALITIES
TO REQUIRE THE GEO FENCING FROM
SINCE.
SO THEY CAN STILL DO THAT.
THANKS.
MR O'DONNELL.
YES THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THE
BILL WAS FRIEDMAN ALWAYS SAY.
THE SKATEBOARDING IS NOT A CRIME
SCOOTER IS NOT A CRIME AS WELL.
OF I JUST A QUESTION FOR YOU
GENERAL MAYBE YOU CAN.
RESPOND TO THIS WHAT A SCOOTER
FALLS OVER -- IS IT DETECTED
SOMEWHERE SUCH THAT THEY CAN
RESPOND TO THAT SCOOTER FIRST
AND PICK IT UP IS I HAVE TO SAY
THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS I
ACTUALLY HAVE A CD CONCERNED
ABOUT WHEN I GO AROUND THE
COMMUNITY.
I SEE A SKINNER THE SCOOTER.
NOT A SKINNER -- I'VE SEEN THAT
BUT A SCOOTER LAYING SIDEWAYS
BUT DID THIS SOMETHING HAPPEN
UNIQUE WHEN THERE IS A STATE
IT'S DETECTED IF IT EVEN IS
DETECTED.
YEAH YES YEAH THERE'S A
TELEMETRY DEVICE WITH AND EACH
OF THE SCOOTERS THAT ALLOWS YOU
TO KNOW WHETHER IT'S VERTICAL OR
HORIZONTAL.
AND IN MOST AND WHAT WE DO WITH
CITIES GENERALLY AS WE HAVE AN
SLA OR A SERVICE LEVEL AGREEMENT
IN PLACE SO THERE'S A CERTAIN
NUMBER OF MINUTES OR HOURS OR
WHATNOT. FOR OUR WE CALL BIRD
WATCHERS PUN INTENDED -- TO GO
OUT AND ACTUALLY ADDRESS THE
CLUTTER ISSUES SO WE'VE DONE A
LOT OF WORK AND OUR TWELVE
MONTHS OF ACTUAL OPERATION IN
CITIES AND ARE SEVENTEEN MONTHS
OF ACTUAL EXISTENCE OF THE
COMPANY. TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
MEETING THE NEEDS OF CITIES AS
BEST WE CAN AND AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE.
SO CITY AND ITS AGREEMENT.
CORRECT COULD -- DESIGN AN
ELEMENT WHERE AND WHEN THE
SCOOTERS LAYING ON SITE.
IT WOULD BE PICKED UP SOONER.
THEN MAYBE OTHERS SO -- SURE.
YES SO WE HAVE WE HAVE BIRD
WATCHERS WHO ARE CONSTANTLY
MOVING AROUND CITIES TO ENSURE
THAT -- AS WE CALL IT NESTING
THAT THE BIRDS ARE PLACED
APPROPRIATELY LIKE I SAID THE
PONDS WRITER CAME AGAIN MY
QUESTION SPECIFIC TO ONE'S ONE'S
GOING ON INSIDE IRAQ.
THAT'S WHEN I WAS DOWN IN SAN
DIEGO LAST WEEK AND THERE WAS A
COUPLE OF OUT THERE IN THE
MARINO LAND ON THEIR SIDE AND IN
THE SIDEWALK AREA.
SO AGAIN.
DOES IT DOES IT IS IS A TYPE OF
OTHER CITY WOULD ASK THAT A
SCOOTER LAYING ON ITS SIDE HE
RESPONDED -- TO IN IN A HIGHER
PRIORITY THAN ONE THAT IS NOT.
YES SO AGAIN WE HAVE THAT
TORTURE DEVICES SO THAT WE KNOW
WRITING.
IS LAYING DOWN OUR CITIES AND
REQUESTING THAT THOSE.
YES THAT THE PART OF IT THAT'S
PART OF THIS THE SERVICE WILL
AGREEMENT BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY
DEPENDING ON THE SIZE OF A CITY --
IT DOES TAKE SOME TIME TO GET
PEOPLE TO THAT PARTICULAR
UNDERSTAND THAT.
BUT IT IS A TYPICAL CITY.
ACTOR ASKED THAT THAT BE A
PRIORITY.
THAT THIS.
SAY THAT IN MOST CASES CITIES
MAKE SURE THAT SIDEWALK CLUTTER.
EIGHTY A ACTION I ANSWER MY
QUESTION SO.
AGAIN WITH THE SERVICE AGREEMENT.
DO CITIES ASK BIRD WHOMEVER IT
MAY BE TO THE ASSET SCOOTERS
LAYING ON THEIR SIDE MAYBE IN A
SIDEWALK.
BE PICKED UP AT A HIGHER
PRIORITY IN THOSE THAT ARE NOT.
LINE ON THEIR SIDE I HAVE YOU
KNOW IF YOU DON'T KNOW THAT IT'S
OKAY I HAVEN'T SEEN THAT
SPECIFIC.
REQUEST BUT I HAVE SEEN THE
ISSUE OF SIDELINING THAT'S
CITIES NEEDED YOU KNOW I THINK
THAT'S YOU KNOW YOU ON EXPECT
THAT THEY DO THAT BECAUSE I
THINK THAT'S THE BIGGEST.
DOWNSIDE TO THE MY SCOOTER
EXPERIENCE AND FROM WHAT I'M
HEARING FROM MY COMMUNITY IS
WHEN THEY BECOME A SAFETY HAZARD
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YEAH THE QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
MS FREEMAN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
FINALLY CLOSE.
I APPRECIATE THE QUESTIONS AND I
THINK ALL OF US HAVE SEEN THIS.
VERY RAPID GROWTH IN SCOOTERS
AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
WE TAKE THE STEP NOW TO START
WITH A STATEWIDE FRAMEWORK AND
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOU
KNOW ALL ALL OF THE FOLKS THAT
HAVE CONCERNS AND TRY TO GET TO
SOMETHING THAT'S YOU KNOW
WORKABLE AND WITH ALL.
OF OUR CITIES I KNOW THAT I
REQUEST AND I BOTH.
THANK YOU SOME REMEMBER FRIEDMAN --
SURE YOUR INTEREST ENSURING.
HI ENSURING SHARES SCOOTERS ARE
BEING FAIRLY IN ADEQUATELY
REGULATED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
WHERE IT SHOULD BE CAN YOU COME
FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
I HOPE YOU'RE ABLE TO RECONCILE
YOUR BILL WITH YOUR INTENT
MOVING FORWARD.
I WILL BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL.
BUT I DO HAVE.
THE SAME CONCERNS THAT -- MISTER
O'DONNELL AND DOES IT THE THEIR
STEWARDS OF THEIR OWN -- MESSES
AT TIMES.
AND SO WITH THAT OLD.
CALL THE WE HAVE A FIRST MR
DAILY SECOND BY MISTER GRAYSON --
BUT SECRETARY CULTURAL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO PRIVACY
AND CONSUMER PROTECTION FRAZIER
AYE FRAZIER AYE FONG.
FONG I AGUIAR-CURRY.
I I BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NOT VOTING QUEUE.
CHIU AYE AYE CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
IN HIM NO DAILY OUR DAILY I DEEP.
DEEP I FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE MEDINA.
DEAN I IN THIS AREA.
IS THERE ARE NOT VOTING
O'DONNELL.
AYE O'DONNELL AYE.
THANK YOU ALL.
THANK YOU.
THAT IS TWELVE WE ROLLED IN
FRANCE MEMBERS -- MADAM
SECRETARY LISCO SINCE WE HAVE SO
MANY MEMBERS HERE RIGHT NOW --
MELISSA CALLS AND IF YOU WANT TO
GO THROUGH THE PROCESS.
I WOULD MUCH APPRECIATE.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR TI<c.cyan>.</c>
SURE I FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE MEDINA -- MEDINA AYE
NAZARIAN.
THIS AREA.
ITEM NUMBER ONE AB ONE SEVENTY
NINE REYES TO PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN
[inaudible]
BERMAN IQ.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I FRIEDMAN.
AB ONE SEVENTY NINE RAY IS
NUMBER.
ONE FRIEDMAN I MEDINA.
THE AND I IN THIS AREA
[inaudible]
NAZARIAN AYE.
THAT MEASURE HAS FIFTEEN VOTE.
THAT MEASURE HAS FOURTEEN BUT
NUMBER THREE AB THREE TWENTY TWO
THIRTY EIGHT THE MOTION --
SANTIAGO DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS [inaudible]
AND BERMAN [inaudible]
BERMAN I CHIP REID CHIU AYE
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I FRIEDMAN
[inaudible]
FRIEDMAN I MEDINA.
MEDINA I IS THERE IN.
IS THERE AN AYE.
THAT MEASURE HAS FIFTEEN VOTE.
NUMBER SIX AB FIVE SIXTEEN CHIU
THE MOTION IS TO PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN.
BERMAN I CHU.
CHU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN HI MEDINA.
WE DO NOT VOTING IS THERE IN.
AB FIVE SIXTEEN ITEM NUMBER --
SIX SYRIAN I THAT MEASURE HAS
TWELVE VOTES.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN A. B. SEVEN
THIRTY FIVE THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN.
BERMAN NOT VOTING QUEUE.
CHIU NOT VOTING [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN NO.
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON NO MEDINA.
MEDINA NOT VOTING NAZARIAN --
NAZARIAN KNOW.
THAT MEASURE HAS FOUR EYES
EIGHT
EIGHTY SEVEN FIFTY TWO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GABRIEL THE MOTION IS TO
PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN.
BERMAN I CHIU.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
AM I FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I AM MEDINA.
MEDINA I AND IS THERE IN.
THIS AREA AND I O'DONNELL
[inaudible]
O'DONNELL I THAT MEASURE HAS
FIFTEEN EYES.
ITEM NUMBER NINE AB SEVEN FIFTY
THREE EDUARDO GARCIA THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NO FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN NOT VOTING MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN I THAT MEASURE HAS
ELEVEN ICE.
ITEM NUMBER TEN AB EIGHT OH
EIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER TI<c.cyan>.</c>
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL NOT VOTING THAT
MEASURE HAS THREE EYES
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
THE MISS CHOOSE WHAT I REQUEST
READ.
RECONSIDERATION WE HAVE --
GRANTED WITHOUT PREJUDICE.
I AM ELEVEN A. B. NINE SEVENTY
OR SIMPLY MEMBER SALAS THE
MOTION IS TO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
BERMAN.
BERMAN I CHIU.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN NO MEDINA.
MEDINA INEZ ARIAN -- THE SYRIAN
NOT VOTING.
YES.
IS THERE ENOUGH VOTING TO I THAT
MEASURE HAS FOURTEEN EYES.
THAT IS FOURTEEN BILLS OUT.
AT NUMBER TWELVE AB TEN TWENTY
FIVE GRAYSON THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN.
BERMAN I CHIU -- I CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I AM MEDINA.
DEAN I IN THIS AREA.
JERRY AND I O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I FIFTY THAT IS.
FIFTEEN THAT BILLS OUT.
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN AB TEN
FORTY SIX BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TING THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CHIU.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NO DEEP.
DEEP KNOWN FRIEDMAN.
HI FRIEDMAN I GRAYSON.
GRAYSON NOT VOTING MEDINA
[inaudible]
MEDINA I THAT IS A STELLAR BILLS
OUT.
THE ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN AB
ELEVEN TWELVE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN.
THAT MEASURE HAS TWELVE EYES.
THAT HAS TWELVE APPETIZERS --
IT'S OUT.
ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN AB ONE TWO
TWO SIX BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOLDEN THE MOTION IS TO PASSED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I TO KNOW
[inaudible]
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE [inaudible]
LEVEL [inaudible]
THIS [inaudible]
IS [inaudible]
BERMAN I THE BILL HAS TWELVE OF
LOS ITSELF.
ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN AB ONE TWO
TWO SIX BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ROBERT RIVAS EMOTION IS DUE
PASSED. TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CHIU.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I DEEP.
DEEP I FRIEDMAN. TWO SIX SIX ONE
TWO SIX SIX AB ONE TWO SIX SIX
FRIEDMAN I MEDINA [inaudible]
MEDIAN I THE BILL HAS TWELVE LOS
IT'S OUT.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN A. B.
THIRTEEN TWENTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JONES SAWYER THE MOTION
IS TO PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CHU.
CHU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN HI MEDINA.
MEDINA HI O'DONNELL [inaudible]
O'DONNELL I THAT IS.
FIFTEEN ANGLES OUT.
ITEM NUMBER NINE AB THIRTEEN
FIFTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LACKEY THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I O'DONNELL
[inaudible]
O'DONNELL I IT IS THE BILL HAS
FIFTEEN THOSE WHO IS OUT.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY ONE AB
FOURTEEN OH SIX BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER O'DONNELL THE MOTION IS
TO PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN.
BERMAN I CHIU.
CHIU AYE FRIEDMAN.
MEDINA -- MEDINA I AND IS THERE
IN [inaudible]
YES.
IS THERE AN AYE.
THE BILL HAS THIRTEEN VOTES.
IT IS OUT.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY THREE A. B.
FOURTEEN EIGHTEEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TO THE MOTION IS TO
PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
UTILITIES AND ENERGY. TO CHIU
AYE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON OF GIPSON
THOUGHT GIPSON WAS AND I MEDINA --
TWENTY NINE IS THERE IN
[inaudible]
I YEAH.
YEAH I AGREE.
THE BILL HAS TWELVE LOOSE IT IS
OUT.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB ONE FOUR
FIVE SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAY AS THE MOTION IS TO PASSED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN.
BERMAN I CHU.
CHU AYE FRIEDMAN.
I MEDINA.
MEDINA I IN THIS AREA.
THIS AREA AND I THE BILL HAS
TWELVE THOSE IT IS OUT.
AB FIFTEEN EIGHTY NINE ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS CHIU
[inaudible]
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN NO MEDINA.
MEDINA I AM IS THERE IN -- THE
BILL HAS TEN VOTES IT IS OUT.
SIXTEEN OH FIVE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TING THE MOTION IS TO
PASS CHIU.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NO DEEP [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN.
ADMIN I GRAYSON.
HI.
GRAYSON AYE O'DONNELL
[inaudible]
O'DONNELL I MEDINA [inaudible]
MEDINA I THE BILL HAS ELEVEN IS
OUT.
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY AB SIXTEEN
EIGHTEEN THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS [inaudible]
HELLO [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I FRIEDMAN.
ADMIN AYE MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE O'DONNELL
[inaudible]
O'DONNELL AYE.
THE BILL HAS TWELVE LOS IS OUT.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB.
SEVEN THIRTY FIVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAYSON.
NOT WORKING NOT LOADING
[inaudible]
THE BILL ONLY HAD FOUR VOTES --
THE GRANT RECONSIDERATION
WITHOUT PREJUDICE.
LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS FOR THE
ASSEMBLY TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE IS NOW COMPLETE THIS
HEARING IS ADJOURNED